Moin, ich habe nichts besseres zu tun heute vormittag wobei vormittag ist ja nicht mehr
außer meinen zweiten chart zu leveln
habe ich mir gedacht ich mache einfach mal strieb an auch wenn es die meisten wahrscheinlich
absolut gar nicht juckt
Ich bin noch ein bisschen erkältet weiß nicht
was da los ist
was auch immer
Moin
mal kurz chat auf
Moin, heute gibt es sinnlos kreisel grind
aber nicht mit dem chart hier
Ich hoffe dass plörn vom chat funktioniert ganz brauchbar
homeoffice stream
wie gesagt sinnlos mmo kreisel grind
Ich habe
ein chart gelevelt
Jetzt level ich meinen scalde weiter den habe ich ja auch season one gespielt hauptsächlich
sodass ich zweigleisig aufgestellt bin dass ich spielen kann was gerade gerade passt und ich dachte mir hast du was
aber einfach stream an
ich sage euch gleich das wird langweilig dark pv ist
alles ich glaube zum zuschauen
eines der langweiligsten sachen die es überhaupt gibt ja
Dementsprechend gibt es auch entspannte
10 stunden fantasy
ambient music im hintergrund ich hoffe die lautstärke passt ganz gut
und
ich werde jetzt erst mal mein
zweiter
aber nicht den hier nicht den jahr
schätzt sollte man hoffentlich nicht lesen können weil das ist gegen die serverregeln
genau
also soll ich sagen
vielleicht falls schon jemand da ist das spiel nicht kennt wovon ich ausgehe ich meine das ist 20 jahre alt
das kam 2001 oder 2 jahre später, ne?
oder so raus das ist dark edge of camelot das beste pvp mmo was hier gemacht wurde weiß werden
sich dann die eso leute und die guild wars leute und so streiten sich wieder aber ja für mich das
beste pvp mmo was hier gemacht wurde ich hoffe die game lautstärke und so passt auch alles und
da ist vor am dienstag am samstag am samstag am samstag ist die zweite season auf dem edon
free start gestartet in ihrer website ist bisschen pp aber okay könnte auch am dark
wieder liegen naja ist ein bisschen besser und ich spiele einmal im jahr immer so zwei drei
vier monate je nachdem wie wie lange die season so so gut läuft gut geht spiele ich immer zwei
drei vier monate
spiele ich immer im jahr noch so dark meistens auf dem free start die live server die live server
kann man ja im endeffekt vergessen da habe ich auch gar keinen bock drauf da sind auch die ganzen
klassen nicht wieder zu erkennen was bei gamigo gearbeitet ok gamigo hat er nicht unbedingt den
besten ruf gehabt so das ist ein pre world of warcraft game ja und nicht wundern dass ich ein
bisschen schnupfen habe so hört sich ist nicht schlimm aber ja deswegen mir ist heute auch nicht
so fair wie gesagt
der katze geht es ja auch nicht gut deswegen ml mit nicht so sehr danach irgendwie großen
highq sachen zu machen ich level an 2 wir müssen jetzt noch mal eine sache checken recess und zwar
ob die helligkeit ok ist weil das spiel kann in danach relativ dunkel werden also ich glaube ich
muss erstmal ein bisschen für mich die helligkeit hoch drehen aber das seht ihr ja nicht gerne nicht
dass hier ändert dass sie sehen wir ich müssen wir mal schauen richtig krasser kreise Wine müssen wir mal schauen ich hoffe ich habe das Kapitel ganz gut gemacht das ..
hoffe, ich hoffe, Vodafone
macht mit. Ich werde spielen
bis heute Abend.
Ich werde spielen, soweit ich komme
und dann spätestens am Wochenende auch
den Char 50 machen.
Aber scheint zu funktionieren.
Und heute Abend machen wir
vielleicht tatsächlich noch eine Runde normalen
Stream und gucken uns Dockge an.
Ja.
Genau. Also, falls
einer Bock hat, mal Oldschool-MMO
zu spielen,
der muss erstmal mit der Grafik klarkommen.
Das ist noch eine der
schöneren Ecken hier im Spiel. Ich lock mal auf
den Char um, den ich eigentlich spielen will jetzt.
Wir spielen, ich spiele den gleichen
Char weiter, den ich auch Season 1 gespielt
habe. Nur, dass er resetet
wurde für Season 2.
Wie gesagt, die Grafik
muss man erstmal klar mitkommen, wenn man
selbst wenn man Bock hat, sich ältere Games
anzugucken. Also, die
Grafics
sieht man
halt schon. Die Grafics sind jetzt halt schon
ein bisschen 2001. Aber das Spiel ist halt
auch von 2001.
Aber zum Glück sieht man seine Charts nie so groß.
Oh, fuck. Jetzt wird das Game crashen gleich.
Ne, wird nicht.
Und was wichtig ist,
hier, Reshade.
Reshade anmachen. Weil, guckt mal,
vielleicht fällt euch das auf,
das Game ist halt
auch ein bisschen unscharf so.
Guckt mal, guckt euch mal die Namen an
und guckt euch mal hier die ganzen Sachen an.
Und, also ich mach mal aus
wieder die Grafik-Enhancing.
Sieht halt schon ein bisschen
plass aus und ein bisschen,
mach mal die Lampe an und nicht so farbenfroh
und ein bisschen verschwommen.
Was aber auch daran liegt,
dass das Game halt
noch für CRT-Monitore entwickelt wurde
und auf CRT-Monitoren sah das
deutlich farbenfroher aus
als jetzt auf aktuellen Monitoren.
So, und deswegen
mach ich Reshade an
und mit Reshade
sieht das deutlich mehr aus
wie man das auch noch von CRTs
in
EC-Quid
keine Gilde mehr.
Die Leute haben keinen Bock mehr.
Bist du deiner Zeitschleier?
Ja, schon.
So, wo sind wir hier überhaupt?
Ist die Musik eigentlich okay?
Die Musik ist ein bisschen lauter.
Ein bisschen lautes Fantasy-Gedudel im Hintergrund.
Mein Problem ist
hier
auf 80 runter.
Relaxing
Medieval Fantasy
Music Ambience
Ich glaub, passt eigentlich ganz gut.
Die Dark-Background-Musik ist auch gar nicht
so schlecht entspannend.
So, ich bin Level 1 wieder.
Letzte Season war ich mit dem
Char... Oh geil, jetzt steck ich den Boden drin.
Letzte Season war ich
mit dem... Besser Name auch.
Mit dem Season war ich
RR6. Das ist nicht sonderlich gut.
Ich hab auch die letzte Season nicht so lange gespielt.
Was daran lag,
weil irgendwie meine ganzen Guild-Mails
keinen Bock mehr hatten nach...
kurzer Zeit.
Ich war gestern... Ich war, glaub ich, 6L8 oder sowas.
Und da hatte ich keinen Bock mehr.
Weiß nicht, sieht man das hier vielleicht?
Irgendwo?
Ne, sieht man, glaub ich, erst später.
Es wurde ja alles...
Resettet. Ja, sieht nur noch den Titel.
Gibt noch nicht.
Wurde alles resettet.
Genau. Ich muss jetzt mal kurz in Char-Planer reingucken.
Wie man das...
Wie ich das am besten mache für...
ab Level 10. Lass mal kurz gucken.
Weil ich brauch immer Speed
und ich brauch immer
halbwegs einen ordentlichen Style.
Okay, Battle Songs.
Max Level. Muss sein.
Ach, Water Breathing gibt's schon auf Level 10?
Wusste ich gar nicht. Nice.
Dann muss ich mir um Tränke
keine Sorgen machen.
Das ist sehr nice.
Mir war gar nicht bewusst,
dass es das schon auf Level 10 gab.
Ich dachte eigentlich,
dass das später erst...
kam. Aber okay.
Ich will mich mal...
Ich will mich nicht beschweren.
Ah, das ist bloß,
wie schnell man unter Wasser ist.
Ja, gut.
Und dann brauchen wir irgendeinen halbwegs gescheiten Style.
Irgendwie sowas. Ja, das ist gut.
Peilen wir mal an mit Level 11.
Irgendwie sowas.
Oder nee, machen wir nicht.
Wir machen nicht Hammer. Wir machen Schwert.
Da gibt's den Town of Level 6.
Ah.
Ah, ist okay.
So, machen wir das am Anfang erstmal.
Ja, Leute. Das ist Dark Age of Camelot.
Ein MMO pre World of Warcraft Ära.
Und für mich das beste PvP-Spiel,
das es gibt.
Nachdem ich den Char schon in Season 1 gespielt hab,
das ist privater Server.
Privater Server.
Da sieht man ja auch, dass da ordentlich was los ist.
Aktuell sind 344 Spieler online
in Midgard.
Und in Hip und Alp
ist auch ungefähr ähnlich.
Und es ist früh.
Also ich würde...
Ich würde sagen...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die Spielerzahlen veröffentlichen.
Die hatten doch hier sowas.
Die hatten doch Spielerzahlen-Statistiken
irgendwo, oder?
Stats?
Server Population.
Nee, die haben keine...
Performance, Performance...
Ah, die haben keine Server...
Also ich glaube, abends sind so 3.000, 3.500 Leute
vielleicht on.
Das ist tatsächlich relativ viel, ja.
Aber das liegt auch daran,
das ist der einzige Free-Show-Programm, der wir haben.
Das ist der einzige Free-Show-Programm, der wir haben.
Das ist der einzige Free-Show-Programm, den es zurzeit gibt.
Und die offiziellen Server will keiner mehr spielen.
Die offiziellen Server haben...
Hallo?
Die offiziellen Server haben, glaube ich,
irgendwie 200 Spieler gesamt oder so abends.
Aber das liegt auch daran,
weil gerade Season 2 gestartet ist am Dienstag.
Äh, nicht am Dienstag, am Samstag.
Am Samstag ist Season 2 gestartet.
Und die haben saumäßig viel gemacht.
Also eins muss man ohne Scheiß sagen,
die Eden-Leute, die kümmern sich viel, viel besser um das Game als...
Äh, wie heißen sie?
Broadsword, glaube ich, die offiziellen Server-Betreiber jetzt.
Warum ist das Game so gut?
Weil Best Game Ever...
Fragt mal den Mitglied BG-Lieder,
dann wird er das ins Ohr schreien,
dass es Best Game Ever ist.
Warum das Game so gut ist?
Also das werdet ihr heute wahrscheinlich nur ansatzweise sehen,
weil wir spielen heute zum größten Teil Leveln.
Ich bin Level 1.
Ich bin gerade immer...
...im Tutorial-Gebiet.
Also, das Beste an dem Game ist tatsächlich das PvP.
Solo, Gruppe, Duo, Trio, vollkommen egal.
PvP ist eigentlich...
Also, das ist das Game, wo sogar Casuals gerne PvP gespielt haben.
Das hat, glaube ich, kein anderes Game irgendwie geschafft.
So, wir machen jetzt kurz das Tutorial durch bis Level 10.
Und dann machen wir mega langweilige Kill-Quests.
Eventuell, eventuell gehe ich auch in Battleground
und sammle 1, 2 RPs,
dass ich schneller sprinten,
oder nicht schneller sprinten, ist falsch,
länger Ausdauer zum Sprinten sammeln kann.
Ja.
Tutorial-Quests, easy as fuck.
Man rennt hier hin, killt ein paar Schweine.
So wie das im Prinzip...
Alle Leute, alle MMOs fangen doch an mit
Kille 5 Schweine oder Kille 5 Ratten oder sowas.
Alle, oder?
Ja.
Ich habe übrigens auch die alten Models.
Dementsprechend sieht das auch nochmal so richtig schlecht aus.
So, wir können mal gleich gucken, dass wir Leute...
Ich invite den Ludmar.
Weil...
Gucken wir mal, ob er Bock hat.
Will er nicht?
Weil, das ist gar nicht schlecht, wenn man Leute invite hat.
Dann kriegt man schneller Quests.
Aber gut, wenn er keinen Bock hat, dann nicht.
Es ist überall sinnlos, es ist sinnlos, Mob-Gebäsche.
Oh, shit.
Ich kann keine gelben killen.
Okay.
Oh, ich muss meinen...
Ich muss meinen Chat ein bisschen verkleinern, ne?
Guckt er...
Guckt...
Alter!
Seriously!
Alter, was ist mit den Wachen los, Mann?
Ich werde von der fucking Level 1 Wildsau gebasht, Mann.
Wachen, please.
Die haben keinen Bock.
Die wollen nicht.
Die haben einfach...
Okay, jetzt.
Jetzt.
Will...
Will zauern ab.
Geil.
Beste.
So.
Ich muss den Chat mal kurz ein bisschen kleiner machen.
Mal kurz schauen, dass das so passt.
Ob es so ist gut.
Ja.
Alles geblucht.
Das schieben wir mal dahin.
Moin, Dr. Chaos.
So, also.
Gelbe Mobs sind zu...
Zu hart für mich, wie es aussieht.
Also, in Dago ist das so.
Und erstmal hier kryptische...
Set camera.
Ja.
Erstmal kryptische Shell-Befehle, weil...
Oldschool-MMO.
Übrigens, für Leute, die es früher gespielt haben, Lampe an ist kein Noob-Signal mehr.
Die haben das auf Eden geändert, dass die Lampe man nur selbst sieht und die anderen nicht.
Im Main-Game war das früher so, wenn man die Lampe im Dunkeln angemacht hat,
dann haben einen quasi die Gegner gefühlt über die halbe Map gesehen.
Deswegen hat man nie Lampe angemacht.
Aber jetzt kann man Lampe anmachen.
Ich habe auch Gamma ein bisschen hochgedreht.
Sollte eigentlich alles...
Soweit passen.
Ja.
Und auf die Frage hin, warum das best Game ever ist...
Oh, ich muss reinleachen.
Ich muss reinleachen.
Reinleachen.
Bam.
Auf.
Hau drauf, Kollege.
Hau drauf.
Du kannst nicht casten, während dich der Mob hittet.
Wir machen den Fehler und wollen...
Nice.
Cakeweight.
Ja.
Auf die Frage hin, warum das das beste...
Das beste MMO ist.
Ganz einfach.
So, wartet mal kurz.
Wir müssen mal kurz den Blur...
Filter...
Ich mache einfach mal ein Chat ein Stückchen größer.
Du hast die Faszien als beste.
Ein Stückchen größer hier unten.
Ja, genau.
Hau drauf und lass mich mitbashen.
Easy.
Ja, Fabian.
Den habe ich schon versucht zu überreden.
Vielleicht am Wochenende, ja.
Mal gucken.
Ich sollte die Dudes inviten.
Ja.
Weil es ist deutlich...
Es ist deutlich einfacher mit mehreren Leuten.
Aber der will nicht, oder?
Es ist deutlich einfacher, wenn man das mit mehreren Leuten macht, ja.
Guck.
So, fertig.
Nice.
Ja, mal gucken, ob der Fabian will.
Also...
Es ist so...
Ich muss ab und zu mal ein bisschen in den Chat gucken.
Äh, wo sind wir denn hier?
Also es ist so...
Das Game hat...
Das...
Wie soll ich das erklären, wenn man das nicht kennt?
Du hast eigentlich grundsätzlich zwei verschiedene Reiche in dem Game.
Du hast quasi...
Also es gibt...
Es gibt...
Neue Quests annehmen.
Es gibt drei verschiedene Reiche.
Also die Story ist wurscht, ne?
Drei verschiedene Reiche im Krieg miteinander.
Bla, bla, bla.
Moment.
Oh.
Wir müssen noch mal kurz eine Wildsau hauen.
Und...
Man kann sich am Anfang...
Man kann sich am Anfang raussuchen, in welchem Reich man spielen will.
Ich hab, äh...
Chars in Albion und Midgard.
Das wird jetzt mein...
Den hab ich hauptsächlich...
Den hab ich gespielt die erste Season.
Und, ähm...
Ich hab mir jetzt noch ein Alb gelevelt.
Und jetzt hier noch ein Midgard.
Und es gibt quasi...
Eine Grenzfestung in jedem Bereich.
Alles dahinter ist PvP-Gebiet.
Und alles davor ist...
Ah, Spider-Skill.
Und alles davor...
Ist PvP-Gebiet.
Wobei das tatsächlich...
Äh...
Etwas...
Etwas schwammig ist.
Die...
Die Definition, weil es gibt auch so ein paar Hybrid-Gebiete.
Es gibt zum Beispiel einen PvP-Dungeon.
Der ist zugänglich für alle Reiche, potenziell.
Und da macht man PvP und PvE gegen Monster.
Und es gibt...
Also es...
Es ist nicht so klar zu sagen, ja.
Und im Endeffekt, ich kann euch ja mal kurz die...
Die Grenz...
Vom Grenzgebiet die Map zeigen.
Jedes der Reiche hat quasi ein Grenzgebiet.
Mit Festungen und Türmen.
Die können erobert werden.
Aktuell sieht man, die Albs kriegen auf den Sack.
Wie immer.
Wie auf jedem Server.
Gefühlt zumindest am Anfang.
Die haben quasi nur noch die Hälfte ihrer Festungen.
Und was passiert, wenn man die Festungen verliert?
Ist folgendes.
Slash Relic.
Also ganz, ganz kurz.
Grobe Übersicht, ja.
Jedes Reich hat zwei Relikte.
Ein Stärke-Relikt und ein Magie-Relikt.
Das bringt, glaube ich, 10% Schaden.
Nahkampf, 10% Schaden.
Magic, Damage.
Und das kann man, wenn man die...
Wenn man die...
Die Festung erobert.
Von dem gegnerischen Reich.
Dann kann man...
Zur Relikt-Festung das Relikt klauen.
Und dann kriegt man halt selbst die 10%.
Die 10% Damage-Plus.
Oder Magie-Plus.
Das heißt, eigentlich feiten sich da konstant alle drüber.
Und das Spiel hat auch...
Oh, ich glaube, der verreckt gleich.
Das Spiel hat auch keine Trennung zwischen PvP und PvE-Stats.
Kurz ein bisschen Ausrüstung anziehen.
Ich habe noch nichts.
Keine Trennung zwischen PvE und PvP-Stats.
Also sprich...
Oh, fuck.
Wir kriegen auf den Sack vom gelben Mob, Mann.
Und dementsprechend bringt es auch allgemein dann was für niceres PvP.
Fuck, Alter.
Wir kriegen auf den Sack von einem popeligen Level 3...
Von einem Level...
Level 2-Mob, Mann.
Hoffentlich.
Okay.
Okay, ich glaube, wir haben...
Potenziell schaffen wir das.
Okay, nice.
Und dementsprechend bist du bei allem besser.
Wenn du in einem Bereich besser bist.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal trainieren gleich.
Also so ganz...
Jetzt grobt da die Übersicht zum...
Zum Game und...
Wie es halt so ist bei so richtig Oldschool-Spielen.
Du hast sehr viele...
Etwas unklare Mechanics.
Wir gehen jetzt da hin und holen uns einmal Speed, dass wir schneller rennen können.
Es ist...
Ein bisschen unklare Mechanics im Endeffekt, weil...
Fängt schon an...
Fängt schon an mit den Stats.
Bei der Charaktererstellung.
Das müssen wir jetzt machen.
Ah, Wölfe killen.
Okay, nice.
Ich muss mal kurz trainieren.
Train.
Battle Songs.
Okay, nice.
Speed.
Damage.
Mehr haben wir noch nicht.
Moment.
Ja, wir sollten uns übrigens Ausrüstung kaufen.
Fällt mir gerade so auf.
Aber jetzt killen wir erstmal.
Nein, die können ja nicht viel, die Mobs.
Ja, also, es ist gerade für Einsteiger nicht so...
Also, ich finde, das Game lohnt sich heute immer noch.
Gerade, also, für mich ist es das beste PvP-MMO, was hier gemacht wurde.
Zumindest, allein schon die Stats blickt halt jemand, der neu ist, nicht.
Weil, seriously, Leute.
Okay, Chat, war so eine Frage an euch.
Es gibt ja, es gibt natürlich auch keine Hilfe irgendwie in dem Game.
Okay, was denkt ihr, was das Stats...
Was Stärke als Stat macht?
Das ist noch relativ easy.
Stärke ist also quasi das, was man denkt.
Stärke ist Nahkampf-Damage.
Okay, das kann man sich, kann man sich noch irgendwie denken.
Ja, genau.
Hitte den Mob von dem Typ.
Nice Idee.
Fuck.
Gleich haben wir die Wölfe fertig.
Okay, fertig.
GG.
Und, also, Stärke ist Nahkampf.
Nahkampf-Damage, das, da kommt man noch ungefähr hin.
Ja, Konstitution ist, äh, ja, Leben.
Und jetzt, jetzt geht's aber schon los.
So.
Oh, da ist einer dead.
So, Geschicklichkeit ist für Range-Damage.
Das ist okay.
Kann man sich vorstellen.
Für Bogendamage und so.
Range-Damage, okay, kann man sich vorstellen.
Ja, aber, so einfach ist das Ganze nicht.
Decks ist auch Kasten.
Cast-Speed.
Nicht etwa Quickness.
Das ist halt so ein Ding, das checkt niemand, wenn man das Spiel nicht kennt.
Man würde vermuten, Quickness ist Cast-Speed.
Aber nein, Quickness ist nur Melee-Speed.
Und Decks ist Cast-Speed.
Allerdings auch gleichzeitig Range-Damage-Primary-Stats.
Ja.
Es ist nicht so, nicht so klar alles.
Was ist denn das?
Das hab ich auch nie gesehen.
Was ist das?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
So, jetzt müssen wir hier die Invaders killen.
Er fragt mich gerade, welchen AR ich war in Season 1.
Ich hab jetzt gerade 6 oder 7.
Aber hauptsächlich rumgezergelt.
Mit den Leuten, mit denen ich gespielt hab.
Ich brauch mal ne Waffe.
Okay, ich brauch erstmal ne Rüstung.
Okay, neue Waffe.
Armlinge.
Juwel, okay, perfekt.
Immerhin.
Jetzt mach ich wenigstens ein bisschen Damage.
So, genau, wo wir gerade bei den Stats gewesen sind.
Also, Decks.
Ist Cast-Speed.
Wo man sich auch denkt, okay, man weiß es nicht.
Man mag in Dark Souls auch so sein, okay.
Vielleicht denkt sich das der ein oder andere heute.
Tatsächlich, kann sein.
Aber damals war es extrem weird, Champ.
Zumal Decks auch nicht nur Range-Damage ist, Cast-Speed.
Decks ist auch Staff-Damage, falls man mit Stab unterwegs ist.
Es gibt eine Klasse, die kämpft hauptsächlich mit Stab.
Und die ist 100% Decks.
Und ein Kumpel von mir damals, der Carsten, da, den kennt ihr vielleicht noch, wo ich mit dem Fabian unterwegs war.
Wir haben ja öfters mit dem Carsten gespielt.
Was ist so mit Carsten los?
Und der Carsten hat quasi eine Klasse gespielt, die hauptsächlich mit Stab verwendet hat.
Und der hat damals die Entwickler angeschrieben, welche Start-Stats er nehmen soll.
Und die haben ihm gesagt, nehm Stärke für Nahkampf-Stab-Damage.
Und damit war er komplett verskillt.
Er hatte 100% Decks skillen müssen.
Also, das ist eine Zeit, die Entwickler wussten selber nicht, was man skillen soll, ja?
Also insofern, ja, es war doch Cakeway-Zeit, ne?
Achso, ich hab jetzt gar nicht geguckt, ob wir done sind.
Wir sind done.
Kompetent, inkompetent.
Ja, ich seh übrigens gerade, ich muss mal XP einblenden.
Level XP.
Muss man overseed hier, so.
Ja.
Und, oh, weiter geht's.
Also, das hab ich mich drüber ausgelassen.
So, Quickness.
Quickness ist, entgegen auch der offiziellen Beschreibung, in dem Game, also im Game damals,
ist Quickness nur Melee, also Melee-Speed, Nahkampf-Speed.
So, Intelligenz, kann man sich wieder denken an Stats.
Intelligenz ist, mir fehlt ein Mob für XP, man.
Weiß.
Ja, es wird.
Kreisegrind gemacht, bis, bis heute Abend.
Ah, muss die Cloud-Stärke passen, ganz gut.
Ja, also Intelligenz kann man sich denken, das ist für Cast-Damage.
Passt ja soweit.
Empathie ist auch so ein Ding, niemand weiß, wofür das Stat wirklich da ist.
Also damals, zu Release, wusste niemand, wofür das wirklich da ist, das Stat.
Und der Witz ist, Empathie macht bei so gut wie keinem Char irgendwas, außer du spielst Hibernia, nein, das ist nicht für Magie-Stärke.
Es sei denn, du spielst Hibernia.
Du spielst Hibernia, die sind ja so naturaffin.
Dort ist es für Heiler und Caster.
Wobei, ich glaube sogar, dort ist Caster int.
Ja, ja, doch, doch, Caster sind dort auch int.
Also Empathie braucht niemand in diesem Spiel.
Niemand muss Empathie skillen, außer du spielst einen Heiler in Hip.
Dann hast du Piety, oder auf Deutsch hieß das Frömmigkeit.
Frömmigkeit brauchst du in Albion als Heiler.
Und in Midgard ist es für...
...alle Caster notwendig.
Weil in Midgard, so Odin und Thor und so, die müssen ganz besonders gläubig sein, dass sie Damage machen können für...
...beim Casten.
Wo müssen wir jetzt hin?
Ah, den Commander killen.
Typisch Bio-Break.
So kurz warten, bis er vom Klo wieder da ist.
Und Charisma...
Charisma...
...gibt's...lohnt sich, glaube ich, bin ich mir nicht so ganz sicher aus dem Kopf, aber ich glaube, Charisma ist nur relevant für ganze...
...drei Klassen im gesamten Spiel.
Nämlich Skalde, Bade oder Minnesänger.
Für Mana Pool und...
...ich glaube auch Damage-Varianz bei den Spells.
Also insofern...
...ohne Scheiß, das Game checkt halt niemand. Du musst erst mal einen kennen, der es kennt, oder Wiki lesen, dass du es verstehst.
Also es ist super kryptisch, auf jeden Fall.
Ich muss aber ehrlich sagen, ich hab das so verinnerlicht.
Alles.
Für mich ist...für mich kein Problem mehr.
Es ist genauso wie...genauso wie Resistenzen.
Resistenzen sind quasi gecapt bei 26 auf Level 50.
Und da fragt man sich jetzt natürlich, ok, warum ausgerechnet 26?
Weil...
...es gibt verschiedene Buff-Modifier oder Stat-Modifier.
Und in dem Fall ist es...
...Level...
...durch 2 plus 1.
Und wenn man das nicht weiß...
...denkt man sich halt, hä, warum genau 26?
50 durch 2 plus 1.
Das ist halt so ein Ding, das...
...wenn du es nicht weißt, hast du halt gelitten einfach nur.
So, jetzt müssen wir hier dieses Viech killen.
Dann haben wir das Tutorial auch fast schon fertig.
Bam.
Jetzt schreckt...
...zum Glück machen meine Shouts ordentlich Schaden.
Ey!
Gehst du weg?
Alter, taunte mir den weg!
Taunte mir den weg, Alter!
Hallo, hallo!
Taunte mir den Mob weg!
Geck weg.
Und das...das Game ist halt voll mit solchen Dingern.
So nach dem Motto, weißt es, dann ist gut.
Weißt es nicht, hast du verloren.
Aber es gibt kein...es gibt ein ganz gutes Wiki dazu.
Es gab richtig...es gab früher ein richtig gutes...
...ein richtig gutes deutschsprachiges Wiki.
Das wird aber schon seit Jahren nicht mehr aktualisiert.
Und...ja.
Blickt man halt nicht...blickt man halt nicht durch.
Ja.
Zum Beispiel genauso, wenn du dich buffen lässt von Heilern...
...dann ist das Cap von Buffs auch super weird.
Wo auch keiner weiß, warum das so ist.
Du musst dann unterscheiden zwischen Spec-Buffs und Base-Buffs.
Die einen geben quasi...
...125 Prozent.
Die anderen glaube ich...boah, weiß ich aus dem Kopf gar nicht mehr...
...irgendwie 75 Prozent.
Aber die geben...
...es ist super weird.
Es ist super weird, ja.
Bringt auch gar nichts, wenn ich euch das jetzt erzähle.
Es ist...es ist halt echt undurchsichtig.
Also entweder man weiß oder man hat halt gelitten.
So, habe ich irgendwie noch...
...Schuhe habe ich noch gekriegt.
Und einen Umhang, nice.
Ich muss jetzt eigentlich trainen.
Mal.
Eine Runde.
So, was wir machen werden ist...
...Level 10.
Gehen wir in Battleground.
Versuchen PvP...
...ein paar...
...Habe ich überhaupt den richtigen...
Ups, ich kacke nur bei falscher Knopf.
Bei Level 10...
...versuche ich...
...es kommt drauf an.
Wir müssen mal gucken.
Wenn der weiter...
...Wenn der weiter questen will, dann questen wir ein bisschen weiter.
Weil zu zweit ist es einfach deutlich...deutlich angenehmer als alleine.
Und dann machen wir kurz PvP und versuchen 1, 2...
...Kills zu machen.
Damit ich...
...mir...
...mehr Ausdauer kaufen kann.
Also...
...in dem Game ist tatsächlich PvP nicht nur kosmetisch und nicht nur just for fun.
In dem Game ist...
...Moment, ich zeige es euch mal ganz kurz, ohne dass ihr zu lange warten müsst.
...kannst du RR's kaufen.
Das sind Fähigkeiten, die kannst du dir kaufen, nur von Punkten, die du kriegst, wenn du Gegner killst.
Du musst Gegner nicht solo killen.
Es reicht auch, wenn du in der Gruppe drin bist, die Gegner killt.
Generell muss man sagen, das Game ist...
Ups, da müssen wir hin.
Das Game ist sehr...
...ja auch...
...gruppenorientiert.
Die Gruppengröße ist 8.
Nicht wie das World of Warcraft etabliert.
Das World of Warcraft etabliert hat 5.
Die Gruppengröße hier ist 8.
Was sehr schöne viele Varianten ermöglicht, was du spielen kannst.
Und gerade mit den Buffs für die unterschiedlichen Klassen hier, muss man sagen, du kannst hier erstaunlich viel spielen.
Das Spiel hat auch sehr viele verschiedene Klassen.
Also ich glaube...
...ich glaube jedes Reich hat so...
...Albion hat die meisten.
Wenn ich nicht...
...ich sag mal so im Durchschnitt...
...jedes Reich dürfte so um die 13 verschiedenen Klassen haben.
Was dann quasi ungefähr...
...so irgendwie...
...fast...
...fast an die 40 Klassen macht.
Alles zusammen.
Und...
...du kannst fast...
...ich sag fast, weil das ist nicht wirklich so...
...du kannst fast alles...
...spielen im PvP.
Also wenn du...
...mit mehreren Leuten rumläufst, auf jeden Fall.
Wenn du so auf...
...Elite PvP machst...
...mit 8er Gruppe gegen 8er Gruppe...
...dann nicht wirklich...
Ups, den wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht.
...dann nicht wirklich, dann kannst du nicht alles spielen.
Aber du kannst zum größten Teil...
...du kannst zum größten Teil tatsächlich alles spielen.
Ich kann euch nachher mal die Klassen zeigen.
Ups.
Ich kann euch nachher die Klassen zeigen.
Also es gibt jede Menge.
Es ist eigentlich für jeden was dabei.
Ich hab eine Frage.
Du hast zu Beginn Graphics...
...kannst du das bitte nochmal zeigen?
Kann ich dir zeigen, aber das alleine wird dir nichts bringen...
...weil du brauchst...
...du brauchst Software dafür, dass das geht.
Ich kann dir aber zeigen, welche du brauchst.
Ey.
Wir rennen jetzt vor dem Mob einfach mal weg.
Wir rennen vor dem Mob weg und ich hoffe...
Ach komm, scheiß drauf.
Wir machen jetzt platt.
Oder...
Ich dachte nämlich, da hat kein Endo mehr...
...und kommt nicht weg, der Dude.
Ja.
Also, wenn wir zurückfliegen...
...zeige ich dir das nochmal kurz.
Ach, nice.
Also, du drückst POS 1 auf der Tastatur...
...und kannst dann hier die Presets durchstellen.
Also, aus, an.
Die habe ich eingestellt.
Was du dazu brauchst, ist Reshade.
Sag, Reshade.
Nee, hieß das Reshade?
Ähm...
Ja, Reshade.
Musst du die runterladen...
...auf...
...irgendwo...
Äh...
Nee, hieß das Reshade?
Moment, ich bin grad...
...verwirrt.
Gleich.
Wir porten mal kurz weg.
Bin gleich wieder am Start.
Nee, ich muss mal kurz Ausrüstung kaufen.
Ich frag den mal, ob er weitermachen will.
Äh...
Ich...
Wir brauchen...
Haben wir hier irgendwas Gescheites, was ich mir kaufen kann?
Kunde, ähm...
Wollen wir kurz ne Waffe?
Ähm...
Greatsword...
Okay.
Train...
Ich brauch eigentlich Level 6...
Für...
Den...
Halbwegs gescheiten...
Anytimer...
Zum taunten...
Train...
Alles klar.
Okay.
Also...
Was wollte ich jetzt...
Wollte ich dir erzählen?
Genau.
Also...
Was...
den zu betäuben, aber
der war noch nicht gehotkey
mapped.
Ich muss mal meine Hotkeys ordentlich belegen.
Habe ich das hier drauf?
Sekunde.
Ich weiß nicht, worauf ich das
gelegt habe.
Healsong und
ich hätte eigentlich gesagt, die Dinger können wir
ich muss unbedingt
meine Hotkeys
ordentlich legen.
Oh, einer noch.
Ich muss unbedingt meine Hotkeys ordentlich legen.
Also ich glaube, Speed
muss hier hin.
Okay, Speed muss da hin.
Und
das muss so. Ne, Moment.
Ich bin
gerade echt planlos.
Das muss
da hin, oder?
Okay, das ist Speed.
Dann muss ich so rum
legen.
Okay.
Ich bin
planlos.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wo ich meine Hotkeys habe, Mann.
Habe ich meine Hotkeys vielleicht...
Ups.
Habe ich vielleicht meine Hotkeys so?
What the fuck?
Okay, ich habe seriously...
Ich denke, so sind die Hotkeys, ne?
Ja!
Okay, Hotkeys.
Ich habe meine Hotkeys wieder gefunden. Nice.
Was ist denn aus dem Dark Nachfolger
geworden? Moment. Meinst du etwa
Camelot Unchained?
Daraus ist leider nichts geworden.
Daraus ist leider nichts
geworden. Also, ich würde nicht
sagen, dass die uns
gescammt haben.
Aber bis jetzt ist da nix
weiter rausgekommen.
Schade, schade
eigentlich, ja.
Moment, seitlich läuft man schneller im Wasser.
Guck mal. Da auch Logik.
Da auch Logik.
Seitlich läuft man im Wasser
schneller. Das kenne
ich gar nicht. Das wusste ich noch gar nicht.
Dass man im Wasser schneller läuft seitlich.
Das ist ja zu geil, Mann.
Weißt du was? Ich lerne
nach 20 Jahren in dem Game immer noch was
dabei.
Guck mal.
Das kann ich
ja echt noch nicht. Null.
Guck mal, wir sind viel schneller seitlich laufen im Wasser.
Was sind deine
Augen? Was sind...
Das ist ein Private Server. Ja, das ist ein
Private Server.
Die Server sind übrigens auch noch online, ja.
Das auch. Guck mal, das ist zu geil.
Wir sind einfach
schneller im Wasser, weil wir seitlich
rennen, Mann.
Nur gut.
Soll mir
alles recht sein.
Ich muss mich da echt dran gewöhnen.
Guck mal. Guck mal.
Ein Gegner. Ein Gegner.
Ein
Kälte.
Der möchte gebasht werden von uns.
Oh, pass auf. Da sind noch mehr Gegner.
Wir laufen einfach jetzt hier.
Seitlich.
Beste, beste
Taktik, Mann.
Das ist so kaputt, Mann.
Siehst du mal, man lernt echt noch was.
Man lernt echt noch was in dem Game.
20 Jahre danach, Mann.
Ja, das ist... Okay, jetzt kann ich euch
tatsächlich auch ein bisschen was erzählen.
In jedem Battleground gibt es
eine Festung, die man
einnehmen kann und das ist
quasi so Vorbereitung für
dann größeres,
großes PvP.
Und bekommt man ein Level, wenn man die
Festung einnimmt.
Guck mal hier. Neue
Schuhe haben wir am Start. Level
20. 20
Amor, ein Ring.
20 Weste.
Ah, Rest kann man
verkaufen.
Witzig. Das finde ich echt
lustig mit dem seitlich Laufen, Mann.
Ach ja.
Bei der Gelegenheit.
Was man noch erwähnen könnte
ist, Farben
von Gegnern.
Das ist auch was,
was nicht erklärt wird in dem Spiel.
Aber
was essentiell ist, dass man nicht laufen
verrecken möchte. Also.
Graue Gegner. Ich glaube,
das ist übrigens in World of Warcraft auch so.
Nur mal so, wenn Leute das kennen.
Graue Gegner sind weit unter deinem Level
und
bringen keine XP.
Grüne Gegner
sind weit unter deinem Level, bringen noch ein bisschen
XP. Blaue
Gegner sind ein bisschen unter deinem Level,
bringen
ganz
okay XP. Gelbe Gegner
sind auf deinem Level,
bringen
normale XP. Orangene
Gegner sind ein bisschen über deinem Level.
Wie viel brauchen wir davon eigentlich noch?
Zwei.
Und bringen
eigentlich Cap-XP solo.
Und rote Gegner,
also das, was wir gerade die ganze Zeit gekillt haben,
rote Gegner
sind eine ganze Ecke über deinem
Level, bringen Cap-XP
für zwei Personen.
Wobei ich glaube auch sogar schon,
ich glaube sogar, ich glaube sogar
hohe Orange reichen auch für zwei Personen.
Hier ist die Glinde
am Start.
Valkyrie. Ja, gibt's auch
neu auf dem Server. Gab's letztes
Season nicht. Eigentlich eine mega nice Klasse,
so eine Mischung zwischen
Melee, Support, Damage und Heiler.
Ich würde die eigentlich entweiten, aber wir sind
durch mit dem,
mit den Mobs.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, dass uns keine Gegner
abfarmen, weil wie gesagt, PvP-Gebiet.
Immer gucken,
dass man ein bisschen Endu hat,
weil ohne Endu
keine Nahkampfangriffe möglich sind.
Und jemand, da ist doch,
ich bin ja gerade nicht
mein Albion, muss ja gucken.
Ich hab das Profil der
verschiedenen Models schon drauf. Ich kann euch meistens
innerhalb von zwei Sekunden sagen,
wenn ich nur ganz kurz eine Silhouette sehe,
haben wir Tokens?
Wir haben Tokens, aber unser
Tokendude ist nicht da, ne?
Der Tokendude ist nicht da.
Was das, was das für ein Gegner ist.
Darug gibt's, Free Shard.
Darug Free Shard Season 2 ist am
Samstag gestartet.
Ach ja, und um mal das mit den Gegnern
abzuschließen,
dann gibt es noch Lila oder Purple.
Die sind weit über deinem Level.
Du weißt nicht wie viel.
Können bis Level 99 im Endeffekt
sein.
Und bei Gegnern ist es übrigens genauso.
Im PvP.
Die Gegner sind auch, ähm,
ja.
Wobei ich glaube, bei Gegnern, die sind,
ne, ich glaube, die sind auch grün.
Irgendwann haben sie eingeführt,
dass Gegner, die zu niedrig sind, nur gelb
angezeigt werden so kann.
Aber, wenn du quasi
im PvP einen roten Gegner siehst,
dann weißt du, wenn es nicht gerade eine Support-Klasse
ist, eigentlich
guck mal, den brauchen wir auch,
den Dude, den Boss da.
Ich frende den mal.
Ja,
Gunde, hau mit drauf, gib's ihm.
Der macht ganz schön
Damage, der Typ.
Alter.
Wenn ich sterbe, dreh ich
durch, ey.
Er hat's mir weggetauntet.
Sehr nicer Dude.
Oh, Seeklinde hat's nicht mehr abgekriegt.
No.
Erstmal hier Horn an Goblins wegschnetzeln.
Ja, da sieht man, guck, der war jetzt orange.
Der ist quasi ein bisschen über unserem Level.
Der ist gelb, der ist auf unserem Level.
Eigentlich könnten wir die inviten, oder?
Kindergarten, Yordheim.
Ey, mit den...
Es könnte sogar sein, dass ich den kenne.
Gloria.
Ey, ich kannte einen Heiler von denen.
Haben wir öfters mal gespielt, letzte Season.
Sind wir fertig?
Ich bin verwirrt, ich hab die Quests überhaupt nicht drin.
Okay, wir müssen nur noch
einen Boss killen, dann haben wir's geschafft.
Easy.
Ja, Heilsong.
Achso, ich könnte vielleicht ein bisschen was zu meinen
Skills erzählen noch.
Das mach ich aber, wenn wir aus dem PvP-Gebiet raus sind.
Dann hab ich auch alle Basic-Skills.
Fast alle.
Fast alle Basic-Skills.
Als Skaldemon was zu erzählen kann.
Mir fehlt, glaub ich, noch Endo-Reduce.
Endo-Reduce ist enorm praktisch.
Und sobald ich Gold habe,
muss ich unbedingt...
Ist unser Zelt...
Zelt-Guy am Start?
Zelt-Tent?
Es gibt nämlich in jedem...
Äh, Battleground klickt man für gekillte Monster und Gegner.
So, Tokens.
Und die Tokens kann man abgeben.
Und dann kriegt man auch ein bisschen XP für...
Ach, guck mal, ein Nekro!
Ein Nekro!
Der out uns jetzt.
Der basht uns jetzt.
Nekros sind OP!
Nekros sind krass OP, man!
Hahaha.
Ach, wir wollten den Mob killen.
Okay, jetzt gab's ein bisschen...
...gab's ein bisschen Punkte.
Hab nicht gesehen, dass der Mob gespawnt war.
Der Nekro hat da drauf gehauen.
Wir müssen mal kurz gucken, ob wir respawnen, abwarten
oder direkt weitergehen.
Deserters, Deserters
ist auch eine gute Idee.
Ja.
Ja, Deserters ist tatsächlich eine gute Idee.
So, Leute, jetzt müsst ihr mir mal sagen,
ist der Stream hell genug?
Wenn nicht, mach ich euch das Gamma noch ein bisschen hoch.
Da ist er, guck mal.
Boss ist am Start.
Geht?
heller machen ich mache ich mache ich noch ein ticken heller bisschen
bisschen heller weil nacht in dark ist immer mega mega dunkel und ätzend ich
habe keine ahnung wo die sörter sind weil meine karte hat keine die sorters
to the left of the keep near water okay left keep ist hier schauen wir mal
schauen wir mal wo die sind ich war ich war mal ganz kurz den ticken in ticken
heller aber hier einfach mal drei punkte heller ob hier die sörter sind es
gibt in jedem battleground gibt es eine zusätzliche kill quest wenn man noch
nicht max max level ist dass mein level ist zu laut
ok pass auf gegner ist am start muss wohl gegner special man ich habe meine
hotkeys noch nicht belegt ich kann nur bald das ist das ist richtig mies okay
okay okay passt
okay aus irgendwas davon habe ich auch
okay aus irgendwas davon habe ich auch modki
modki
modki koma galagunde ist wieder am start was hat
koma galagunde ist wieder am start was hat
koma galagunde ist wieder am start was hat er vor und willst du nicht hin
er vor und willst du nicht hin
er vor und willst du nicht hin alle direkt wir sollten uns mal verpissen
alle direkt wir sollten uns mal verpissen
alle direkt wir sollten uns mal verpissen hier sind die sörter sondern hier sind
hier sind die sörter sondern hier sind
hier sind die sörter sondern hier sind dieser das okay nice
dieser das okay nice
dieser das okay nice jetzt müssen wir von hinten gucken weil
jetzt müssen wir von hinten gucken weil
jetzt müssen wir von hinten gucken weil also das problem ist tatsächlich dass
also das problem ist tatsächlich dass
also das problem ist tatsächlich dass die festung gehört den gegnern und was
die festung gehört den gegnern und was
die festung gehört den gegnern und was man da vor rumlaufen hat sehen wann auch
man da vor rumlaufen hat sehen wann auch
man da vor rumlaufen hat sehen wann auch gegner das ist halt als wir sind hier
gegner das ist halt als wir sind hier
gegner das ist halt als wir sind hier gerade wirklich ziemlich wirklich sehr
gerade wirklich ziemlich wirklich sehr
gerade wirklich ziemlich wirklich sehr dumme sehr durche posi ja hier hinter
dumme sehr durche posi ja hier hinter
dumme sehr durche posi ja hier hinter uns ist wasser wir kommen nicht weg
uns ist wasser wir kommen nicht weg
uns ist wasser wir kommen nicht weg warum ist der die sörter sparen so
warum ist der die sörter sparen so
warum ist der die sörter sparen so langsam wir können auch mit unserem
langsam wir können auch mit unserem
langsam wir können auch mit unserem neu gelehrten trick ins wasser laufen da
neu gelehrten trick ins wasser laufen da
neu gelehrten trick ins wasser laufen da kommen sie nicht hin oder kommen als
kommen sie nicht hin oder kommen als
kommen sie nicht hin oder kommen als als das ist ein nekro das ist eine
als das ist ein nekro das ist eine
als das ist ein nekro das ist eine alpgruppe am start kommt war im wasser
alpgruppe am start kommt war im wasser
alpgruppe am start kommt war im wasser im wasser seht ihr die da hinten die
im wasser seht ihr die da hinten die
im wasser seht ihr die da hinten die trauen sich aber nicht die trauen sich
trauen sich aber nicht die trauen sich
trauen sich aber nicht die trauen sich nicht wie immer kacken hubs am start
nicht wie immer kacken hubs am start
nicht wie immer kacken hubs am start hinter uns gucken keine gegner am start
hinter uns gucken keine gegner am start
hinter uns gucken keine gegner am start okay aber die alps sind wieder abgehauen
okay aber die alps sind wieder abgehauen
okay aber die alps sind wieder abgehauen oder die kommen jetzt von der seite was
oder die kommen jetzt von der seite was
oder die kommen jetzt von der seite was eigentlich jetzt okay zwei stück noch
eigentlich jetzt okay zwei stück noch
eigentlich jetzt okay zwei stück noch zwei stück auch mein dude ist fast tot
zwei stück auch mein dude ist fast tot
zwei stück auch mein dude ist fast tot mann machen heilsorg an
mann machen heilsorg an
mann machen heilsorg an okay wir haben es wir haben es dann
okay wir haben es wir haben es dann
okay wir haben es wir haben es dann schreiben wir mal gucken dass uns keine
schreiben wir mal gucken dass uns keine
schreiben wir mal gucken dass uns keine gegner im rücken fallen
gegner im rücken fallen
gegner im rücken fallen akuma da der steht da können wir nicht
akuma da der steht da können wir nicht
akuma da der steht da können wir nicht wir können nicht ins wasser in gaten
wir können nicht ins wasser in gaten
wir können nicht ins wasser in gaten wir können nicht ins wasser wenn wir ins
wir können nicht ins wasser in gaten wir können nicht ins wasser in gaten
wir können nicht ins wasser in gaten
wir können nicht ins wasser in gaten sind wir sind wir gefickt die sollen
sind wir sind wir gefickt die sollen
sind wir gefickt die sollen rauskommen die müssen rauskommen aus dem
rauskommen die müssen rauskommen aus dem
rauskommen die müssen rauskommen aus dem wasser typisch schon dauern
wasser typisch schon dauern
wasser typisch schon dauern da können wir nichts machen verpissen
da können wir nichts machen verpissen
da können wir nichts machen verpissen wir uns mal also ins wasser rein
wir uns mal also ins wasser rein
wir uns mal also ins wasser rein eingelten wenn er wenn der blöde idee
eingelten wenn er wenn der blöde idee
eingelten wenn er wenn der blöde idee wir gehen jetzt erstmal bei uns die
wir gehen jetzt erstmal bei uns die
wir gehen jetzt erstmal bei uns die quest abgeben also ich merke ich kann
quest abgeben also ich merke ich kann
quest abgeben also ich merke ich kann mich unglaublich schlecht auf labern
mich unglaublich schlecht auf labern
mich unglaublich schlecht auf labern chat und pvp konzentrieren was auch
chat und pvp konzentrieren was auch
chat und pvp konzentrieren was auch kommen wir haben ein heiler ich fasse es
kommen wir haben ein heiler ich fasse es
kommen wir haben ein heiler ich fasse es nicht exzellent woher der das richtig
nicht exzellent woher der das richtig
nicht exzellent woher der das richtig gut ja der kerl da macht jetzt group
gut ja der kerl da macht jetzt group
gut ja der kerl da macht jetzt group group in waldsee der da muss ich mich
group in waldsee der da muss ich mich
group in waldsee der da muss ich mich da nicht drum kümmern
da nicht drum kümmern
da nicht drum kümmern das ist gut macht man brain gerade
das ist gut macht man brain gerade
das ist gut macht man brain gerade nicht mit ja also ich hoffe jetzt ist
nicht mit ja also ich hoffe jetzt ist
nicht mit ja also ich hoffe jetzt ist hell genug weil es ist nacht und es ist
hell genug weil es ist nacht und es ist
hell genug weil es ist nacht und es ist scheiß wetter da ist da auch doch schon
scheiß wetter da ist da auch doch schon
scheiß wetter da ist da auch doch schon sehr dunkel
sehr dunkel
sehr dunkel das muss ich erst mal kurz trainer
das muss ich erst mal kurz trainer
das muss ich erst mal kurz trainer trainieren trainieren für neue spells
trainieren trainieren für neue spells
trainieren trainieren für neue spells und skills
und skills
und skills ja falls irgendjemand da spielt und sich
ja falls irgendjemand da spielt und sich
ja falls irgendjemand da spielt und sich wundert warum ich schwert gespielt
wundert warum ich schwert gespielt
wundert warum ich schwert gespielt bin und nicht hammer
bin und nicht hammer
bin und nicht hammer er liegt das daran weil ich schwert mehr
er liegt das daran weil ich schwert mehr
er liegt das daran weil ich schwert mehr mag aber und das muss man ja auch ganz
mag aber und das muss man ja auch ganz
mag aber und das muss man ja auch ganz klar sagen hammer ist in der regel die
klar sagen hammer ist in der regel die
klar sagen hammer ist in der regel die bessere variante habe ich irgendwas das
bessere variante habe ich irgendwas das
bessere variante habe ich irgendwas das kann man noch austauschen
kann man noch austauschen
kann man noch austauschen ja dass ich bräuchte ich bräuchte
ja dass ich bräuchte ich bräuchte
ja dass ich bräuchte ich bräuchte unbedingt neue schwert ring aber noch
unbedingt neue schwert ring aber noch
unbedingt neue schwert ring aber noch okay ich brauche auf jeden fall neues
okay ich brauche auf jeden fall neues
okay ich brauche auf jeden fall neues schwert hammer bringt mir nichts ich
schwert hammer bringt mir nichts ich
schwert hammer bringt mir nichts ich kann nicht so viel gleichzeitig man
kann nicht so viel gleichzeitig man
kann nicht so viel gleichzeitig man schafft man boomer hier nicht mehr
schafft man boomer hier nicht mehr
schafft man boomer hier nicht mehr oder sind ganz viele das sind ganz viele
oder sind ganz viele das sind ganz viele
oder sind ganz viele das sind ganz viele hips dahinter auf auf go go die wenn
hips dahinter auf auf go go die wenn
hips dahinter auf auf go go die wenn das gebast links sind kälte aller
das gebast links sind kälte aller
das gebast links sind kälte aller machte noch platt
machte noch platt
machte noch platt das ist ein bisschen viele sehr gut sehr
das ist ein bisschen viele sehr gut sehr
das ist ein bisschen viele sehr gut sehr gut den typen haben jetzt dauer ja ja
gut den typen haben jetzt dauer ja ja
gut den typen haben jetzt dauer ja ja ja ja ja lauft ihr alle nur lauft ihr
ja ja ja lauft ihr alle nur lauft ihr
ja ja ja lauft ihr alle nur lauft ihr alle nur schatten man enden ist alles
alle nur schatten man enden ist alles
alle nur schatten man enden ist alles nice next lauf dir alle plus random bei
nice next lauf dir alle plus random bei
nice next lauf dir alle plus random bei uns rein und lasst euchkeiten sehr gut
uns rein und lasst euchkeiten sehr gut
uns rein und lasst euchkeiten sehr gut so der bade muss sterben sonst wird das
so der bade muss sterben sonst wird das
so der bade muss sterben sonst wird das nix
nix
nix ausschütte die heim ich hab ich hab zu
ausschütte die heim ich hab ich hab zu
ausschütte die heim ich hab ich hab zu wenig spells kann er hat das pet drauf
wenig spells kann er hat das pet drauf
wenig spells kann er hat das pet drauf das ist okay sobald der kassel wird
das ist okay sobald der kassel wird
das ist okay sobald der kassel wird angeschautet ansonsten nicht gut gut
angeschautet ansonsten nicht gut gut
angeschautet ansonsten nicht gut gut gut speed bade bade macht den bade kalt
speed bade bade macht den bade kalt
speed bade bade macht den bade kalt der bade muss sterben der andere heiler
der bade muss sterben der andere heiler
der bade muss sterben der andere heiler steht die haben keinen hiel mehr aktuell
steht die haben keinen hiel mehr aktuell
steht die haben keinen hiel mehr aktuell fakt der heiler ist frei ich habe keine
fakt der heiler ist frei ich habe keine
fakt der heiler ist frei ich habe keine endung das ist mein problem
endung das ist mein problem
endung das ist mein problem sondern jetzt okay den nächsten bade
sondern jetzt okay den nächsten bade
sondern jetzt okay den nächsten bade kann ich abstellen wenn ich glück habe
kann ich abstellen wenn ich glück habe
kann ich abstellen wenn ich glück habe und resisted jetzt habe ich nichts mehr
und resisted jetzt habe ich nichts mehr
und resisted jetzt habe ich nichts mehr den zu unterbrechen aber da ist blöd
den zu unterbrechen aber da ist blöd
den zu unterbrechen aber da ist blöd du mehr mann
du mehr mann
du mehr mann ok 14 prozent 14 prozent geben 0 dauer
ok 14 prozent 14 prozent geben 0 dauer
ok 14 prozent 14 prozent geben 0 dauer jawohl
jawohl
jawohl der wird abgestellt ok das fast dauer
der wird abgestellt ok das fast dauer
der wird abgestellt ok das fast dauer das fast dauer
das fast dauer
das fast dauer du musst nichts peilen macht nichts macht
du musst nichts peilen macht nichts macht
du musst nichts peilen macht nichts macht nichts du musst nur peilen dass wir
nichts du musst nur peilen dass wir
nichts du musst nur peilen dass wir gewonnen haben du musst nur peilen dass
gewonnen haben du musst nur peilen dass
gewonnen haben du musst nur peilen dass wir gerade acht gegner gekillt haben oder
wir gerade acht gegner gekillt haben oder
wir gerade acht gegner gekillt haben oder so zu viert
so zu viert
so zu viert das reicht ja sehr gut also ich kann
das reicht ja sehr gut also ich kann
das reicht ja sehr gut also ich kann versuchen euch zu erklären was da
versuchen euch zu erklären was da
versuchen euch zu erklären was da gerade gewesen ist
gerade gewesen ist
gerade gewesen ist mein brain gerade mit aufpassen
mein brain gerade mit aufpassen
mein brain gerade mit aufpassen überfordert ich muss trainen battle
überfordert ich muss trainen battle
überfordert ich muss trainen battle songs moment wenn ich mal battle songs
songs moment wenn ich mal battle songs
songs moment wenn ich mal battle songs neuen speed brauchen wir
neuen speed brauchen wir
neuen speed brauchen wir und speed 9 damage song endu
und speed 9 damage song endu
und speed 9 damage song endu enchantment das brauchen wir jetzt das
enchantment das brauchen wir jetzt das
enchantment das brauchen wir jetzt das beste kann man besser rennen hätten wir
beste kann man besser rennen hätten wir
beste kann man besser rennen hätten wir eben gebraucht mehr damage nahkampf und
eben gebraucht mehr damage nahkampf und
eben gebraucht mehr damage nahkampf und meines näher da bin ich mir nicht sicher
meines näher da bin ich mir nicht sicher
meines näher da bin ich mir nicht sicher auf welchen ort gehe ich den hat das
auf welchen ort gehe ich den hat das
auf welchen ort gehe ich den hat das letzte mal so mann hat son den braum
letzte mal so mann hat son den braum
letzte mal so mann hat son den braum an selten okay passt ich bin ich kann
an selten okay passt ich bin ich kann
an selten okay passt ich bin ich kann nicht so viel multi multitask waren so
nicht so viel multitask waren so
nicht so viel multitask waren so passt mal auf high iq seitwärts laufen
passt mal auf high iq seitwärts laufen
passt mal auf high iq seitwärts laufen wieder am start also übrigens das waren
wieder am start also übrigens das waren
wieder am start also übrigens das waren echte gegner eben diese diese die wir
echte gegner eben diese diese die wir
echte gegner eben diese diese die wir da gerade gekillt haben also wenn er so
da gerade gekillt haben also wenn er so
da gerade gekillt haben also wenn er so echte echte spieler token abgeben gibt
echte echte spieler token abgeben gibt
echte echte spieler token abgeben gibt xp der ist aber der ist sehr
xp der ist aber der ist sehr
xp der ist aber der ist sehr optimistisch dass wir mit vier leute
optimistisch dass wir mit vier leute
optimistisch dass wir mit vier leute das kieb erobern können
das kieb erobern können
das kieb erobern können das ist ich weiß ja nicht das erscheint
das ist ich weiß ja nicht das erscheint
das ist ich weiß ja nicht das erscheint mir etwas mega optimistisch guck mal
mir etwas mega optimistisch guck mal
mir etwas mega optimistisch guck mal wir sind vier leute ok 5 mit dem pad von
wir sind vier leute ok 5 mit dem pad von
wir sind vier leute ok 5 mit dem pad von ihm dabei aber mit fünf leuten das
ihm dabei aber mit fünf leuten das
ihm dabei aber mit fünf leuten das kieb ich bin mir unschlüssig oder sind
kieb ich bin mir unschlüssig oder sind
kieb ich bin mir unschlüssig oder sind alps
alps
alps nach dem moment da sind schon da sind
nach dem moment da sind schon da sind
nach dem moment da sind schon da sind schon mit am start easy
schon mit am start easy
schon mit am start easy und da kann ich nicht hin leute da kann
und da kann ich nicht hin leute da kann
und da kann ich nicht hin leute da kann ich nicht da bin ich der ich bin ich
ich nicht der ich bin ich der ich bin ich
ich nicht der ich bin ich der ich bin ich da hingehe unser heiler muss da
da hingehe unser heiler muss da
da hingehe unser heiler muss da irgendwas reinbekommen sehr gut
irgendwas reinbekommen sehr gut
irgendwas reinbekommen sehr gut perfekt pockers hieler pockers hieler auf
perfekt pockers hieler pockers hieler auf
perfekt pockers hieler pockers hieler auf rein leute rein leute ihr müsst da
rein leute rein leute ihr müsst da
rein leute rein leute ihr müsst da rein ich krieg auf den sack die charge
rein oh ich krieg auf den sack die charge
rein oh ich krieg auf den sack die charge nicht mit die charge nicht mit
nicht mit die charge nicht mit
nicht mit die charge nicht mit no fuck bin da und okay so kann es
no fuck bin da und okay so kann es
no fuck bin da und okay so kann es gehen schnell release nur wieder hin
gehen schnell release nur wieder hin
gehen schnell release nur wieder hin der heiler hat den satz richtig gut
der heiler hat den satz richtig gut
der heiler hat den satz richtig gut gemacht er hat das richtig gut gemacht
gemacht er hat das richtig gut gemacht
gemacht er hat das richtig gut gemacht die standen alle da hätten wir in dem
die standen alle da hätten wir in dem
die standen alle da hätten wir in dem moment voll rein drücken müssen dann
moment voll rein drücken müssen dann
moment voll rein drücken müssen dann hat das geklappt spielt holen
hat das geklappt spielt holen
hat das geklappt spielt holen entscheidungs holen speed am ende
entscheidungs holen speed an ende
entscheidungs holen speed an ende reduce an let's go volle pulle zum
reduce an let's go volle pulle zum
reduce an let's go volle pulle zum keep wenn man respond hier so schnell dass
keep wenn man respond hier so schnell dass
keep wenn man respond hier so schnell dass man dass man vor allem mit speed
man dass man vor allem mit speed
man dass man vor allem mit speed dass man klar wieder da ist okay und die
dass man klar wieder da ist okay und die
dass man klar wieder da ist okay und die machen irgendwelche quests so jetzt
machen irgendwelche quests so jetzt
machen irgendwelche quests so jetzt kommt was man auf trick trick 17 wir
kommt was man auf trick trick 17 wir
kommt was man auf trick trick 17 wir laufen jetzt nicht den weg außen
laufen jetzt nicht den weg außen
laufen jetzt nicht den weg außen drumherum wir machen jetzt das was ich
drumherum wir machen jetzt das was ich
drumherum wir machen jetzt das was ich gerade gelernt habe messe feier que
gerade gelernt habe messe feier que
gerade gelernt habe messe feier que seitwärts walking das ist so ein geiler
seitwärts walking das ist so ein geiler
seitwärts walking das ist so ein geiler bug den kannte ich noch gar nicht man
bug den kannte ich noch gar nicht man
bug den kannte ich noch gar nicht man guck mal wie schnell wir hier durch sind
guck mal wie schnell wir hier durch sind
guck mal wie schnell wir hier durch sind anstatt um den see zu laufen
anstatt um den see zu laufen
anstatt um den see zu laufen guck mal ich krieg sogar apps
guck mal ich krieg sogar apps
guck mal ich krieg sogar apps nice das ist der beste klitsch ever man
nice das ist der beste klitsch ever man
nice das ist der beste klitsch ever man ohne die anderen sind auch am start
ohne die anderen sind auch am start
ohne die anderen sind auch am start ich muss meine leute supporten wo ist
ich muss meine leute supporten wo ist
ich muss meine leute supporten wo ist mein team mein team hier unten sitzen wir
mein team mein team hier unten sitzen wir
mein team mein team hier unten sitzen wir sind hier auf der karte ja da sind sie
sind hier auf der karte ja da sind sie
sind hier auf der karte ja da sind sie da sind sie da sind sie schnell nicht
da sind sie schnell nicht
da sind sie schnell nicht sterben nicht sterben leute nicht
sterben nicht sterben leute nicht
sterben nicht sterben leute nicht sterben
sterben nicht sterben
sterben nicht sterben oh shit ist näher jawohl sterben
oh shit ist näher jawohl sterben
oh shit ist näher jawohl sterben sterben nein nein nein fuck okay ich bleibe auf
sterben nein nein nein fuck okay ich bleibe auf
sterben nein nein nein fuck okay ich bleibe auf dem ich hab halt nix mehr
dem ich hab halt nix mehr
dem ich hab halt nix mehr steht ich habe echt keine ende und nix
steht ich habe echt keine ende und nix
steht ich habe echt keine ende und nix mann kommt jetzt kommt jetzt der mutter
mann kommt jetzt kommt jetzt der mutter
mann kommt jetzt kommt jetzt der mutter kann es auch sterben
kann es auch sterben
kann es auch sterben nice und
nice und
nice und er kann auch noch sterben okay
er kann auch noch sterben okay
er kann auch noch sterben okay das geht ja gerade richtig was ab hier
das geht ja gerade richtig was ab hier
das geht ja gerade richtig was ab hier so wir haben wieder gewonnen
so wir haben wieder gewonnen
so wir haben wieder gewonnen jetzt okay ich hoffe unsere leute kommen
jetzt okay ich hoffe unsere leute kommen
jetzt okay ich hoffe unsere leute kommen schnell da hinten ist noch ein kälte
schnell da hinten ist noch ein kälte
schnell da hinten ist noch ein kälte guck mal die hauen ab seht ihr so wie sie
guck mal die hauen ab seht ihr so wie sie
guck mal die hauen ab seht ihr so wie sie wegrennen diese wegrennen ein bisschen
wegrennen diese wegrennen ein bisschen
wegrennen diese wegrennen ein bisschen deserter ist gut deserter xp nämlich
deserter ist gut deserter xp nämlich
deserter ist gut deserter xp nämlich nämlich auch mit kein ding ja also
nämlich auch mit kein ding ja also
nämlich auch mit kein ding ja also früher war das so du konntest nur eines
früher war das so du konntest nur eines
früher war das so du konntest nur eines der reiche spielen pro server heißt im
der reiche spielen pro server heißt im
der reiche spielen pro server heißt im endeffekt die leute waren ziemlich
endeffekt die leute waren ziemlich
endeffekt die leute waren ziemlich attached so halt zu dem realm was sie
attached so halt zu dem realm was sie
attached so halt zu dem realm was sie gespielt haben und dementsprechend gab
gespielt haben und dementsprechend gab
gespielt haben und dementsprechend gab es immer so kleine also kleine
es immer so kleine also kleine
es immer so kleine also kleine sticheleien gegeneinander
sticheleien gegeneinander
sticheleien gegeneinander ja in albion gab es platten rüstung
ja in albion gab es platten rüstung
ja in albion gab es platten rüstung gab es paladin platten rüstung
gab es paladin platten rüstung
gab es paladin platten rüstung deswegen hat man im deutschsprachigen
deswegen hat man im deutschsprachigen
deswegen hat man im deutschsprachigen raum immer gesagt das sind keine alb
raum immer gesagt das sind keine alb
raum immer gesagt das sind keine alb sondern sind dosen weil platten rüstung
sondern sind dosen weil platten rüstung
sondern sind dosen weil platten rüstung und so eine dosen und zu zu hilfs war
und so eine dosen und zu zu hilfs war
und so eine dosen und zu zu hilfs war man deutlich weniger weniger nett da hat
man deutlich weniger weniger nett da hat
man deutlich weniger weniger nett da hat man meistens gesagt baumficker oder so
man meistens gesagt baumficker oder so
man meistens gesagt baumficker oder so was weil die so natur verbunden sind
was weil die so natur verbunden sind
was weil die so natur verbunden sind ok turn in tokens kann man machen wir
ok turn in tokens kann man machen wir
ok turn in tokens kann man machen wir turnen tokens in ich habe nur 24
turnen tokens in ich habe nur 24
turnen tokens in ich habe nur 24 tokens das lohnt sich eigentlich kaum den
tokens das lohnt sich eigentlich kaum den
tokens das lohnt sich eigentlich kaum den ring können wir austauschen
sie armen linge okay ich brauche hosen
sie armen linge okay ich brauche hosen und schuhe und eine weste
und schuhe und eine weste
und schuhe und eine weste da noch schon 15
da noch schon 15
da noch schon 15 wir machen schnell deserters
wir machen schnell deserters
wir machen schnell deserters bis denn doch der chaos
bis denn doch der chaos
bis denn doch der chaos er meint ihn hier den der bär sie soll
er meint ihn hier den der bär sie soll
er meint ihn hier den der bär sie soll des banden die anderen dass wir sie
des banden die anderen dass wir sie
des banden die anderen dass wir sie entweiten kann
entweiten kann
entweiten kann achtung ging auf der christin er hat
achtung ging auf der christin er hat
achtung ging auf der christin er hat christin stelle stelle stelle stelle
stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle stelle st
holen wir noch. Alter, ich fass
es nicht. Ich hab kein Mana
mehr. Shit.
Jawoll.
Jawoll, er hat ihn, er hat ihn, er hat ihn,
er hat ihn, er hat ihn. Ich bin gleich da, ich bin gleich da.
Jawoll.
Erstmal, Leute, Leute,
erstmal T-Baggen.
Wie sich das in jedem
guten Game gehört. Erstmal die feine
T-Baggen. Seht ihr,
das ist unter anderem eines der
riesen, neuesten Sachen
an Dork.
Dadurch, dass es
zwei Fraktionen, äh, drei Fraktionen gibt
in dem Spiel, es ist
nie langweilig.
Versteht ihr, wie ich mein?
Es war eben so, wir haben gefeitert
von vorne gegen die Alps.
Dann kamen Hips von der Seite und umgedreht.
Äh, übrigens, wir sterben jetzt, das ist
Absicht, nicht wundern. Wir rennen jetzt
in das Portal Keep
der Hips.
Da sind super High-Level-Wachen, die
uns jetzt bashen werden.
Dü-dü-dü-dü-dü.
Ich muss den mal
fragen, was der, was der machen will.
Ob der ins nächste...
Hast du AOC heute schon gemacht?
Nein.
Hab ich noch nicht gemacht.
Aber wir sind 1L2.
Also wir können
gleich noch was, was kaufen.
Alter, wo bin ich denn hier rausgekommen?
Was f...
Alter, random,
random Gilden in White, lol, Alter.
Hahaha.
Ich kenn, ich kenn die
gar nicht.
Ähm,
sind die anderen auch?
Alter, kann ich mal richtig schrumpfen?
Wir machen BG, hä?
Aber irgendwas...
Okay, der will wahrscheinlich BG, oder?
Mal kurz gucken, wo er ist.
Der will bestimmt BG.
Wir machen nächsten BG.
Joa, ich hab gegen PvP nix.
Ich, das ist das Beste, was es in dem Spiel gibt.
Aber ihr habt's gesehen, es kann nicht
langweilig werden mit drei Fraktionen.
Das ist halt das Geile daran.
Und wir sind jetzt in der nächsten BG.
Und wir sind schon Level 15, ging wirklich sehr, sehr zackig.
So, Leute, ich muss mal kurz Bio-Aften.
So wie man das in MMOs nennt.
Aft-Bio.
Heißt, ach guck mal, ich hab
Deserters fertig gehabt. Nice, gibt's ein bisschen
Bonus-XP.
Ich will mal kurz Bio-Breaken.
Und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder eine Minute.
Wieder am Start.
Nice, Twitch.
zuschauer ich sollte euch vielleicht noch eine sache erklären zu dark und zwar gibt es hier
ein bounty guck mal da bounty points sollte ich bounty points dafür ausgeben ja ich gebe bounty
points dafür aus ich gebe bounty points für eine waffe aus ich brauche unbedingt ich brauche
unbedingt eine gescheite waffe es gibt einen makro um alle gegenstände zu verkaufen das habe
ich aber noch nicht deswegen verkauf jetzt mal manuell can't be sold okay ja ich muss euch
noch was erzählen zu einer ziemlich aus für die heutige zeit einzigartige mechanic von dark und
zwar ist es das interrupt system also
Also, wenn ihr, brauche ich zwar nicht, aber ich ziehe es trotzdem an, wenn ihr Caster seid oder Heiler, also wenn ihr irgendwas casten möchtet und euch jemand im Nahkampf angreift, dann könnt ihr nicht zaubern.
Und selbst wenn euch Range Damage hittet, könnt ihr auch nicht zaubern.
Das heißt, es gibt nur ganz wenige Spells, die ihr abkriegen könnt, bei denen ihr noch weiter zaubern könnt.
Das heißt, was enorm wichtig ist, gerade als Supporter und Heiler, dass man sich ordentlich positioniert.
Ansonsten hast du eigentlich nahezu verloren.
Und das haben die gegnerischen Supporter bei den Fights eben nicht gemacht.
Ich war permanent dran, konnte die so gut wie die ganze Zeit interrupten.
Und dementsprechend haben die auch keine Spells rausgekriegt.
So sieht's aus.
So, jetzt trainieren wir erstmal.
Du weißt schon, dass du mit Shift-S auf... Nein, das weiß ich nicht.
Ist das neu?
Weiß ich nicht, nee, wusste ich nicht.
So, Battle Songs muss auf Level.
Ein neuer Metz und etwas schwer.
Ein Side-Style, Back-Style?
Front-Style?
Was ist denn das?
In Front of Target.
Okay, das könnte vielleicht was...
Ich glaub, einfach mit meinem Any-Timer drauf, Braindead und gut ist.
So.
Battle Songs, gut.
Während das hier läuft, äh, hab ich Power Toys drauf.
Power Toys?
Fuck.
Ich brauch, ich brauch mein Shortcut-Mapping, sonst wird das nix.
Ich, ähm, hab, ähm, Snare immer auf Control liegen.
War schon immer, ernsthaft.
Ich spiel das seit 20 Jahren.
Nur ist nix davon.
Null.
Hahaha.
Hab ich schon zwei Sachen gelernt.
Side-Fat, Scraven und Verkaufen.
Zumindest, ich, ich kann euch jetzt mal ganz grob die, die, die Spells erklären.
Hab ich überhaupt Quests angenommen?
Ja, hab ich.
Ganz, ganz grob erklären, was es, was es gibt.
Also, Skalde ist ne Hybrid-Klasse.
Das ist quasi die, die Musik-Klasse aus Midgard.
Und dementsprechend hab ich Speed.
Was so ziemlich eines der begehrtesten Sachen im gesamten Spiel ist.
Also, wenn ihr euch fragt, welche Klassen sind begehrt, dann sind das prinzipiell Heiler und Supporter.
Und Klassen mit Speed.
Weil, im PvP-Gebieten, wenn du dort nicht maximalen Laufspeed hast, bist du quasi dead.
Und du holst auch keine Gegner ein und sowas.
Kannst du eigentlich, kannst du eigentlich voll vergessen.
Im Prinzip können alle Klassen relativ beliebt sein, finden, finden was.
Wobei, naja, nicht unbedingt alle, aber die meisten.
Aber gerade, gerade Supporter und Klassen mit Speed sind, sind immer, sind immer beliebt.
Also, ich versuch euch das mal kurz zu erklären.
Also, das ist ne Hybrid-Klasse.
Sprich, ich hab erstmal den laueren Mob-Killen.
Alter, ich krieg echt Damage.
Krieg ich so ein Damage.
Warte mal kurz, Heilsong an, Heilsong und Endo-Reduce.
Okay, ich warte mal kurz, bis der getauntet hat.
Ja, also, ich hab ein bisschen, bisschen wenig TP gerade.
Also, ich lass, ich lass den mal kurz draufhauen, regge mal schnell.
Also, ähm, nachdem das ne Hybrid-Klasse ist, hab ich Nahkampf-Warngriffe.
Wie das, wie das funktioniert, kann ich euch zeigen.
Zum Beispiel hat man, wenn man jetzt das hier nimmt, Drawout, da steht dran, was das, was das macht.
Also, es ist quasi, es hat ein Defense-Penalty, es hat einen hohen Bonus-To-Hit und Low-Damage.
Das ist also eigentlich für PvP nicht der optimale Style.
Aber, was Drawout hat, ist, ähm, äh, Taunt-Target.
Also, sprich, die Gegner sind wahrscheinlicher, mich anzugreifen.
Was jetzt in der Konzeption ist, ist, dass die Gegner, die Gegner sind, die Gegner sind, die Gegner sind, die Gegner sind.
Was jetzt in der Konstellation gar nicht so sinnvoll ist, mit einem Krieger dabei, die können eigentlich ruhig stehen, hitten.
Was ist denn da oben?
Ah, das ist ein Hit.
Und die Styles, also Nahkampf-Warngriffe nennen sich in Dark Styles, die Styles haben oftmals unterschiedliche Voraussetzungen.
Guckt, der hier zum Beispiel, der geht nur, wenn man in Front of Target ist.
Oh, Speed vergessen.
Der geht nur, wenn man direkt in Front, also wenn man quasi so vor dem Gegner steht, so, ich glaub, irgendwie so bis zu 60 Grad Winkel oder sowas.
Würde das funktionieren?
Und Drawout ist Opening, also wichtig ist bei Opening, Anytime, das heißt, geht immer.
Dann hat man so Sachen wie zum Beispiel Follow-Up.
Also, sprich, man muss zuerst den einen Style machen, dann den anderen.
Es ist relativ simpel, ja, es ist relativ simpel.
Also, man muss sagen, wenn du einen reinen Nahkampf-Char spielst in Dark, also, du verbiegst dir nicht gerade die Hände.
Nice.
Schön, dass wir, wir schön auf der Karte angezeigt jetzt.
Top.
Topke!
Aber der ist Level 19, der ist fast weg hier.
Oh ne, shit, ich hab nicht geguckt, wo, wo, what the, oh.
Oh shit, Bade, Bade, Bade, Bade.
Bade steht.
Bade steht nicht, fuck.
Okay, wir sind dead.
Wir sind, wir sind dead.
Wir sind dead, wir sind dead.
Wir sind dead.
So sieht das aus, wenn man gepfarmt wird von der Seite.
So sah das eben bei den Gegnern aus.
Und das sind auch etwas zu viele.
Oh ne, wir brauchen 29 Sekunden, bis man gebufft werden kann.
So sah das eben für die anderen aus, als wir die von der Seite weggeballert haben.
Ja, dazu kommt, weil es eine Hybridklasse ist,
es gibt neben Nahkampfangriffen, kriegt man auch noch eine Spelllinie.
Skalde ist tatsächlich eines der simpleren Klassen.
Man hat nicht wirklich viel, was man managen muss.
Eigentlich musst du eine halbwegs gute Position haben und dann geht das.
Skalde ist gut Solo, in der Gruppe.
Also, ach guck mal da, ach, die machen das gleiche wie wir, sie sind fertig mit dem Battleground.
Deswegen haben die sich hier gerade gewiped.
Nice.
Und es gibt auch eine Sache, die man auch nicht unbedingt machen sollte.
Im PvP, und das ist einfach blind sticken.
Man hat eben gesehen, dass es keine gute Idee ist.
Also sticken ist quasi hinterherlaufen.
Quasi direkt.
Sollen wir das gelinkt aufnehmen?
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, da wissen alle, dass wir da sind.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so eine gute Idee ist.
Ne, ne, gut, machen wir auch nicht.
Ja, es ist meistens keine.
Voll gute Idee.
Weil wenn du das Gelinkt aufnimmst, wirst du immer auf der Karte markiert für alle.
Jo, und ihr habt es gerade gesehen, wenn man stickt und hier auf dem Klumpen läuft, dann steht man halt auch mal schnell.
Das heißt, es ist immer besser, wenn man etwas destickt läuft, so wie ich.
Gerade, weil ich Instant Interrupt habe für die Gegner.
Brauchen wir das Viech?
Ich denke mal schon.
Bin mir noch nicht sicher, welchen Shortcut ich hier wie.
Aber wisst ihr, was ich gut finde?
Der Danik, bei mir aus der Gruppe, der scheint gerne Gruppeninvites zu machen und Sachen zu managen.
Guck, der invitet die Leute und sowas.
Das ist mega praktisch, jetzt gerade, wenn ich am Streamsort bin, am Schwätzen bin.
Da muss ich das nicht machen, weil mein Hirn schafft es nicht, das noch nebenbei zu machen.
Guck, jetzt kann ich euch das mit dem Style mal zeigen.
Wenn ich jetzt zu dem, ja, das Viech, ich stelle mich jetzt vor das Viech.
Dann kann ich den Style machen, weil das ein Front-Style ist.
Wenn ich hinter dem Viech stehe und versuche den Style reinzuhauen, guckt, dann geht das nicht.
Also da muss man ein bisschen auf die Position gucken.
Ansonsten ist es super easy, weil Dark auch recht, sagen wir mal, recht laggy ist.
Und du kannst, also richtig, die richtig guten Leute, das ist ein bisschen verpönt, aber wie gesagt, ich finde, es gehört, wenn man Melee-Charakter spielt, irgendwie dazu.
Man kann ziemlich gut um Gegner strafen.
Also durch Gegner, durch Strafen, an die Seite strafen.
Und dementsprechend kannst du aus fast jeder Position Positional-Nahkampfangriffe treffen, die du eigentlich nicht treffen können solltest.
Der Netcode ist für 56k und ISDN gebaut, ja, das ist korrekt.
Das ist richtig.
Moment, habe ich jetzt nicht sogar schon Water-Buff mit 10?
Nee, ich habe Water-Buff, jawohl, beste.
Water-Buff, jetzt können wir sogar schneller schwimmen.
Exzellent.
Und jetzt hier, guckt, stellt euch vor, eine gegnerische Gruppe kommt von der Seite, die stehen alle hier, weil die so auf dem Haufen sind.
Deswegen versuche ich immer ein bisschen die Stick zu laufen.
Wir warten übrigens auf Monster, auf Monster-Respawn.
Muss ich gar nichts machen, guckt, Bäm.
10 von 10, Eats.
Was gibt's denn hier?
Eis.
Warum durfte ich das Ding hier vorhin eigentlich nicht anziehen?
Hat das irgendwie spezielle Sachen?
Ach, guck mal hier, Replenish Target Power Pool.
Ach, guck mal, das Item hat einen Charge.
Ja, das ist nice.
Level Requirement 20.
Ja, alles klar.
Toll.
Trinkets.
Hier ist das Hip-Häuschen für den Token Merchant.
Ja, aber was ihr auch daran seht, man kann, wenn man eine Gruppe hat, man kann auch komplett im PvP leveln.
Wir sind jetzt schon Level 15 und wir sind eineinhalb Stunden oder so am Start.
Das ist jetzt nicht wahnsinnig schnell, muss man sagen.
Also wenn man eine wirklich gut optimierte Gruppe hat und einfach nur sinnlos PvP macht,
mit Bomben und allem, dann ist man das auch schnell.
Aber nachdem wir ja quasi alle Solos sind, die sich jetzt hier in Groups zusammengeschlossen haben und nicht irgendwie Premade-Gruppe,
ist das gar nicht so schlecht.
Also läuft ganz gut.
So.
Oh, die Albsen am Start.
Mit diesen Tokens, die man hier in jedem Battleground bekommt, also mit...
Ach, guck mal, was läuft denn da unten?
Ey, das ist ein...
Ach, die Brücke, man.
Mit den Tokens, die man bekommt hier in jedem Battleground,
kann man zu diesem Zelt gehen, wo wir eben gerade dran vorbeigelaufen sind.
Und an diesem Zelt steht so ein Händler, dem kann man die Tokens geben.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wo das Mittent ist, das ist mein Problem.
Und dann beschwört der so einen Belagerungs-Mob, der zum Keep in die Mitte rennt und die Tür einschlägt.
Dann kann man einfacher rein.
Hoffe, man versteht das.
Ich hab mir aufgeschrieben.
Wenn wir hier mit PvP und...
Wenn ein bisschen Luft ist, dass ich euch was zeigen kann.
Ich hab mir aufgeschrieben, ich wollte euch mal ganz kurz zeigen.
Falls irgendjemand mal reingucken möchte.
Übersicht, was es für Klassen gibt, erzähle ich euch einfach dann, während wir PvM machen.
Und dann noch...
Ja, genau.
Ach, stimmt.
Und Übersicht über meine Skills.
Wo ist das Zelt für die Tokens, man?
Wir suchen unser Zelt.
Da ist das Zelt.
Und da ist auch unser...
Da ist auch unser Token-Dude.
Jawoll.
Hier.
Tokens.
Gibt ein bisschen XP.
Und wenn wir genug Tokens reingegeben haben...
Äh, da ist ein...
Da ist ein...
Da ist ein Nekro irgendwo, oder?
Da ist ein Nekro.
Aber ein großer Nekro.
Weiß nicht, ob das so eine gute Idee ist, den anzugreifen.
High...
Highspeed...
Highspeed-Mob am Start.
Der ist richtig...
Fast and Furious, ja.
Er wird immer langsamer.
Auf Siege-Giant.
Gib alles, Mann.
Was ist da unten?
Ah, Grab.
Wenn man stirbt, gibt es ein Grab.
Da kann man beten gehen.
Und kriegt wieder ein bisschen XP zurück.
Die Alps rennen weg!
Kick, wait!
Kick!
Oh, nein!
Nice, Level up.
Okay, ich muss ein Stückchen weg.
Ich muss ein Stückchen weg.
Ich habe keine Resis.
Ich bin instant...
Ich bin instant dead.
Wenn einer auf mich castet.
Nice, GG.
Shit, shit, shit, shit.
Wir müssen da rein.
Okay.
Der steht.
Sehr gut.
Äh, warum...
Warum hauen wir den Tank?
Das ist richtig dumm.
Sollten nicht den Tank hauen, Mann.
Das ist der Nekro.
Okay, der kriegt...
Der kriegt Damage hier.
Sehr gut.
Ich laufe dem einfach hinterher.
Sobald er stehen bleibt...
...ist er dead.
Ich warte nur, bis ich Speed habe.
Moment, das ist ein Reaver?
Das ist ein fucking Reaver, Alter.
Mit Stoffrüstung.
So leben noch Leute von mir hier am Keep?
Ich glaube schon.
Okay, fuck, der ist dead.
Nope.
Ich glaube, die sind...
Ich glaube, die sind alle dead.
Aber die Nekros...
Die Nekros haben es gerissen, Leute.
Die Nekros haben es gerissen.
Auf, Kollege, komm.
Wir gehen zurück zu unseren...
...zu unseren Jungs.
Warum klicke ich eigentlich?
Ich habe doch meine Shortcuts mittlerweile am Start.
Aber gut.
Gut RPs gemacht.
Gut...
Gut XP.
Kann man nichts sagen.
Ist okay.
Ich meine, Nekros sind eh in den unteren BGs extrem schwierig zu killen mit einer Nahkampfgruppe.
Die machen übelst Damage.
Die halten übelst aus.
Die kannst du so gut wie gar nicht interrupten.
Und die sind höheres Level als wir.
Also Nekros zacken.
Eigentlich ist das so richtig Instant Win Button für die Albs auf dem Level.
Guck mal.
Da kommen sie.
Ja.
Und auch so ein Ding in Damok.
Es gibt Speed 1 bis 5.
Hat die jeweilige...
Ja.
Ich stelle jetzt mal Musikklasse in jedem Realm.
Aber wenn du sprintest, wird das oftmals Speed 6 genannt.
Weil du quasi nochmal genauso viel zusätzlichen Runspeed kriegst wie mit so einem Speed Buff.
Killer noch.
Ich habe ja kaum eine.
Ja.
Und gegen Nekros ist das Beste, wenn du Caster hast.
Also Magiedamage.
Weil die Nekro...
Die Nekropads halten nicht viel aus.
Guck mal.
Das Tor ist schon auf.
Nice.
Die Albs haben...
Guck mal.
Und deswegen ist Three Realm Combat das Beste.
Die Albs haben das Tor kaputt gemacht.
Und wir gehen ja jetzt rein.
Gleich.
Und...
Warum will der nicht rein?
Ja.
Genau.
Die Albs...
Die bashen uns gleich, die Albs.
Ja.
Wenn sie schnell genug sind.
Die kommen gleich rein und bashen uns.
Do we have rams?
No.
Ich habe keine rams.
Oh, ich muss meine...
Ink, ink, ink, ink.
Okay.
Albs kommen an den Start.
Jetzt müssen wir gucken, dass die hier...
Wenn die hier reinkommen...
Wir können die killen, wenn die reinkommen.
Das geht.
Den...
Muss ich mal abstellen, kurz da hinten.
Jetzt müssen wir gucken, wenn die Albs reinkommen...
Warum setze ich mich hin?
Wenn die Albs reinkommen...
Ich habe da schon was durch die Wand klitschen sehen gerade.
Albi und Siege Golem, okay.
Ach, das habe ich durch die Wand klitschen sehen.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, Albs kommen.
Albs kommen.
Achtung, lass dich nicht baiten.
Lass dich nicht baiten.
Die Nekros.
Die Nekros ficken uns jetzt halt gleich.
Wir können nicht raus.
Sobald wir um die Ecke gehen, sind wir dead.
Und die sind auch noch higher level als wir.
Okay, den können wir killen.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
Wir müssen langsam rauspushen.
Langsam rauspushen.
Nicht overextenden.
Nicht übertreiben.
Die haben nämlich...
Die haben Wachen add.
Sehr schön.
Darkspeak.
Ich kann es gerade nicht ändern.
So, mal kurz die Pets anhauen, dass die aufhören zu casten.
Wache taunten und zurück ins Keep.
Ich habe Endosong laufen.
Okay, nice.
Ja, haben wir gut gemacht.
Haben wir gut gemacht.
Und den können wir wieder beleben.
Hit door.
Ja.
Door ist auf 22.
Easy.
Müssen wir uns beeilen.
Wir haben leider keine Ramme dabei.
Ich habe nicht gedacht, dass wir jetzt gerade siechen gehen hier.
Weil die Alps sind gleich wieder am Start.
100 pro.
So, brauchen unsere Heiler.
Brauchen unsere Heiler Mana.
Ich glaube, wir brauchen eher Endo für das...
Ne, ich habe keine Ramme.
Ich habe nicht gedacht, dass wir jetzt hier irgendwas machen wollen in der Richtung.
Alle müssen Damage machen.
Theoretisch müssen sogar die Caster ran.
Also eigentlich müssten jetzt sogar, dass es schnell geht, die Heiler ran und mit dem Hammer draufklatschen.
Weil die Alps, die respawnen hier unten.
Und die sind in drei Minuten sind wieder da.
Und wir sind super langsam.
Bis wir das aufgeschlagen haben.
Wir sind super langsam.
Guck mal, ohne Ramme.
Alps will be back, korrekt.
Ne, ich habe keine Ramme.
Ich habe keine Ramme mitgenommen, Mann.
Ich hätte nicht damit gerechnet.
Ich hätte nicht damit gerechnet, dass wir eine Ramme brauchen.
Okay, was brauche ich denn noch für Rüstung?
Ich könnte...
Eigentlich habe ich alles.
Armlinge, okay, nice.
Habe ich auch hier.
Füße, Hände, Kopf.
Könnte ich noch gebrauchen.
Tokens.
Ich habe auch Tokens.
Es dauert zu lang.
Wir sollten alle unsere Tokens...
Abgeben.
Ja, ich weiß, dass 50 nicht reichen.
Sollten Tokens.
Wir sollten Tokens.
Hipster coming, okay.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung.
Hipster am Start.
Leute, Gegner kommen.
Ich sage euch mal was.
Ich gehe mal kurz hoch.
Da können wir runter gucken.
Wobei ich unten sein muss.
Es bringt nichts, wenn ich als Nahkampfcharakter oben bin.
Aber ich kann es euch mal zeigen von oben.
Also, man kann...
Kann man runter gucken.
Dann sieht man auch ein bisschen was.
Aber es ist eigentlich...
Ziemlich, ziemlich Low-IQ als Nahkampfcharakter oben auf der, auf der Feste rumzulaufen.
Okay.
Es ist...
Es dauert auf 14.
Okay, okay.
Steady.
Wir sind, wir sind nicht schnell.
Wir sind langsam.
Aber es passt.
Und immer wichtig.
NPC-Wachen taunten.
Alter, ich kriege so Damage von dem Viech.
Damit sie nicht auf die Heiler gehen.
Weil es gibt eine Sache, die noch mehr die...
Also, Mobs und...
Und Wachen tauntet als Damage.
Das ist Heilung.
Heilen zieht in dem Spiel echt die meiste Agro.
Gibt es irgendwas, was ich noch austauschen kann?
Also, Hose haben...
Okay, Beine.
Beine, Kopf, Hände bräuchte ich noch.
Oder einen Gürtel.
Gürtel habe ich keinen mehr.
Kommt von hinten was? Nope.
Okay, 11%.
Ich brauche noch unbedingt mehr Hips, äh, mehr Mids, die hier rankommen.
High-Octane-Gameplay, wie ihr seht hier.
Wir schlagen aufs Tor.
Ja, aufmacht die Wache, Blattmann.
Wir können die Caster jetzt umnuken, nachdem er die getauntet hat.
So, 10%.
10%, okay.
Ich muss auf jeden Fall gucken, dass ich ein bisschen Endu behalte.
Äh, wie?
Ich sehe keinen Guard, Guards, die respawnen sind.
Ich muss auf jeden Fall gucken, dass ich ein bisschen Mama
und Endu behalte.
Also, ich sollte jetzt keinen Mana mehr raushauen, sinnlos.
Wir können sogar mal kurz...
Können theoretisch sogar mal kurz Mana-Song reinswitchen.
Nee, Damage, Damage-Add und Endu ist das Beste, was wir jetzt machen können in der Situation.
Also, ich habe verschiedene, ich habe ja verschiedene Spells.
Ich wollte euch das ja eigentlich mal zeigen.
Also, ich habe verschiedene Songs, weil ich bin Skalde, ja.
Also, das sind, das sind eigentlich Songs, sieht man ja auch.
Gibt halt keine Song-Sounds irgendwie in dem Spiel.
Ich habe, äh, Endu.
Also, Ausdauer, Reduktion, Speed, schneller rennen, mehr Nahkampfschaden und, äh, Leben regenerieren und, ähm, Mana regenerieren.
Und in dem Fall, wenn man an so einem Tor ist, bietet sich an, mehr Nahkampfschaden und, ähm, Ausdauer-Reduktion.
Da kann man nämlich konstanter aufs Tor prügeln und macht mehr Schaden.
Weil ich mir gar nicht sicher bin, ob es Damage-Add, nee, Damage-Add am Tor gibt es gar nicht.
Nein, Advent of Code haben wir noch nicht gemacht.
Ich muss bis heute Abend Kreisel-Crime machen.
Und mein, mein Mid-Level.
Alp ist schon 50.
Jetzt Zeit für Mid.
Okay.
Gleiches, gleiches.
Jetzt ist, jetzt kommt es halt echt drauf an.
Scheiß drauf.
Tor aufmachen.
Okay, dann, wir müssen von unseren Heilern.
Also, immer Wachen von Heilern und Castern weg.
Das ist wichtig.
Ja.
So, und den Rest können die machen.
Und wir hauen jetzt weiter aufs Tor.
Hauptsache, Hauptsache immer die Wache taunten.
So, 3% Tor.
Die anderen, die Alps haben schon keinen Bock mal zu defenden.
Ich krieg ziemlich Damage, Leute.
Es wäre nice, wenn ich einen Heal bekommen könnte.
Äh, nice.
Ich werde geheilt.
Okay, das, immerhin.
Ich will mich ja nicht beschweren.
Ich weiß, als Heiler ist echt stressig.
Gerade, wenn du auf alles achten musst.
Und in BG ist Heiler zu spielen nochmal doppelt stressig.
Weil du kaum Mana hast, diesen Cast-Speed und alles.
So, Tor ist gleich offen.
Ich hoffe, jetzt kommen nicht die Alps noch um die Ecke.
Zwei Sekunden vorher.
Okay.
0, 0% Tor, geh auf.
Nächster Style.
So.
Und jedes, jede Festung hat einen Miniboss im Endeffekt.
Alter, Mana kriegt es voll.
Kälte, Kälte, Kälte, Kälte.
Bashen.
Das war jetzt wieder ein Gegner.
Ein echter.
So, alle rein ins Keep.
Alle rein ins Keep.
Wir können den Heiler nachholen.
Wir können den Heiler nachher retzen.
Der liegt im Keep.
Der kriegt XP.
Wache taunten.
Dass sie nicht auf die Heiler und auf die Caster geht.
Jetzt hoch zum Lord.
Das ist so quasi so ein Miniboss, der in jedem Keep oben ist.
Kann eigentlich auch nichts.
Oh, oh.
Ich krieg Damage.
Ich krieg...
Ich mach nichts mehr.
Ich krieg mega krass Damage.
Heil.
Heal, please.
Prage.
Heil mich.
Heiler.
Er hat kein Mana mehr.
Okay, oder?
Egal, nice.
Wir haben alle Level bekommen.
Sollen wir recht sein.
War knapp.
So ein Rats wär nice.
Heiler, du darfst mich wiederbeleben.
Besser mit Waffs vom Keep.
Okay.
Haben wir gut gemacht.
Gleich nochmal ein Keep eingenommen.
So, haben wir Deserter-Skill-Allow-Of-Friend.
Moment, hab ich überhaupt die Deserter-Quest?
Deserter allerdings, ja, hab ich.
Okay, dann renn ich mal schnell zurück zu meiner Group.
Ich bin 1L3.
Ich hoffe, ich kann Longwind 2 kaufen.
Mana hat's wieder am Start.
Nice.
Guck mal, wir sind auch alle relativ hohes Level.
Wir kommen...
Wir leveln alle ungefähr zeitgleich aus dem BG raus.
Wir könnten gleich in das nächste...
Okay.
Da sind die Jungs hier.
Guckt's euch an.
Wir sind am Start.
Wie der Fabian jetzt sagen würde.
Am Start.
Wir können...
Zelt-Zeugs abgeben.
Falls der Dude da ist.
Nee, der ist nicht da. Shit.
Okay.
Ähm...
So.
Ich müsste jetzt mal...
Ich müsste jetzt mal trainieren schnell.
Aber erstmal aufholen.
Ja.
Ich brauch unbedingt Longwind 2.
Jetzt kann ich euch auch gleich zeigen,
was man davon hat, wenn man PvP macht in dem Spiel.
Also...
Eine der Sachen, die man Vorteile hat.
Und zwar...
Ich bin jetzt...
Rang 1L3.
Also es gibt quasi so 10, 10...
Eigentlich 11 oder...
Nee, ich glaub sogar 14 mittlerweile.
Hauptränge und jeweils immer 10 Unterränge oder 9 Unterränge.
Guck mal da.
Alps am Start.
Lapps.
Die gibt...
Oh, das sind ganz schön viele.
Oh, und das sind auch noch...
Das sind auch noch Hips am Start.
Okay, wir sollten...
Wir sollten auf jeden Fall die Hips fokussen.
Und nicht...
Und nicht die Alps.
Nicht die Alps.
Wir sollen die Hips fok...
Jawoll!
Damage, damage, damage.
Volle, volle, volle, volle.
Ja, ja.
Der muss umkippen, bevor die Heiler wieder über den Berg kommen.
Jawoll.
Okay.
Alps, lasst die Alps.
Macht die Hips...
Macht die Hips down.
Sehr gut.
Jetzt rüber zu den anderen.
Und da seht ihr...
Drei reiche PvP ist das Beste.
Wir haben die jetzt voll ass jammed.
Im Endeffekt.
Gachibas.
Richtig geass jammed.
So, snare.
Der Bade...
Der Bade darf nicht frei werden.
Doch, der Bade wird frei.
Nicht ganz.
Oh, ich sprinte ja gar nicht.
Ich kack noob, alter.
Wie der letzte Kackbun, ey.
Ja, guck mal, wie er versucht zu straven.
Wie er versucht zu straven.
Ihr kommt hier nicht weg, Leute.
Ihr kommt hier.
Du bleibst stehen.
Du kommst hier nicht weg, Mann.
So, jetzt, jetzt wird er mal outstraved.
Kann er mal sterben, please?
Jawoll.
Albs sind wieder am Start hier hinten.
Albs.
Okay, Albs da drüben.
Okay.
Alles tot.
Nice.
So mag ich das.
GG Eats.
RVR.
Genau.
Aber hier hast du es wieder gesehen.
Ohne Mist.
So, RVR mit drei Fraktionen oder PvP mit drei Fraktionen.
Das ist einfach das Beste.
Weil während die anderen sich gekloppt haben, wir waren weniger.
Ihr habt es gesehen.
Wir waren weniger.
Sind drauf und haben die taktisch geschickt weggebashed.
Nämlich zuerst die, die gewonnen hätten und dann haben wir aufgeräumt.
Ja.
Was hast du mit Max FPS gemacht?
Ich habe nur das Logo geklaut.
Ich bin wubblos.
Ich glaube, wir haben jetzt hier alles.
An was ist er denn gestorben?
Oh, oh, oh.
Ich kann nur.
Ich habe es gar nicht gesehen.
Ich habe es auch nicht gesehen.
Da waren zwei Ranger, Mann.
Im Baum.
Im Baum haben sie sich versteckt.
Keck wait, Mann.
So, was brauchen wir denn hier jetzt noch?
Oh, mein.
Oh Mist, Leute.
Mein Inf ist bald voll.
Okay, das können wir löschen.
Das bringt nichts, wenn ich das verkaufe.
Trinkets.
Fertig. Brauche ich eine neue Waffe?
Nein, noch nicht.
Hier oben, Leute.
Pilzpower.
Das ist der Brainhip.
Das ist ein Deutscher, soweit ich weiß.
Was heißt, soweit ich weiß? Ich weiß, dass es ein Deutscher ist.
Nicht nur,
der redet auch manchmal Deutsch.
Aber er hört sich auch
ansonsten sehr, sehr deutsch an.
Das ist der Brainhip.
Der ratet den ganzen Tag
irgendwelche Keeps.
Was geht denn da rechts ab?
Ist hier noch ein Boss, den wir
killen müssen? Oder was brauchen wir denn noch?
Was müssen wir
killen? Bogi-Spawns.
Ach, die kleinen Viecher
da vorne.
Diese Mini... Alter, was ist denn das?
Was ist das, Alter?
Ah, das sind die
Darkness-Falls-Mobs, nur in klein.
Okay, sieben Stück.
Sechs Stück noch.
Ich glaube, wir sind zu high level.
Das sind zu wenige
Mobs.
Wasser-Buff?
High IQ seitwärts laufen.
Hier im Wasser
ist noch einer.
Okay. Ich muss unbedingt
zum Zelt die Tokens abgeben. Das gibt
richtig dicke X-P.
Nochmal.
Aber du musst doch sagen...
Oder...
Chat, versteht man, dass ich da ohne Probleme
auch mal sechs Stunden Kreisel-Crime machen kann in dem Game?
Du kannst halt die ganze Zeit
irgendwas machen und du kannst
dir im Prinzip selbst ausdenken.
Möchtest du jetzt actionreich PvP?
Möchtest du eher ein bisschen
entspannt
ähm...
im Heimgebiet PvM machen?
Ist halt mega nice.
In MMOs gibt es immer
genug zu tun. Ehrlich gesagt
sehe ich nicht so.
Das letzte MMO, was wir
vom Scratch angefangen haben zusammen, also Fabian
und ich, war Final Fantasy 14.
Da war gerade
frisch das Addon raus.
Das war Heavensward, das erste Addon.
Haben wir gemacht. Haben das Addon durchgespielt.
Es gab nichts zu tun.
Außer angeln oder irgendwie so ein Blödsinn.
Asia-Crinder...
Asia-Crinder ist nicht so das.
Okay. Wir müssen
Hips bashen.
Keep. Immer schön
Kamera schwenken, umdrehen, gucken, dass man nicht
assjammed wird von der Seite.
Und ganz wichtig.
Fuck. Ich hab ein RP zu wenig.
Ich wollte Longwind 2
specken, dass ich besser
rennen kann.
Also Longwind 2 beim Leveln
finde ich lohnt sich extrem.
Dann verliert man nämlich viel weniger Ausdauer
beim Sprinten.
In Kombination mit meinem Song
für Endu-Reduzierung
ist das richtig nice.
Massive nice.
Da kann man nahezu unendlich sprinten.
Was essentiell für
Nahkampf-Character ist.
Weil, naja.
Rennen kostet Endu
und
Nahkampf-Draufschlagen kostet Endu.
Oh, rechts.
Alps!
Gib ihm! In your face!
Okay, die haben jetzt
Skeletten gehabt. Da machst du nix.
In den modernen MMOs
geht's nur noch um Endorphin-Instant-Creativik.
Das stimmt. Sehe ich auch so.
Deswegen mag ich das hier auch.
Hier musst du im Endeffekt selbst dafür sorgen,
dass du was auf die Reihe kriegst.
Du musst dir hier auch schon den Plan selbst machen.
Du kannst Sturm,
Killquest-Ablauf und du kannst PvP
machen. Du kannst auch irgendwelche
muss man ja schon sagen, ziemlich
Braindead, High-Level-PvP, äh
PvM-Content machen.
Du kannst, du hast eigentlich
den ganzen Tag was zu tun.
Und wenn du gar nichts mehr zu tun hast,
machst du dir noch einen zweiten Charakter.
Oh, Hips hinter uns.
Bade? Ist das der Bade?
Ich hoffe, das ist der Bade.
Das ist der Bade.
Das ist der Bade. Der wird gefickt jetzt.
Der wird richtig...
Bade gemetzt. Jawoll.
Jawoll, jawoll, jawoll.
Kack-Noobs, Kack-Noobs. Get rekt.
Es wäre nice, wenn ich geheilt werde,
übrigens.
Alter, warum trainen die mich? Was ist mit euch los, Mann?
Seid ihr dumm?
Lasst mich in Ruhe.
Bade wieder am Start. Bade am Start.
Bade wird interrupted.
So geht das, Leute. So geht das.
Der Bade darf nie zum
Karsten kommen. Nie.
Oh, Truide gemetzt.
Bade interrupted.
Oh, shit.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. Ich bin out of range.
Ich bin out of range. Out of range. Ich bin dumm gelaufen.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ich bin out of range gelaufen.
Ja, das war dumm.
Ach, sind noch welche von der Seite?
Es sind noch mehr Gegner gekommen.
Deswegen.
Okay, da sind zwei Gruppen jetzt.
Und noch Alps von hinten.
Ja, gut. Da machst du nix.
Da machst du nix. Aber die ersten, die hatten wir eigentlich.
Was willst du machen, ne?
Noch schöne Bogey-Ads und alles.
Ja, aber so musst du das machen.
Der Bade darf nicht zum Karsten kommen.
Wenn der Bade zum Karsten kommt, ist man tot.
Also nicht, weil der Bade dich killt,
sondern weil er dafür sorgt,
dass du dich nicht mehr wehren kannst.
Dunning macht das wirklich gut.
Also sieht man, der hat schon mal Krieger gespielt.
Ja, jetzt ist, jetzt ist dead.
Jetzt, jetzt ist...
Das sind jetzt zu viele.
Guck mal. Das sind zwei Gruppen
plus irgendwelche Schleicher-Ads.
Da machst du nix.
Und noch ein paar.
Und noch Alps von hinten.
Best-Up-Game.
Also im Prinzip sind wir fast Max-Level für das BG.
Wir killen jetzt zwei Mobs
und dann ist es vorbei.
Wir können theoretisch, wenn alle 20 werden,
sogar in das nächste BG zusammen gehen.
Schauen wir mal.
Okay, ich brauche Hände und...
Ja, unbedingt Hände
und einen Helm.
Hab ich grad nicht.
Die Hips am Anfang hatten wir.
Das haben wir schon.
Richtig gut gemacht, muss man sagen.
Für das, dass das so unkoordiniert ist normalerweise in einem BG.
Ich meine, wir sind hier alle nicht im Voice-Chat.
Wir spielen hier quasi auf Sicht.
Man sieht durchaus, dass wir Leute in der Gruppe haben,
die schon mal ihren Charakter gespielt haben.
Auch der BD macht das hier.
Wie heißt der?
Dalamip.
Ist das...
Moment, ist da vorne was?
Ne, sind wir jetzt...
Dalamip.
Ist das der Name vielleicht umgedreht geschrieben,
wie er sonst...
Das heißt...
Bimalat...
Ne, nicht wirklich.
Der hat auch die richtigen Targets mit seinen Pets und sowas.
Und auch den Heiler, den wir da vorhatten.
Echt nicht übel.
Hat man nicht so oft.
Hat man echt nicht so oft.
Im BG.
Aber man darf nicht vergessen,
das Spiel ist halt 20 Jahre alt.
Dementsprechend, du hast den einen oder anderen,
der auch seinen Char halbwegs spielen kann.
Da oben.
Oben ist Ink.
Der Bade.
Nein, nein, nein, Bade.
Du machst nix.
Da steht er.
Kein Noob.
Nein, nein, du castest nicht.
Du castest nicht.
Da ist ein Schleicher, by the way.
Der Bade ist bald wieder frei.
Der Bade ist frei.
Ich muss auf den Bade.
Ohne Bade sind sie gefickt.
Der muss auf dem Druide bleiben, der andere.
Der muss auf dem Heiler bleiben, unbedingt.
Bade, Bade, komm.
Einmal Damage.
Jawohl, dead.
So, Caster.
Voll durch die Bombe gerannt, lull.
Alter, das werden ja immer mehr.
Fucking shit, man.
Das werden ja immer mehr, Alter.
Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Aber ich glaube, wir können das schaffen.
Okay, okay, nice.
Okay, ich lasse mich nicht backstylen.
Kein Gachi-Bass für euch, Leute.
Da kommen ja immer noch mehr.
Ich fass es nicht.
Wie viele Ads, man?
Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Wie viele Gegner kamen da noch zusätzlich?
Mensch, guck mal.
Wir haben irgendwie 10 gekillt.
Es sind wieder 10.
Die unendliche Respawn, man.
Ist die Kurve nicht extrem hoch bei Dark, da überhaupt reinzukommen?
Also, wenn man ganz alleine startet, ohne jegliche Unterstützung,
ohne Leute, die man fragen kann, braucht man eine Weile, bis man reinkommt.
Ich glaube, das kann man nicht bestreiten.
Aber, sagen wir mal so, es ist jetzt erstmal nicht relevant,
weil du musst nicht PvP leveln, würde ich dir sogar am Anfang auch gar nicht unbedingt empfehlen.
Komplett solo, das frustet eigentlich nur.
Äh, wo ist denn hier?
Oh, Moment, ich muss mal kurz porten.
Also, alleine frustet höchstwahrscheinlich nur, wenn man PvP macht.
Ich würde dir empfehlen, und da kommt man echt ganz gut rein,
einfach PvP, äh, PvM leveln, also ganz normale Kill-Tasks und Monster-Kram.
Und, und dann lernst du auch deinen Char kennen.
Und wenn du dann mal so Level 30 bist oder so, oder 20 oder sowas,
dann kannst du mal ein bisschen in BG gehen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen PvP schnuppern
und dann levelst du bis 50 durch, machst ein paar Raids mit 20.
Ich bin Level 20, so, Schwert.
Ein bisschen aufleveln, Assault, brauchen wir nicht.
Deton, braucht auch keiner.
Äh, ähm, lass uns mal kurz die Spells.
Abchecken.
Das da, ne Raid, gut, neuer Wasser-Buff.
Haben wir schon.
Haben wir schon, wird eh überschrieben im Endeffekt.
Wann gibt's einen neuen Speed auf 23?
You parry, na, das brauch ich nicht.
Sind da noch aktiv Spieler drin? Ja.
Ja, ich, das, wir haben heute nur PvP gespielt mit, mit und gegen.
Echte Spieler.
Hab ich den Char-Planer noch?
Irgendwo offen?
Wollt ich grad noch was checken.
Level 20.
20 und Rest Schwert.
Ähm, wann gibt's denn den nächsten Speed?
Das wollte ich eigentlich gucken.
23, okay, immer 3, 13, 23, 33, 43.
Okay, während der, während, äh, Danik Afghis.
Ah ne, der ist schon wieder da.
Ich wollte euch sagen, kann ich euch da ein bisschen was zeigen?
Aber, also das, ich bin echt froh, dass ihr da seid.
Also, das, ich bin echt froh, dass ihr da seid.
Also, das, ich bin echt froh, dass ich den gleich auf Level 1 hier jetzt getroffen hab.
Der übernimmt auch das Crew-Builden und sowas, was sehr, sehr nice ist.
Übrigens, von der Gruppe weiß keiner, dass sie grad im Stream sind.
Was ist denn das da?
Ah, ein, ein mit.
So, nächstes Battle-Crowned.
Wir warten einfach mal, was der, der kann den einfach einladen hier.
Auf BD, Caster drauf.
Slash-Up hat keinen Bock.
Äh, achso, was ist das für ein Spiel?
Jetzt hab ich gar nicht, das ist Dark Edge of Camelot auf dem Eden-Free-Chart.
Ja, man muss sagen, manche Leute haben's noch nicht so richtig gecheckt, dass die Regeln auf Eden ein bisschen anders sind.
Normalerweise ist es extrem verpönt, Mobs anzugreifen, also Monster, die andere Leute schon attackiert haben.
Allerdings, auf Eden nicht.
Auf Eden haben sie's nämlich gescheit gemacht, wo ich mich gefragt habe, warum haben die das nicht auf Live schon vor Jahrzehnten gefühlt gemacht.
Ähm, auf Eden kriegst du Quests trotzdem und Sachen trotzdem.
Auch wenn du die Mobs anhaust.
Wo jemand anderes schon draufgeschlagen hat.
Es ist auch komplett dumm, wenn nicht.
Da wurde so krass rumgegrieft früher.
So mit, äh, ich klau dir Mobs, ich greif deine Mobs an, dann gibt's keine XP und sowas.
Muss mal kurz den Heilsong anmachen.
Ich lass die mal kurz hier ein bisschen bashen.
Ich, ich rack mal schnell.
Den, den hitten wir hier.
Okay, na, ist fertig.
Hä, jetzt ist er back.
Dann.
Wir sind fertig, ne?
Wir sind, Return to Captain.
Ja.
Und ja, da ist alles.
Derhmen wir jetzt gleich wieder ein, oder?
Immerhin in den letzten, äh, Tag.
Jetzt, hm.
Also, ich würde sagen, ich würde sagen, ich würde sagen, geht nicht alles gut.
Aber, ähm, ja, wir haben jetzt, äh, das ist jetzt und das ist, äh, sehen wir gleich.
Das ist, äh, äh, das ist der, die sich jetzt, äh, sieht ganz genau um nicht gerade ganz genau aus ist.
Und die sind halt, ähm, ähm, man kann ja auch in der ohne, äh, wie auch immer, ähm, irgendwie ganz gut.
Äh, circa da.
ich unbedingt nur noch zum zum weiter level 1 l4 dann habe ich nämlich genug punkte um mir
longwind 2 zu kaufen da kann ich nahezu unendlich sprinten auch ohne endo pots was sehr nice ist
guck mal der krieger macht das hier solo jetzt easy kein problem der stellst die alleine weg
und ich krieg schon fast auf den sack von einem einzelnen orangenen krieger ist mit der beste
reine nahkampf charakter oder hell wie nennt man das eigentlich nahkampf klasse im spiel man
kann nicht drüber streiten die sind eigentlich alle ziemlich gut die die main tanks der jeweiligen
reich sind eigentlich alle ganz gut die mitte gehen gehen deserters oder irgendwo hier sind
die irgendwie sind die anderen mit 10 hier müssen wir gucken weil die sind als da gehen wir nicht
hin hier vorne ist die alp pg da vorne ist die alp pg
da sind auch die metz null ich hab nichts gesagt okay wir rennen mal mit dem mit drum ja und wie
gesagt zum thema aktive spieler zum thema aktive mitspieler auf die tage ist die neue season
gestartet mit saumäßig vielen verbesserungen und richtig geilen sachen für alle für alle
langzeit langzeit dauerung spieler und sind abends aktuell würde ich sagen so
3500 Leute
ungefähr on, so würde ich sagen, ich glaube, die haben
gar keine richtigen Spielzahlen, aber da haben wir
ungefähr 3500 Leute
und das wird die nächsten Monate
über, also am Anfang
jetzt gerade wird es wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen
mehr, so die ersten paar Wochen
das wird die nächsten Monate wieder ein bisschen
droppen, so auf
und so zwischen 2000 und
2500, sagen wir mal zwischen 1500
und 2000, wird es da eine
ganze Weile bleiben und das ist
also bis dann die Season
oder weniger durch ist
und das ist
super zum Spielen, oh guck mal
Alps, ach da sind
sie wieder, lol
das sind die von eben
erkennt ihr sie wieder
ich erkenne diesen komischen
Bretonenbinde wieder, ey was ist mit euch
los, du bleibst hier
du bleibst hier
das sind die von eben, die wir eben schon mal
weggeklatscht haben
immer schön seitlich laufen
du bleibst hier
äh wo
sterben unsere Leute, hallo woran
sterben gerade Leute
what the fuck
wo sterben
die denn, sind die da hinten
noch, oh da hinten im
Wasser ist noch was, lol
oh
ich vergesse immer, dass ich die Song schon angemacht hab
hier hinten im Wasser war noch was
oh da hinten ist ein Nekro, oh attacke
ok ich brauch unbedingt Longwind 2, 1L3, man
ich brauch mehr Arpies
mehr Arpies
da sind sie wieder
wow
alter, rekt
der hat mich beat, voll in your face
hahaha
tja, das geht bei Schleichern ganz gut
ähm
ich release schnell und komm zurück
der hat mir voll ins Gesicht beat
also es gibt
so zur erklärung
Schleicher
sind alles Sacken eigentlich, so
außer in 1vs1 Files und so was, aber
das Ding is'
also in Gruppenfiles
falls kannst du kannst du schleicher vergessen aber also jedes jedes klasse
hat so eine 12 schleicher klassen und die haben in allen reichen eine
fähigkeit und zwar wenn die direkt vor einem stehen und getan sind dann können
die so ein super krass angriff machen und den habe ich gerade komplett ins
gesicht bekommen normalerweise passiert das nicht weil
du normalerweise nicht frontal auf den schleicher zuläuft der getarnt ist aber
das hat mich ziemlich ziemlich zerrissen gerade ich brauche eine neue waffe
bounty merchant ich brauche eine neue waffe und zwar great swords 15 bounty
points also danik muss weg das game war noch nie offline
es gibt wieder in season 2 seit samstag und deswegen gibt es wieder ein paar tausend
spieler die spielen gleich wird ein bisschen entspannter gleich machen wir
ein bisschen solo pvp quest oder mal gucken mal gucken ich werde auf jeden
fall nicht solo spiel oder pvp spielen ohne dass hier gescheiterted am start sind
Alter, wo ist der BD?
Wir haben den irgendwie
verloren, oder? Ich habe doch
extra Wasser-Buff gemacht. Du kannst tauchen.
Du kannst tauchen. Ja, komm ins Wasser.
Wir haben unseren BD verloren.
Unser BD ist sonst wo da hinten.
Den sollten wir aber mal einsammeln
gehen. Das ist, oh, das ist
super risky, wo der langläuft. Der läuft direkt
an der Brücke, wo die Alps langkommen.
Okay, vielleicht kriegen wir ein paar Desserte.
Also, ich werde euch jetzt mal kurz
erzählen, für alle, die vielleicht früher schon mal
Dark
für die Leute, die schon mal ein bisschen früher
Dark gespielt haben, ein paar Sachen, die die bei
Eden geändert haben. Es gibt
jetzt eine Sache, die sich alle gewünscht
haben. Es gibt ab und zu Home-Invasion-Events,
dass du quasi
bis ins, bis in das
innere Land des jeweiligen
anderen Realms rein kannst.
Das gibt es nicht dauerhaft, das gibt es nur Events,
aber das ist mega nice.
Das ist nicht Ingame-Musik, das ist eine Playlist.
Wo sind Gegner?
Ich sehe keine Gegner.
Ach, hier neben dir.
Ja. Oh, wir kriegen gleich
auf den Sack. Oh, jetzt kommt
Sneaking-Tactics.
Ja, also, es gibt ab und zu
Home-Invasion-Events.
Das Leveln ist, finde ich,
viel angenehmer als früher,
weil du mit
Killtasten und PvP ordentlich leveln kannst.
Hier, Stelz-Modus aktiviert,
Leute. Niemand, niemand
kommt drauf, dass wir hier stehen.
Hier unten sind übrigens
die Alps. Sieht man auf der Map.
Die haben quasi
ein, ich glaube, die haben ein Relikt,
dass man sie sieht.
Oder ist das eine Alp-BG, dass man sie sieht?
Ich bin mir unschlüssig gerade.
Die sehen uns auf der Map
auf jeden Fall nicht.
Haben die Radar? Woher wissen die,
dass wir da sind, Alter?
Das ist eine Playlist von YouTube.
Was ist denn?
Was machen die Alps da unten?
Wir brauchen eigentlich nur die Gegner hier.
Dann haben wir die Quests für das BG auch fertig.
Wir haben schon...
Ein Level haben wir schon durch.
Wir hauen mal ab.
Warum wir hier rumrennen ist,
wir sind nur vier und das andere sind zehn plus.
Da können wir
nichts machen.
Gar nicht auf dem Level.
Die campen den Spot da oben.
Da oben sind zwei gelaufen gerade.
Die machen die Quests,
die Alps da oben.
Die machen die Quests.
Wie viele Mids haben wir?
Wir haben 19.
Wir haben 19
hier.
Im BG.
Und wir sind nur vier.
Wo ist denn der Rest von uns?
Pentium 2 oder höher?
2002 rum war das.
Ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher.
Oh shit.
Oh, S-Champ.
S-Champ.
Oh, fuck, der hat uns gesehen.
Wir sind gefickt.
Okay, wir sind dead.
Officially dead.
Alter, so viele Mobs auch dabei.
Nice.
Officially dead sind wir.
Offiz...
Es ist offiziell...
Naja.
Amdi, Adlon.
Ja, ich glaube, ich hatte einen Adlon.
1.900?
Gab es sowas?
Okay, Gruppe ist...
Gruppe ist fertig.
Alles klar.
Dann...
Disbande ich mal.
Und...
Jetzt kann ich aber ein bisschen was über das Game machen.
Was ich euch die ganze Zeit schon erzählen wollte.
Und zwar...
Nur für den Fall der Fälle.
Dass irgendjemand...
Doch...
Ja, wie soll ich sagen?
Den...
Die Lust verspürt...
Sich das mal anzugucken, das Game.
Also ich...
Ich will euch jetzt nichts erzählen, dass das super einfach ist vom Einstieg.
Ist es nicht.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, ob ich mir nicht gescheite...
Gescheite Rüstungen...
Auskauf.
Bounty Points 305.
Okay, lass mal...
Lass mal...
Lass mal ein bisschen...
Pfeifert sein.
Lass mal ein bisschen Pfeifert sein.
Okay.
Schwerter haben wir ganz gut.
Rüstung ist auch durchaus noch okay.
Ich würde sagen, wir brauchen gar keine Bounty Points auszugeben.
Wir gehen einfach zum Quartermaster und holen uns dort was.
Wenn ich wüsste, wo der aktuelle Quartermaster ist.
Ich glaube in der Grenz.
Ich glaube in der Grenzfestung.
Gucken wir mal.
Und ich sell den Rest mal.
Wie war das?
Shift-S zum sellen?
Äh.
Shift-S?
Achso, man kann das nicht verkaufen.
Kann man doch zerstören.
Shift-S.
Wie man damit macht.
Wie sehen eigentlich meine Stats aktuell aus?
Lasst mal kurz checken.
Ich brauche Stärke.
Volle Pulle.
Quickness.
Ein bisschen Constitutional.
Und Charisma.
Charisma fehlt mir.
Das ist jetzt aber erstmal nicht so wild.
Hits.
Quickness.
Decks.
Magic Skills.
Constitution.
Parry.
Ich nicht.
So.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Wollen wir kurz gucken.
Constitution.
Strength.
Quickness.
Das ist top.
Das wollen wir nicht.
Speedy Belt.
Quickness.
Okay, der suckt.
Der Sackt ja noch mehr.
Alter, okay.
Lol, weh.
Schrott.
Aber hier.
Constitution.
Quickness.
Hits.
Das ist ganz gut.
Quickness.
Constitution.
Spirit.
Decks.
Okay.
Nehmen wir auf jeden Fall den.
Was verkaufen?
Killaloe brauche ich halt nicht.
Weiß ich, ob man die noch irgendwo einlösen kann.
Tinderbox.
Also, ich hatte damals einen AMD Athlon XP.
Gab es einen Athlon?
Athlon XP 1900+.
Ja, den hatte ich damals.
Ich glaube, das war mein Daok PC.
Mein erster Daok PC.
Mit einem, passt mal auf, mit einem Zahlmann-Lüfter.
So ein Ding war das noch.
Irgendwie hatten die das noch.
Die waren damals Super-Lüfter und danach nie wieder.
Die waren richtig wild, ja.
Den Zahlmann hatte jeder, aber schon irgendwie.
Okay.
Lass uns mal kurz trainen.
Battle Songs.
Oh, gibt es nichts geschafft.
Battle Songs und Schwert.
Der sollte eigentlich die Sachen hier selbst replacen, aber man weiß ja nie.
Ich muss jetzt mal ein paar Sachen kurz zur Vorbereitung machen.
Sonst wird das nachher nervig.
Jetzt so ein Mana-Song.
Ich muss mal kurz in die Housing-Zone porten.
Auch so ein Ding.
Lasst mal kurz vor die Tür schauen, ob dort irgendwie noch Mids am Start sind.
Also, das ist nämlich auch so ein Ding.
In Daok kann man sich Häuser kaufen.
Gibt es eine extra Zone für.
Kann man sich Häuser kaufen.
Und in den Häusern kann man dann Drops, random generierte Items, gecraftete Items, Tränke und sowas anbieten.
Dass andere Spieler das kaufen können.
Und da will ich jetzt mal gucken nach Endu-Tränken.
Oh, ist das teuer.
The fuck?
Warum ist das so teuer?
So viel Geld habe ich nicht.
Ich brauche aber einen Endu-Trank.
Ich habe nur 53 Gold, man.
Ich bin Level 21.
Was haben wir denn hier?
30 Charges.
Endu-Trank ist Endu-3.
100 Charges Endu-3.
Okay, 90 Gold muss ich irgendwie zusammenkratzen, ja?
Dann kann ich mir Endu-Tränke kaufen.
Endu-Tränke sind enorm, also sind quasi essentiell, dass man ordentlich Melee-Nahkampfcharakter spielen kann.
Ich habe halt kein Geld.
Ich habe vorhin erst angefangen zu leveln.
Okay, dann holen wir uns mal neue Ausrüstung ab.
Ich glaube, die standen hier irgendwo rum.
Also Core-to-Duo hat damals noch keiner dran gedacht.
Damals hatten die CPU-Hersteller noch die Devise, mach mehr Takt und dann wird alles besser.
Intel kam ja damals auf die glorreiche Idee.
Vielleicht erinnert sich da noch einer dran.
Intel kam ja damals auf die Idee.
ATX.
ATX kennt ihr alle, oder?
Vom Namen her.
Ey.
Sind die Quartermaster verbuggt?
Oder, ich glaube, die Quartermaster sind einfach zu high level für mich.
Siehst du, ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die Quartermaster sind für mein Level.
Ja.
Gut, wir machen ein paar Kill-Tasks, damit wir ein bisschen Gold kriegen und XP.
Dazu gehen wir auf Eden in das Wiki.
In das Eden-Wiki.
Und schauen uns die Midgard-Quests an und schauen, in welche Zone wir hier müssen.
11, äh, 10 bis 34.
West-Zweiland und Gotha.
Curse-Thomp machen wir nicht.
Dungeons habe ich jetzt keinen Bock.
Mount brauche ich nicht, ich habe Speed.
Haben wir gerade.
Vendor machen wir auch nicht.
Okay, wir können...
West-Zweiland und Gotha, wir können mal gucken.
Agier gibt es nix mehr. Da sind...
Ne! Ha! Die machen wir!
Die machen wir, die sind nice, die Quests.
Und da sind wir mit 21 genau richtig für.
Die machen wir.
Ja.
Perfekt.
Äh, Porter.
Äh, Moment.
Wo ist hier ein Teleporter-Dude, Mann?
Hier.
Da... Agier, wo ist es?
Ja.
Da wollen wir hin.
Wollen Quests.
Da waren ein paar Kill-Quests.
Und wir brauchen noch ein paar.
Das ist auf jeden Fall Gold.
Ja, und wenn ich die Quests angenommen habe,
dann erzähle ich euch mal,
was es so für Klassen gibt und sowas.
Falls irgendjemand doch Bock hat, sich das anzugucken.
Except...
Äh...
Was?
Wie, warum gibt es da nur eine Quest?
Wie? Nur eine Quest?
Nee, ist das falsche Gebiet, oder?
Bin ich...
Bin ich komplett...
Ich bin Pepega?
Warum gibt es da nur eine?
20 bis 24, da gibt es nur eine Quest?
Das ist ja komplett bescheuert.
Äh, wie läuft da euer Job?
Gut, wir machen schnell die Quest.
Das ist ja easy.
Ich habe... Ich habe gehofft, vielleicht hat hier noch einer was.
Gut, die Quest machen wir schon.
Es wird jetzt nicht allzu wahnsinnig viel XP geben.
Ach ja, ich wollte fast zu Hardware sagen, ob es wer kennt.
Richtig.
Vielleicht kennt es noch jemand.
Intel, also ATX kennt ihr ja alle noch.
Intel wollte damals den...
Oh, ich laufe übrigens falsch.
Den BTX-Standard
einführen.
Weil Intel sich gedacht hat,
es wird zu warm
in Rechnern.
Und Intel ist damals nichts eingefallen,
außer,
ja, dann brauchen wir einen neuen Gehäuse-Standard
und einen neuen Mainboard-Standard,
wo man einfacher die Abwärme abführen kann.
Ja.
Und...
Dreimal dürft ihr raten, wie gut sich das durchgesetzt hat.
Keck-Wait.
Kennt jemand heute noch BTX?
Gehäuse?
Also...
Ich glaube, die wenigsten.
Ihr kennt vielleicht noch BTX,
dieses Telekom-Internet da.
So, lasst mal kurz checken.
Wo gibt es denn hier sonst noch Quests?
Hier.
25 geht es da weiter.
Das können wir machen.
Okay, das ist gut.
Weil sobald wir 25 sind,
gehen wir da hin.
Das sind gute, das sind nice Zonen.
Guck mal, Manfred am Start.
Ice Age ist auch so eine Filmserie.
Ich habe den ersten Ice Age-Film
voll gefeiert.
Den zweiten habe ich mir angeguckt,
hab mir gedacht, okay, jetzt sind euch die Ideen ausgegangen.
Danach habe ich nie wieder eingeguckt.
Aber der erste, Ice Age,
den fand ich echt nice.
Habe jetzt zum zweiten, ersten
neuen Job als Admin.
100% Home Office.
Okay, das ist gut.
Wenn man drauf steht.
Also, ich würde das auch machen.
Okay,
dann lasst uns mal Björn,
Shrek und Talvor killen.
Und Uga auch?
Nein, Uga nicht.
Moment, wir sind hier auch falsch.
Torre?
Wir müssen zum nächsten Camp.
Hier, hier sind angeblich
Viecher,
die man killen soll.
Angeblich,
angeblich ist hier ein Boss.
Bu...
Ah, nicht Buba, Bobri.
Aber hier
ist kein Boss. Seht ihr einen?
Ich sehe keinen.
Hier sollte eigentlich Björn, Shrek
oder Talvor sein.
Gucken wir mal, ob da oben einer ist.
Erstmal Shrek bashen.
Da ist er doch.
Oh ne.
Lass das Viech.
Finger weg.
Mein Boss.
Never donated,
never subscribed,
stolen laptop.
Ich entwalte den BD.
Es ist einfach viel angenehmer,
das mit mehreren Leuten zu machen.
Ach, der ist erst 20, okay.
Das ist auch eine Sache,
die finde ich
wirklich nice.
Du bist permanent dazu angehalten,
einfach mit anderen Leuten zusammenzuspielen.
Da ist Shrek.
Moin.
Shrek wird jetzt weggeschreckt.
Oh, Shrek
kriegt richtig Damage reingefahren.
Stimmt, ich habe gehört, Cyberpunk gab es.
2.1 Update.
Okay, der Kerl ist halb AFK.
So, ich brauche jetzt eigentlich
nur noch einen Boss.
Rick, Rick, kommst du mit?
Oder nicht?
Einen, wir brauchen noch Pjörn als Boss.
Okay, Rick hat keinen Bock.
Rick kommt nicht mit.
Okay, der ist fertig mit der Quest.
So, ich muss Pjörn killen.
Wo ist Pjörn, Alter?
Angeblich ist Pjörn hier.
Laut meiner Map.
Wo ist Pjörn?
Pjörn muss noch respawnen,
kann das sein?
Aber zum Glück sind die Respawn-Timer kurz.
Respawn-Timer dauern
so
drei bis vier, fünf Minuten
und davon sind jetzt wahrscheinlich schon fünf Minuten.
Der kann nicht mal lange dauern.
Wo ist Pjörn?
Ich kill jetzt mal das Viech, solange ich auf Pjörn warte.
Pjörn wird gebasht,
sobald er auftaucht.
Es kann auch nicht schallen, weil ich brauche ein bisschen
Gold.
Shrek Bracer!
Kann der was? Parry, hits,
Slash, Dexterity.
Nun ja.
Hits, Parry,
Parry all melee weapons.
Es ist besser.
Okay.
Shrek's Bracer suckt.
Da, Pjörn! Alter!
Dich habe ich gewartet.
Pjörn Champ am Start.
Hab gerade meinen ersten Job nach der Ausbildung
angeboten bekommen, die sucht eine komplette
IT-Abteilung in mir. Nice.
Kannst du, kannst du scheren?
Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht. Nee, lass.
Selbst wenn du es kannst, lass es lieber sein.
Nicht, dass es irgendwie negativ auf dich zurückfällt.
Okay, nice. Porten wir mal zum
Bindestone.
Gut, Quests done hier.
Porten wir zum Bindestone.
Ich bin übrigens richtig dumm.
Von den Aufgaben, ja, zeig mal.
Würde mich interessieren.
Porten zurück zum Bindestone.
Zurück
zu dem
NPC.
Und dann sind wir halt leider noch
nicht 25.
Dann müssen wir entweder doch nochmal in BG
gucken.
Oder wir machen
das.
Okay, nee, die machen wir.
Die, ja,
die machen wir. Oh, das ist eine schöne,
das ist eine schöne Schleife, glaube ich,
die man hier laufen kann.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist eine schöne
Schleife, die man laufen kann.
Frontier-Quests, gibt's die
auf dem Level überhaupt schon?
Thor-Quests gibt's
jetzt ja auch. Ach, der Arab
20. Ich dachte, die gibt's erst ab,
keine Ahnung, 40 oder so.
Ach, die sind, ja, dann machen wir Frontier-Quests.
Frontier-Quests.
Spielst du noch manchmal mit dem Friseur?
Selten, selten.
Gerade mit so, jeder mit seinem Zeug.
Wie schicke ich dir am besten ein Screenshot?
Keine Ahnung, einfach hier im Ego oder irgendwo
hochladen,
Image CC, Flicker, wo auch immer
und dann Link posten
zum Screenshot.
Okay, äh,
Zack, was wollte ich jetzt machen? Quest abgeben.
Ach, Frontier-Quests gibt's ab
20, das ist auch neu, gell? Also letzte
Season, wo ich gelevelt hab, gab's noch gar keine
Frontier-Quests.
Da gab's nur die, da gab's nur dann
Deserter-Quests und
tägliche Kill-Tasks und sowas.
Ich guck mal, ob von den Leuten, die ich aus letzter Season
kenne, irgendjemand an ist.
Okay, einer ist schon mal 50.
Kann mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Lul.
Ey, ich hab...
Ich spiel... Ernsthaft, das spielt nur...
Okay, das sortieren
von... Okay, von den Leuten, mit denen ich
gespielt hab, letzte Season irgendwie...
Also, die
ich mal gefriended hab.
Irgendwie keiner, keiner am Start mehr.
Finish!
Okay,
zeigt mal her.
Okay, wir gucken uns das mal schnell an.
Was sollst du machen? Halbe IT-Abteilung.
Ihre Aufgaben.
Betreuung von IT-Infrastruktur, Hardware,
Software im Bereich der Verwaltung und der Ausstellung.
Oh, Verwaltung! Das klingt so ein bisschen nach
öffentlicher Dienst oder sowas. Wir porten mal
kurz ins RVR-Gebiet.
Wo könnten die
Quartermaster sein? Ah, guck mal, wir kriegen
neue Schuhe. Das ist ja nice.
Shrek-Spracer brauch ich
nicht.
Wir sellen das einfach jetzt schnell noch.
Enchantments, Stablemaster...
S...
S... S...
Weg. Tinderbox.
Ja, so nice die sind. Okay, das brauchen wir auch nicht
mehr. Destroy...
Wobei, Distrunky kann ich auch abgeben.
Killaloe brauchen wir nicht mehr.
Tinderbox.
Das heben wir auf.
Das ist so ein Campfire.
Da reckt man schneller.
Okay, porten wir mal ins
RVR-Gebiet und machen RVR-Tasks.
Kommt ja noch mehr. Kommt ja noch mehr
PvP an den Start. Wobei,
im großen RVR-Gebiet, PvP-Gebiet
bin ich halt Futter. Sobald irgendjemand
kommt, bin ich direkt Futter. Auf der anderen
Seite, ich bin auch grau.
Ich geb keine Punkte.
Also, zeigt mal her.
Betreuung von IT-Infrastruktur,
Hardware und Software im Bereich der
Verwaltung, Administration von Servern,
professionelle Unterstützung
der Anwender in... Alter, Anwendersupport.
Was ist mit denen los, man?
Was ist mit denen los?
Weiterentwicklung der gesamten
IT-Infrastruktur. Der gesamten.
Konzeptionelle Weiterentwicklung
der gesamten IT-Infrastruktur.
Konfiguration zentraler IT-Systeme.
Also, AD, LDAP,
Datensicherung, Dokumentmanagement...
Alter, was ist mit denen los?
Unterstützung bei IT-Projekten,
Pflege der Internetpräsenz,
Hardware-Software bestellen,
Software-Verträge,
Mitwirkung beim Datenschutz,
Zusammenarbeit mit dem Rechts...
Wer hat denn
das wieder geschrieben, man?
Wer hat das wieder geschrieben, Alter?
Zu geil.
Midcard Frontier
Explorers.
Nice.
Äh, okay.
Ich lehn mal kurz die alten Quests ab.
Die alten...
Quests.
Das Dark-Quest-Menü fühlt sich halt echt an
wie 1995.
Alter, der Witz ist halt,
es ist nicht 1995.
Es ist 2001.
Killaloe brauchen wir auch nicht mehr.
Äh,
The Trunky behalten wir,
Deserted Living Frontier behalten wir auch.
Okay, Midcard Frontier
Explorers, let's go.
Alles klar, auf geht's.
Äh, da...
Ach, das ist auch noch hinterm Wall.
Easy.
Easy. Da kommt doch nicht mal einer hin.
Ich bräuchte unbedingt
1L4, dass ich...
dass ich Longwind 2 holen kann.
Naja.
Wir machen jetzt erstmal hier ein paar Mobs, dann gehen wir nochmal kurz ins
BG.
Und holen uns noch ein paar RPs.
Müssen wir das killen? Was müssen wir killen?
Yaku,
Snowman, Run,
Shizzler
müssen wir killen.
Frosty, Scuttlebug,
und Snowman.
Okay, also von denen müssen wir 10 Stück killen.
Nice. Easy.
Ja, gesamte IT-Infrastruktur ist halt mega übertrieben.
Oh, das ist
solo so langweilig.
Ich brauch irgendjemanden, der mitmacht.
Any Frontier Questers, Alter.
Das wird zu langweilig,
Mann.
Das ist so... Okay,
die 10 Stück kill ich jetzt. 10 Stück kill ich jetzt.
Aber mehr halt ich denn aus?
Ich brauch auch wieder neue Rüstung.
Ich hab's ja gesagt.
Low IQ,
Warnung, Kreisel, Crinder, Stream.
Ich bräuchte mal einen besseren
Anytimer-Style. Wann gibt's denn einen?
Eden, Dark,
Char-Planer.
Wann gibt's einen gescheiten
Anytimer für Schwert?
12? 34
erst?
Vielleicht soll ich doch Hammersbecken
mit so einem leveln.
Mit 34
krieg ich erst einen gescheiten Anytime-Style,
Mann.
Das ist ja schon richtig mies, ne?
Ja, killen wir halt 10 Käfer.
Gut ist.
Also Fabian,
ich geh mal davon aus, dass diese Stellenanzeige
wahrscheinlich schlimmer ist,
als es...
also sich schlimmer liest, als es ist.
Denn,
dadurch, dass es wahrscheinlich die Behörde oder irgendwie so was
ist, vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Haben die wahrscheinlich genaue Vorgaben, was...
Was ist denn da unten?
Was da drinnen stehen muss.
Und dementsprechend
ist das nicht unbedingt tatsächlich
dann so deine Aufgaben.
Auf Käfer.
Sterben, please.
Ist ja schrecklich.
Okay, Leute, ich mach 10 Kills,
danach geh ich wieder ins RVR-Gemiet.
Also danach geh ich wieder, danach geh ich wieder in BG.
Und mach
jetzt noch mal bis 1.11.4.
Und dann brauch ich Gold,
dass ich mir Endothränke kaufen kann.
Und wenn ich Endothränke hab...
Ich brauch ja nicht mehr viel Gold.
Wenn ich Endothränke hab, dann ist easy.
Dann kann ich das hier chainen quasi.
Naja, fast.
Und ne gescheite Rüstung vor allem.
Also falls einer Bock hat auf
Frontier-Quests Level 20, dann...
Das ist auch was Neues.
Ihr seht das hier unten nicht.
Aber die haben immer ständig wechselnde Zonen
auf Eden.
Wo es für Solos,
Duos,
oder ja...
Alles was nicht...
Es gibt extra Zonen für Solospieler,
für Duospieler
und für Smallman-Spieler.
Also ich glaub alles unter 5.
Was ich echt cool finde.
Ey, da ist was.
Oh, die Elite ist am Start hier.
Sind so...
Special.
Ganz special Guild ist das.
Die haben sich bei mir mal
aufgeregt, dass ich
im PvP auf ihre Gegner gehauen hab.
Ey, hätt ich früher auch. Mittlerweile bin ich
deutlich entspannter, was das angeht.
Oh, ist das auch
ein Gegner gewesen?
Snow Imp soll wir auch killen, glaub ich.
Ich lauf jetzt einfach mit denen mit
und mach die Quests.
Warum nicht?
Ist doch ganz nice.
So, haben wir irgendwas gedroppt? Nope.
Ich lauf jetzt einfach mit denen mit.
Weil wenn die hier anfangen, machen die die gleiche Quest.
Oh, easy.
Und zu dritt ist man auf jeden Fall schneller.
Gibt sogar nen Campfire.
So, was brauchen wir denn sonst noch?
Snow Imps gab's doch noch.
Snow Imp.
Da unten hab ich doch Snow Imps gesehen, oder?
Jawoll, Snow Imps.
Wie viel ist... Oh, 20!
Aber wenn die Leute
dabei sind, dann geht das.
Komm, scheiß drauf.
Ist halt mal ein langweiliger Kreisel-Grind.
Ich hoffe,
ich hoffe, das gibt ordentlich
ordentlich XP dann gleich.
Weil das halt ich nicht lang aus.
Den Solo-XP-Grind.
So.
Ach, mehr gibt's nicht, oder was?
Das waren alle!
Dachte, hier steh noch mehr rum.
Lul.
Richtig Boomer Mode am Start.
Yep, clock.
Hier ist angeblich
was? Ich seh hier nix.
Was soll hier sein?
Käfer vielleicht.
Aber die Käfer hab ich ja schon.
Gehen wir mal zum nächsten.
Na, viel mehr als 4 Pixel sind sie auch nicht.
Vielleicht 8 Pixel.
Wie viel spielst du noch?
Du meinst das Game?
Ich hab jetzt die Woche saumäßig viel Kreisel-Grind gemacht,
weil die neue Season hier gestartet ist.
Müssen wir die Dinger bashen hier?
Ey, die sind zu hoch für mich.
Nee, oder?
Die müssen wir nicht bashen.
Vorne müssen wir irgendwas bashen.
Snow.
Snowmans müssen wir bashen.
Endu-Raggin.
Brauch unbedingt Endu-Pots.
Sonst ist das
sehr
nervig und
langweilig.
Gelbe kann ich
Chain-Killen, das ist kein Ding.
Ich überleg grad, was die beste Song-Kombi ist.
Wenn ich jetzt irgendwie Makro-Start hätte,
Makro-Software am Start hätte,
würd ich einfach alle Songs durch irgendeinen Makro
triggern lassen oder so.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist
Endu-Reduce
und ein bisschen Heal,
auch wenn der Heal in Fight schwach ist,
ganz gut, weil dann kannst du
fast
Chain-Kloppen, Gelbe.
Also die Woche hab ich enorm viel gespielt,
weil, wie gesagt, Season-Start
und Season-Start ist halt
immer pock,
reinkriten, Kreisel-mäßig.
Level up heißt.
Okay, trainieren!
Special Songs, neues Zeug.
Ah, neuer Endu-Reduce.
Das ist sehr schick.
Umso weniger Endu ich verbrauche,
umso besser.
Und ein neuer Snare, auch gut.
Du hast früher mit den Makros
gemacht, ich hab grad nix am Start.
Sonst würd ich's auch mit Makros machen.
Übrigens, Makros sind auf dem Server erlaubt,
solange es keine Loops sind.
Der Onkel Bob ist am Start.
Solange es keine Loops sind.
Also wenn du immer alle deine Auren
triggerst, alle 5 Sekunden oder so,
dann ist es okay.
Wenn du einen Loop eingebaut hast,
der quasi, ohne dass du alle 5 Sekunden
selbst eine Taste drückst, triggerst, ist es verboten.
Ob das wirklich
irgendjemand kontrolliert,
I don't know.
Guck mal hier, lohnt sich richtig
mit dem neuen Endu-Chant.
Seht ihr?
Das verliert man fast kaum noch Endu
hier im Fight, so ist das gut.
So hat man relativ schnell 20
dann weggekloppt.
Moin.
So und danach machen wir, wir kloppen jetzt
die 20 um. Ich glaube die
andere Quest mach ich nicht, das ist mir zu langweilig.
Dann gehen wir kurz noch PvP
machen, bis ich 1L4 bin.
Für Longwind 2, dass ich unendlich
sprinten kann. Oder vielleicht, müssen wir mal gucken,
vielleicht kann ich sogar jetzt schon unendlich sprinten.
Ich müsste eigentlich,
ich hab aber weder Endu
Juwel
noch
noch einen Endu-Trank
bis jetzt. Müssen wir mal gucken.
Weil unendlich sprinten können ist enorm wichtig.
Für Nahkampf-Character.
Denn,
also ihr habt es ja vorhin gesehen, ich war
vorhin quasi fast permanent out of Endu,
wenn ich irgendwelchen Gegnern nachgerannt bin.
Weil halt zu viel Endu-Verbrauch mit Nahkampf-Angriffen
plus Sprint.
Also ist wichtig,
dass man Endu hat.
Und ich müsste mal einen Dungeon machen,
dass ich so ein Endu-Rack-Teil kriege.
Aber die mach ich nicht gerne.
Die mach ich immer erst gerne nur die
Level-Sachen.
Weil dann macht man die Eimer und gut ist.
Ich sehe hier auch so wenig.
Kann das sein, dass ich
Aliens? Habe ich irgendwie
Advice? Chat?
Muss ich mal alles anmachen wieder.
Jetzt hatte ich alles ausgeschaltet.
Officer, ja meinetwegen auch.
Alliance looking for group, ja.
Schalte ich mal alles ein.
Dass ich sehe, falls irgendjemand
Dungeons oder so machen will,
die in meinem Level, in meiner Level-Range sind.
Okay, was suchen die
hier unten?
Wenn jetzt übrigens ein Gegner kommt, bin ich instant one-shot.
Ja.
Patrick, ich muss ja auch noch leveln.
Ich bin ja erst Level 22.
Also mein Ziel ist eigentlich
40 heute.
Was auch durchaus geht, wenn ich auch ein paar Leute,
also wenn wir noch ein bisschen RvR machen.
Bisschen PvP.
Und wenn ich
dann noch ein paar
vielleicht die ein oder anderen
Sachen nebenbei mitnehmen kann,
dann geht
40 schon ganz gut.
Also wenn man natürlich eine richtig
gute fixe Group hat, ist man
innerhalb von ein paar Stunden 40.
Aber mir ist das so eigentlich ganz recht.
Ich hab ja auch, mit ganzen Leuten haben wir
diese Season wenig Bock.
Kurz ein bisschen Leben raggen.
So, wie viele brauchen wir von diesem
Müll denn hier noch?
Sechs Stück.
Wobei ich ragge mal kurz
noch Mana.
Mana schnell gereckt.
Normalerweise würde ich mir einen Mana-Trank
kaufen und einen Endo-Trank kaufen.
Und dann sehe die Welt schon mal ganz anders aus.
Aber, ich bin ja
Level 22 und die Season hat gestartet.
Ich hab kein Geld.
Satch. Zumindest habe ich eine gute Waffe.
Off, kipp um.
Jo, während ich hier PvM mach,
erzähle ich euch mal ein bisschen was.
Und zwar,
was ich euch eigentlich schon die ganze Zeit erzählen wollte.
Aber nicht dazu gekommen bin,
weil zu viel PvP, BG, Action.
Also falls irgendjemand Bock hat, sich das Game mal
anzugucken.
Gerade Leute, die auf Oldschool-MMOs stehen.
Für mich ist es immer noch das beste PvP-MMO.
Für PvM sucht ihr vielleicht was anderes.
Wenn es auch gerade was Group-Content
angeht, ein bisschen
was zu bieten hat. Aber es ist kein
World of Warcraft-PvM oder so.
Zumindest
wollte ich einfach mal so ein bisschen was über die Klassen erzählen,
die es gibt.
Denn, was ich so
gemerkt hab, was die letzten
Jahre über in MMOs,
doch
ziemlich, ziemlich
zurückgegangen ist,
ist Support-Klassen.
Es gibt kaum noch MMOs mit richtigen Support-Klassen.
Leute, welches neue
MMO fällt euch ein, die richtig
echte Support-Klassen haben? Also richtig echte
Support-Klassen sind für mich Klassen,
ohne die du eigentlich nicht spielen kannst,
aber die alleine nichts auf die Reihe kriegen.
Da fällt mir echt nicht viel ein.
Ich mein, wenn man sich Final Fantasy
anguckt,
dann haben die schon
Support-Klassen und Heiler,
aber die können alle Solo-Overs
machen.
So in Dark ist es halt so,
du hast
pro Realm
hast du mehrere Support-Klassen.
Du hast meistens so eine Main-Heal-Klasse und
Main-Buff-Klasse.
Manchmal ist das auch in einem.
Und in der Regel kriegen die halt
Solo nicht allzu viel hin.
Aber du brauchst sie in jeder Gruppe,
eigentlich mindestens zwei,
und
du kommst halt ohne nicht aus.
Und was ich gemerkt habe ist, dass es ganz viele
Leute gibt, denen das
wahnsinnig viel Spaß macht, Support-Klassen
zu spielen in Dark.
Wo man ja erstmal denkt, ey,
ich mein,
warum sollte ich
was spielen, was selbst nichts
killen kann?
Aber es scheint enorm viele, also ich spiele übrigens
auch gerne Support.
Also das scheint
enorm viele Leute,
Spaß zu machen.
Auch wenn es sich jetzt erstmal nicht so anhört.
Aber nur
weil du selbst nichts killen kannst, heißt
es nicht, dass die Klassen leicht zu spielen
wären und
nichts können. Also ich würde mal sagen,
in jeder guten Gruppe
sind die Supporter
mitentscheidend für,
dass sie was auf die Reihe kriegt oder nicht.
Sind alle für entscheidend, aber Supporter
ganz besonders.
Und Supporter sind auch die einzigen, die auf irgendwelchen
Raids nicht schlafen können, weil sonst alles
sterben kann.
Als DPS stellst du dich in Dark
an den Gegner dran, drückst einen Knopf,
alle 3 Sekunden und fertig.
Ja.
Also es gibt in jedem
Realm gibt es
Main Support-Klassen,
Main Buff-Klassen.
Dann hast du in jedem Realm
natürlich Main Tanks.
So wie in jedem MMO.
Wobei man halt sagen muss, in Dark ist es so,
Main Tanks
sind ziemlich gute Damage-Dealer.
PvP-technisch, PvM-technisch nicht so sehr.
Und dann hast du natürlich die üblichen Sachen
wie Off-Tanks,
die ordentlich was aushalten, aber
richtig, richtig gut Melee-Damage machen.
Moment, bin ich eigentlich fertig
mit der Quest, Leute?
Ich glaube ich bin fertig, oder?
Ich muss die gar nicht mehr killen. Ich bin durch.
Null. Okay, der ist verbuggt.
Den kann ich nicht hitten.
Hallo, game!
Ich glaube, ich bin fertig.
Easy.
Ja, die hätte ich gar nicht mehr killen müssen.
Null.
Heck, wait!
Ne. Gut.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, ich kille jetzt noch mal
hier vorne die, weil ich bin gerade am Erzählen.
Vielleicht habe ich dann auch genug Sachen.
Aha, neue Armlinge.
Excellent.
Wie sehe ich da eigentlich aktuell aus?
Alter, wie der schlechteste
Low-Level-Kack-Noob sehe ich aus, Mann.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Hier, Hits, Parry,
Constitution, Parry, Decks,
Melee-Weapons. Jawohl, game.
Ja, du hast Off-Tanks
für Nahkampf-Damage,
du hast
ein paar Schleicher,
du hast so ein paar
Hybrid-Klassen,
Damage-Caster,
äh, Main-
Crowd-Control-Character.
Also es ist in Dark, ohne Scheiß, es ist für jeden
irgendwas dabei.
Ich glaube, ich kenne niemand, der in Dark
nicht die richtige Klasse gefunden hat, auf die er richtig
Bock hat. Und man muss sagen, die Klassen
sind,
sag mal, doch schon recht variabel,
was so die,
ja, das Niveau
angeht, auf dem man
die spielen kann. Aber man muss sagen,
es ist relativ
rewarding in dem Fall,
dass, sag mal, in der
Regel, nicht immer,
aber in der Regel sind
die Klassen,
die schwieriger zu spielen sind,
kann man auch mehr rausholen, ja.
Nehmen wir mal ein Beispiel.
Heiler ist einer der schwierigsten zu spielenden Klassen im ganzen
Game.
Es gibt eine Klasse, die ist Heiler und heißt
Heiler, da ist dir nix eingefallen.
Also Healer ist
eines der
mit Abstand schwierigsten Klassen.
Du kannst sie sogar, äh, Triple-Spec
machen, also dass du alle drei Skilllinien
skillst hier.
Und da kannst du alles. Du kannst
heilen, du kannst buffen,
du kannst Crowd-Controllen,
du kannst alles irgendwie, außer
Damage machen, ja. Und das ist
unglaublich schwer gut zu spielen.
Aber wenn du einen guten Heiler in der
Gruppe hast, macht es enorm viel aus.
Genauso in Albion, wenn du eine gute,
gute Sorc dabei hast oder
gute Bade in Hip.
Und
es gibt so ein paar No-Brain-Klassen,
sowas wie Skalder zum Beispiel, was ich spiele,
das ist nicht sonderlich schwierig.
Aber ich bin auch Boomer,
ey, Leute, nur Boomer
spielen dieses Spiel, wer soll es sonst spielen?
Mein Brain macht nicht mehr mit.
Wobei in Alb spiele ich Sorc. Sorc ist auch
echt nicht ohne gescheit zu spielen.
Wenn ich Bock
auf Caster habe, spiele ich Alb. Wenn ich Bock
auf Solo-Nahkampf-
Kram habe, spiele ich mit.
Ja.
Also, Down-Cut, lasst mich mal zählen.
Ähm, wollen wir mal gucken?
Okay, lasst mal überlegen.
Lasst mal überlegen.
Gucken wir mal, ob ich die Klassen zusammenkriege
von den unterschiedlichen Realms.
So, in Albion
in Albion
hast du...
Ich muss abgucken.
Okay, ich guck mal,
was ich alles... Ich muss abgucken. Aber ich
muss mal gucken, wie weit ich die Klassen zusammenkriege.
Ich meine, ich habe das Spiel seit 20 Jahren
gespielt, ich kenne alle Klassen, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich
aus dem Kopf mehr allein falle.
Also, in Alb hast du Paladin,
Cleric,
Ordi,
Kaba, Armsman,
äh, Infi-Scout,
Söldner,
Minnesänger,
Nekro,
Wizard.
Waren das alle?
Ich habe bestimmt was vergessen.
Und ich guck, ich guck mal nach.
Warte mal.
Ich guck mal nach.
Ja, Classes.
Hier, da steht es noch.
Gibt es da nicht ein besseres
Wiki?
Ja, doch.
Ja, viel besser hier.
Wir machen jetzt AFK-Leveling.
Ich schau jetzt auf den Mob.
Und wir gucken uns mal kurz die Klassen an.
Also, in Alb hast du Armsman.
Armsman ist
Main Tank
in Albion.
Hat eine Besonderheit.
Also nur für den Fall, dass jemand Bock hat.
Ich erkläre euch mal ein bisschen die Klassen, die es in dem Game gibt.
Ich muss mal ein bisschen weg
hier aus dem Spawn raus, weil
die Schizzler schizzelt
mich um gerade.
Als erstes, wenn ihr dauernd anfangt, ihr müsst euch für
eines von drei Reiche entscheiden.
Ihr könnt euch für Albion entscheiden, Midgard oder Hipp.
Auf Eden ist es in der Tat
recht easy. Auf Eden
könnt ihr alle drei Reiche spielen.
Auf Eden gibt es die Beschränkung nicht.
Wie, äh, wie auf Live.
Beziehungsweise damals auf Live.
Allerdings haben sie es auf Eden auch clever
gemacht, dass du nicht permanent Winning
oder Teamjoiner machst.
Kriegst du Loyalitätsbonus, wenn du eine lange
Zeit hier spielst.
Und spielst du dann in einem anderen Reich, sinkt der
Loyalitätsbonus.
Das ist eigentlich ganz clever gemacht.
Aber nur solange du PvP
Kills machst.
Also eigentlich ganz gut gemacht.
Also ihr müsst
am Anfang entscheidet ihr euch für eins von drei Reichen.
Es gibt Albion.
Das ist mittelalterliches England.
Die Story von
Dark ist, König Arthur
ist gestorben und
frag mich nicht nach der Story.
König Arthur ist gestorben und
dadurch ist die Welt
im Chaos. Kein Schimmer.
Übrigens die Story dahinter, hinter der Story
warum die das genommen haben
ist, weil es Copyright free ist.
Die wollten
ein Game machen. Die wollten ein MMO
machen. PvP MMO.
Aber alles was sie sich überlegt haben
hatte halt Copyright Probleme.
Und da haben sie gesagt, sie greifen auf die König Arthur
Sage zurück.
Weil die ist halt quasi, wie heißt das?
Royalty Free oder sowas.
Deswegen haben sie
Public Domain. Nicht Royalty Free.
Das wäre was anderes.
Public Domain.
Eigentlich eine ganz clevere
Entscheidung von den Entwicklern damals gewesen.
Das so zu machen.
Aufschüssler.
Zack.
Bevor ich es vergesse.
Genau, also als erstes müsst ihr euch entscheiden für eins von drei.
Reiche. Albion ist so mittelalterliches England.
Midgard ist Skandinavien.
Hibernia ist quasi so
keltisch-irisch. Sowas in der Richtung.
Und
alle Reiche haben
komplett
unterschiedliche Rassen
und komplett unterschiedliche Klassen.
Es gibt nicht, wobei
eine Klasse gibt es in allen Reichen, aber
die spielt keiner. Wobei, die gibt es auf
Eden gar nicht. Vergiss es. Es gibt nicht eine
Klasse die doppelt ist. Alle drei
Reiche haben ungefähr gleich viel, aber
unterschiedliche Rassen.
Du hast, in jedem Reich hast du quasi
so die, so mehr
oder weniger die gleichen
äh, wie soll man sagen, so die gleichen Typen
von unterschiedlichen Rassen.
Bei Albion kannst du Bretonne spielen,
Avalonia, Sarazene, Highlander,
Inkorno oder Halboger.
Wenn man sich die Klassen, die Rassen anguckt, kann man sich schon
ungefähr denken, wer für was gut ist.
Halboger sind richtig gut für
Nahkampfcharacter. Highlander sind auch richtig gut
für Nahkampfcharacter.
Sie sind richtig gute Caster,
weil die viel Geschicklichkeit haben.
Sind auch gute Caster, Allrounder
und Inkorno
für die edgy Leute.
Und
so ähnlich ist das in den anderen Reichen auch.
Es gibt immer
Rassen, die sich besonders anbieten, um bestimmte Klassen
zu spielen. Zum Beispiel Midgard.
Midgard gibt es Nordmänner, die sind so
allround, die können alles ganz gut. Du hast
Zwerge, die haben sehr viel Konstitution.
Eigentlich sind Zwerge für nichts die beste
Klasse. Aber
dadurch, dass sie klein sind, spielen gerne viele
Heilerzwerge,
weil du
nicht so leicht gesehen wirst.
Eigentlich ziemlich pfeifert.
Ich habe früher auch Zwergenheiler
gespielt. Dann hast du Trolle.
Trolle sind mit Abstand im ganzen
Game die beste Nahkampfklasse.
100 Stärke. Keine andere Klasse,
nicht mal Halboger, haben ansatzweise so viel
Stärke wie Trolle.
Dann hast du Kobolde, die sind super Caster,
weil hohe Geschicklichkeit, Valkind, keine Ahnung
wer sowas spielt. Frostalflinger,
ganz gut für Heiler zum Beispiel.
Und in
Hipp hast du ähnliche Sachen. Kälte,
Allroundrasse, Elf, guter
Caster, Vierbolg,
hohe Stärke, gut Melek-Charakter,
Lorikin, hohe Dex, guter Caster,
oder eben Schleicher.
Und Silvan,
ja, auch random Leute,
die das spielen, braucht man eigentlich nicht.
Also man hat
ungefähr schon, sind zwar alles unterschiedliche
Rassen, aber man sieht schon,
es ist schon, also man kann
auch suboptimale Klassen spielen,
man kann Troll-Caster spielen,
aber kein, der Serious-Dark spielt,
spielt Troll-Caster.
Du kannst Troll-Bowndancer oder
Troll-Schamane spielen, aber
dadurch, dass Trolle sau viel Stärke haben
und Bowndancer und Schamanen keine Stärke brauchen,
und die brauchen Dex, und Trolle
haben den niedrigsten Dex-Wert mit
35 von allen Klassen, ist das
total unsinnig. Manche
machen es trotzdem, ich weiß nicht warum, aber
ja,
es gibt auch Leute, die peitschen sich selbst aus.
Wird das geil.
Also insofern,
muss man das nicht hinterfragen, soll jeder spielen,
worauf man Bock hat. Ich finde, man sollte
schon ein bisschen halbwegs passenden
Choice, also passende Sache
dazu nehmen. So, und wenn man sich für
einen Realm entschieden hat, das man spielen will,
dann als nächstes
sollte man sich eine Klasse raussuchen,
auf die man Bock hat. Und das ist das,
das ist wirklich eines der, finde ich, der richtig
richtig nicen Sachen von Dark.
Es gibt wirklich für jeden
irgendwas zu spielen.
Natürlich hast du so
grundsätzliche
Typen wie Main-Tank
oder Main-Healer und sowas
in allen Reichen, aber das sind unterschiedliche
Klassen, die sich auch komplett unterschiedlich
spielen. Mir fällt
kein Game ein, was so ist wie Dark,
was...
von der
Klassenverteilung. Und es ist,
man kann nicht sagen, dass Dark
balanced ist. Ganz im Gegenteil,
aber auf
größerer Skala ist es ganz gut
balanced.
Und auch auf kleinerer Skala,
also wenn du, wenn du mit
Achtergruppen spielst, kannst
theoretisch jeder
gegen jeden gewinnen. Kommt ein bisschen auf das Setup
an, kommt natürlich auch sehr auf die Spiele an,
aber du kannst mit
jeder Achtergruppe gegen jede andere Achtergruppe
gewinnen. Wenn das Setup
nicht dich total benachteiligt,
ja. Also
mit einer reinen Nahkampfgruppe zum Beispiel
hast du es gegen
kite-ende Castergruppen
oftmals dann doch recht schwer.
Zumindest auf niedrigem RR. Auf höherem geht das
ganz gut. Mehr Burst-Damage und auch mehr RRs
zur Verfügung, aber ist
nicht so, ist nicht so ohne.
Glaubt mir, da weiß ich tatsächlich
wovon ich rede. Ich hab das lange gespielt
und wir haben auch genug
auf Elite-Spacken gemacht
früher, also insofern.
Was das angeht, kenn ich mich auch
aus. So, zumindest
wenn man sich mal die Klassen anguckt
und wie gesagt, die Klassen sind pro Reich
alle komplett unterschiedlich.
Eine noch, ja.
Kommen wir uns das mal an. Also, wenn ihr zum Beispiel
Albion spielen wollt, wenn ihr
auf mittelalterliches England steht
und ihr
euch das anguckt,
werdet ihr feststellen, es gibt sowas wie Armsman.
Armsman ist Main-Tank in
Albion, hat eine
spezielle Fähigkeit. Übrigens, ganz
viele Klassen haben spezielle Fähigkeiten,
die einzigartig im Spiel sind.
Also, da ist das Recycling
auch gar nicht so krass in der Ork, dass
man sagt, okay, man nimmt immer das gleiche und
ordnet es dann einfach nur pro Reich anders an. Es ist wirklich
sehr, sehr unique
pro Reich, was man spielt.
So, zumindest Armsman ist der Main-Tank,
also der, zwei der Main-Tanks
in Albion, hat
eine Sache, die sonst keiner hat,
kann Polearms tragen.
Also, was
heißt denn Polearm auf Deutsch?
So helle Bade oder sowas, oder?
Was heißt Polearm auf Deutsch?
Stangenwaffe!
Sagt das irgendjemand?
Sagt ernsthaft jemand
Stangenwaffe? Polearms!
Polearms sind eine richtig gute
Waffe, eine richtig gute Waffenkategorie,
weil die langsam sind und übelst
Damage machen. Also, Armsman
tankt extrem gut,
dank Plattenrüstung und macht auch
nahkampfmäßig enormen Damage.
Als nächstes hast du Kabba,
Kabba ist für
Damage-Caster, die einen Pet haben wollen.
Da hast du permanent
einen Pet dabei, was du rumkommandieren
kannst und neu beschwören kannst
und machst auch ziemlich gut
Damage. Bist so ein bisschen
Mischung aus Support-
Caster, Interrupt
mit dem Pet und Damage-Caster.
Kabba ist sehr beliebt
in Alp-Gruppen, wird eigentlich immer mitgenommen.
Du kannst Kabba auch wunderbar
spielen, wenn du nicht so
auf Elite-Achtergruppen-Fight machen
willst. Kannst du Kabba auch wunderbar
im Zerg spielen, also mit ganz vielen
Leuten auf
einem Haufen, weil Kabba
ist die Klasse, die ein Albion
AE dort hat, also
Gift
Area-Gift.
Damit leechst du RPs wie sonst kein zweiter.
Und Kabba
ist auch ziemlich gut im Solo-Monster-Killen,
dank dem Pet.
So, nächste Klasse, Cleric.
Primary Healing Class, trifft ganz gut.
Cleric ist der Main-Heiler
und der Main-Buffer in Albion.
Macht mir unglaublich Spaß zu spielen.
Ich habe jahrelang Cleric gespielt.
Kann,
aber ein bisschen
Offensive.
Also Clerics hat eine Speck-Linie
fürs Buffen, also dass man
anderen Leuten mehr Geschicklichkeit, Stärke,
sonst was geben kann, Resistenzen.
Hat die besten Heals in Albion.
Instant Heals.
Und kann Gegner
stunnen und ein bisschen Damage machen.
Also ist jetzt nicht so, dass Cleric super
krass Damage macht. Es gibt die wenigsten Clerics
specken diese Damage-Linie.
Aber
ein bisschen Baseline-Damage kann man
machen.
Wie findest du die Ausschreibung der Stelle?
Aber lass uns mal gucken.
Gucken wir gleich.
Ich laber grad mal mein Kram hier fertig.
Dass ich nicht wieder vergesse.
Da gucken wir uns das gleich an.
Ist die Quest jetzt eigentlich fertig?
Yagre müssen wir killen.
Relic, Relic,
Imp. Imps müssen wir noch killen.
Hier oben ist noch was, was wir bashen müssen.
Friends.
Ist der andere eigentlich wieder da?
Hä?
Danik wieder am Start?
Ach, Danik ist wieder da.
Okay.
Ja.
Was haben wir hier?
Heiler.
Müssen wir Heiler killen?
Ist das WoW? Nein.
Ist doch nicht wahr.
Das ist unser zweites Ausübung.
Das ist Dark Age of Camelot.
Bestes PvP
MMO ever.
Aua. Alter, Heiler.
Mach nicht so viel Damage. Was ist mit dir los?
Heiler, lass mich in Ruhe. Finger weg.
Was ist das hier?
Der hat mich fast gebasht.
Ne, den müssen wir gar nicht killen. Nicht kacken, Hoopman.
Wir müssen...
Ey, ich dachte das ist ein Name den ich killen muss.
Den müssen wir überhaupt
nicht killen.
Habe ich jetzt komplett umsonst gekillt.
GG Max.
Gut gemacht.
So, Cleric habe ich schon.
Dann gibt es Ordi oder Ordensbruder
auf Deutsch. Also
Friar auf Englisch.
Ehrlich gesagt
kann man sich drüber streiten
ob es eine gute Klasse ist oder nicht.
Ist Hybrid
Heiler Nahkampf Klasse.
Eigentlich auf Eden ganz gut.
Solo ziemlich gut.
Aber leider kein Speed.
Gibt aber viele die mögen Ordi.
Ich kann dazu nicht so viel sagen.
Habe ich nie groß gespielt.
Eine der wenigen Klassen wo ich nie gelevelt habe.
Und
ich weiß auch nicht wie gut die Changes
auf Eden
jetzt wirklich sind für Ordis in der Gruppe.
Aber spielen viele
gerne. Ordi hat auf jeden Fall
gute RAs für Zerg-Fights.
Infi gehe ich jetzt drüber.
Schleicher-Klassen interessieren mich nicht.
Tick auch
Juckt mich auch nicht so sehr.
Mauler
gibt es auf Eden nicht.
Mercenary.
Eden ist ein Dark-Free-Shot.
Wie viel brauche ich eigentlich von dem hier?
Wo habe ich von den Viechern denn hier?
Boah 20 auch.
Nice.
Oder auch nicht nice.
Aber wir sind noch ein bisschen beschäftigt hier.
Kann ich noch ein bisschen weitererzählen.
Achja und immer wieder umdrehen zum Gegner.
Bevor er seinen zweiten Melee-Angriff macht,
dass man die Chance hat zu parieren.
Und nicht strafen
im Nahkampf, weil dann misst man.
Einfacher.
Gegen Mobs.
Muss ich mal kurz raggen.
Ordi sind aggressive, die bashen mich.
Ja, man sieht halt da auch, guckt euch das mal an.
Man sieht halt da auch schon an,
dass es ein bisschen älteres Game ist.
Guckt mal, der Zonen-Übergang.
Seht ihr das?
Hier haben die Leute halt nicht aufgepasst.
Ein bisschen procken so.
Genau, Mercenary.
Richtig guter Off-Tank.
Nahkampf-Damage.
Also für alle, die Nahkämpfer spielen wollen,
die gut Damage machen und ein paar
kleinere Tricks haben,
ist Mercenary in Albion richtig gut.
Minstrel oder
Minnesänger ist quasi
die Speed-Klasse in Albion.
Wenn ihr in jeder Gruppe gefragt sein wollt,
aber auch Solo gut was reißen könnt.
Man könnte argumentieren, Minnesänger
ist die beste Solo-Klasse im Spiel.
Ich würde
sagen, Skalde ist die beste Solo-Klasse im Spiel.
Aber
man...
kann man sich drüber streiten.
Ich hab meinen Shotgun immer noch nicht gefunden
für den Snare.
Ist überall gefragt,
ist ne super Support-Klasse,
macht nahkampfmäßig nicht viel Damage,
kann aber super nerven und ist schwierig zu spielen.
Kann sich nen Patch haben.
Mekro ist
quasi die PvE-Klasse,
ist nicht schlecht hin in Alb.
Wer viel Gold farmen will, macht sich in Nekro.
Nekro im PvP
kann man spielen.
Find ich persönlich
nicht so geil.
Sind die Changes so gut
auf Eden, dass das
gerechtfertigt ist?
Also der Heal-Prog ist halt
mega in Kombination mit nem Cover-Pet
und sowas.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das
nerft wurde mittlerweile.
Es gab ja die Möglichkeit, dass du Cover-Pet-Heal-Progst
und es nicht gestorben ist.
Okay, jetzt muss ich da den Roten killen.
Paladin ist
eines der beliebtesten Klassen in Albion,
weil alle wollen gerne Paladin spielen.
Das ist der zweite Main-Tank
zu Leber Armsman.
Auch Platten-Rüstung
macht nahkampfmäßig bei weitem nicht so viel
Schaden wie Armsman, aber
mit den Anpassungen auf Eden
ganz gut Nahkampf-Damage
und hat paar ganz nette Auren
für mehr Ausdauer
und bisschen mehr Rüstung und sowas.
Paladin ist wirklich nice. Also für alle,
die nen Support-Nahkämpfer spielen
wollen und gerade im
PvM begehrt sein
wollen, ist Paladin wirklich mega.
Pala ist denke ich auch ne ganz
gute
Startklasse, weil viele spielen halt gerne
Paladin.
An sich, ich persönlich
bin kein großer
Pala-Fan.
Aber auf Eden muss der deutlich besser sein
als damals auf Live, weil Eden viele
Custom-Changes für den Pala hat.
So, next.
Pumbled.
Übrigens, das ist auch neu,
dass Dark so ne Overlay hat mit Parried.
Das gibt's erst seit nem halben Jahr oder so.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo das herkommt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das was, was Eden
gebaut hat vom UI oder
weil eigentlich kann ja Eden am kleinen nix machen.
Also da bin ich mir nicht sicher. Vielleicht ist das was
von Eden. Vielleicht ist das auch was, was sie live
live gepatcht haben. Richtig coole Idee.
Also man sieht das, die Leute,
die Entwickler von Eden sind halt einfach besser
als die Broadsword-Leute.
So, dann gibt es Reaver.
Reaver ist so ne komische Klasse
in Alp. Das war die erste
Addon-Klasse.
Das ist quasi nen Tank mit Schild,
Kettenrüstung
und ner Peitsche, der
in Massen
ziemlich krass abgehen kann.
Es gab so ne Taktik
mal früher, nannte sich Reaver-Bombing.
Da hat man
drei oder vier Reaver
in ne Gruppe gepackt
und hat dann die
passenden drei Fähigkeiten
zusammengedrückt und konnte
mit vier Reavern quasi 80 Gegner
instantwipen.
Ansonsten würde ich sagen, ist Reaver
fürs RVR nicht die allergeilste Klasse,
aber im Zerg kann man alles spielen.
PvP, äh PvM, also gegen Monster
ist Reaver fine.
Ich bin kein großer
Reaver-RVR-Fan.
Reaver ist auf jeden Fall nicht schlecht
oder so, aber
mags nicht unbedingt so.
Scout. Wer auf Bogenklassen steht,
kann das spielen. Allerdings, wenn ihr Scout
spielt, rechne nicht damit, dass ihr ne Gruppe
kriegt. Niemand möchte Scouts haben.
Sorcerer. Beste Klasse in Albion.
Meiner Meinung nach. Meine zwei Lieblingsklassen
in Albion eindeutig Sorc und Cleric.
Cover.
Sorc, Cleric, Cover.
Ähm, wenn ihr mich fragt,
die beste Klasse in ganz Albion.
Sorc kann
mega gut Damage machen.
Sorc kann Pet,
Charm und Sorc kann
richtig gut CC'en.
Also eigentlich kann Sorc alles.
Außer heilen.
Sorc ist quasi
ein bisschen wie ein Heiler in Midgard.
Der kann alles außer Damage machen.
Sorc kann alles außer heilen.
Also, wenn ihr mich fragt,
also aus meiner Meinung nach
ist Sorc der beste Caster im Ganzen.
Der beste Caster im ganzen Spiel.
Aber, da gehen ja die Meinungen
in Darug auseinander.
Turk, ja wer auf Pet Caster
steht,
ich persönlich würde Sorc immer vorziehen.
Und Wizard, wer den Caster mit dem höchsten
Damage Output spielen will, aber den wenigsten
One Button Spells, der kann
Wizard spielen. Wizard ist auch sehr beliebt,
gerade bei Boomern wie mir,
die es nicht mehr hinkriegen, mehr als
drei Tasten gleichzeitig zu drücken.
Oder mehr als eine Taste muss man bei Wizard ja sagen.
Nicht hinbekommen, mehr als
eine Taste gleichzeitig zu drücken.
Die spielen Wizard.
Wizard kann jeder spielen.
Also, mir fällt niemand ein, der nicht
in der Lage ist, Wizard zu spielen.
Ich hoffe, ich sterbe nicht an dem Mob.
Ah, parried, nice.
Hallo? Schlagen?
Please? Hallo?
The fuck?
Au, der Mob haut aber gut rein.
Evade, okay, jetzt haben wir's, jetzt haben wir's.
Easy win, easy win.
Eats.
Also, Wizard hat den höchsten
Damage Output von allen Castern, ohne
Debuffs und sowas jetzt.
Ich glaube, er hat sogar, wenn man sich
die Spells anguckt, den höchsten
Damage Nuke im ganzen Game.
Ich glaube, Feuer Wizard hat, glaube ich,
129er DD oder sowas.
Es gibt keine andere Klasse, die so viel hat.
Und Bowls und alles. Also, wer einfach
nur vier, fünf Buttons
möchte und damit Ultra Damage
raushauen, der spielt Wizard. Dafür
kann Wizard sonst nichts. Wizard kann nur Damage machen.
Zack.
So, das war die Klasse in Albion.
Also, mein Favorit eindeutig
Sorc, wobei ich sagen würde, Sorc ist
jetzt keine gute Einstiegsklasse in Dark.
Weil Sorc kann
halt alles irgendwie, außer heilen.
Also, ich würde sagen,
wer Albion anfangen will, eine gute Einstiegsklasse
in Alp ist eindeutig Cleric.
Brauchst du immer. Du wirst immer eine Gruppe
finden, wirst für alles gebraucht. Du kannst Solo
zwar nichts gut auf die Reihe bekommen, aber das
musst du gar nicht unbedingt, weil du bist überall
gefragt und so lernst
du halt Dark Mechanics, wenn du in Gruppe
spielst. Ja, also insofern.
Alter, könnt ihr mal was anderes
außer rote Gegner spawnen?
Wart mal kurz, bis meine DDs wieder da sind,
dass ich dir mal ordentlich Damage machen kann.
So, also, ich würde jemand, der
neu anfängt und
sagt, ich möchte jetzt mal
Albion spielen,
hier würde ich tatsächlich, wenn er Supporter
mag, ihr müsst Supporter mögen, also
ihr müsst es mögen, Gruppen zu
unterstützen mit Buffs und Heals und
Gegner stunnen und
bisschen minimal Damage machen.
Also, wenn ihr jemand seid, der Support
nichts abgewinnen kann, ist Cleric
nichts für euch. Aber wenn ihr Support was
abgewinnen könnt, ohne Mist, Cleric ist eine der
besten Einstiegsklassen im Game
und auf jeden Fall für Albion. Ansonsten,
wenn ihr gar nichts mit Support
anfangen könnt,
man kann auch immer sowas wie Parler oder
Armsman spielen, da macht man auch nichts mit
verkehrt. Kabba geht auch immer
oder
Wizard, Ice Wizard oder
Minit theoretisch auch,
wobei Minit tatsächlich ein bisschen schwieriger ist.
Einzige Sachen,
wo ich vielleicht nicht so spielen würde
zum Einstieg ist,
ja kann man auch spielen, Zorg würde ich
nicht unbedingt als Einstieg empfehlen,
Scout auch nicht, Reaver auch nicht,
Nekro auch nicht unbedingt,
damit kommt man nicht weit,
Mörg
vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt, Mauler
gibt es auf ihn nicht, Heretic kann ich nicht
einschätzen, Infi auch nicht,
Ordi ist auch so ein Ding,
weiß ich nicht, ob das eine gute
Einstiegsklasse ist. Schwer ist sie glaube ich nicht,
ich kann es schlecht einschätzen,
aber Rest alles fein in Alp.
So, gucken wir uns mal die Midgard-Klassen an,
oh guck mal,
Orangenschnell-Gegner, nice du.
Chat, falls irgendjemand
von euch am Start ist, der auch Dark spielt,
ich weiß, viele sind wahrscheinlich am Start hier
von meinem normalen Stream,
aber vielleicht hat ja auch der eine oder andere den Stream hier
gefunden, der selbst Dark spielt.
Was spielt ihr?
Also
ich spiele Zorg auf Alp und
Scalder auf Mid.
Eventuell mache ich mir noch wieder ein Chammy
auf Mid
und noch ein Clary auf Alp,
dass ich jeweils auch gute Kruppchars habe.
Oder Heiler auf Mid, vielleicht diesmal.
Habe ich auch lange gespielt.
So.
Alter,
die Viecher machen gut Damage, Mann.
Ich muss
gucken, dass ich rechtzeitig abhauen kann, wenn ich
zu viel Schaden kriege.
Pariert, jawohl, easy.
Easy Win.
Okay.
So, dann gucken wir uns mal die Mid-Klassen an.
Falls irgendjemand auf
nordische Wikinger steht
und auf Schnee und Eis
und auf Odin, Thor
und sonst was, der ist in Midgard, richtig.
Der kann zum Beispiel
Berserker spielen.
Wahrscheinlich der Tank,
der, oder was heißt Tank,
der Off-Tank
Melee-Damage-Dealer,
der den größten Burst-Damage im ganzen
Game verursachen kann.
Du kannst dich in einen Bär verwandeln,
alle, keine Ahnung,
wie oft,
und dann ist jeder Angriff
ein Critical-Hit.
Und manche, besonders
High-IQ-Bersis,
switchen dann von
Dual-Wield auf zweihändiger Waffe,
um fette, fette
Crits reinzuhauen.
Ansonsten ist Bersi relativ
Straight-Forward
zum Gegner hin, draufschlagen,
bis er tot ist.
Kann man nicht allzu viel verkehrt machen.
Also, als nächstes Bone-Dancer.
Bone-Dancer ist so ein Ding.
Bone-Dancer finde ich, ist eine super
Einstiegsklasse, die ist nicht schwer zu spielen.
Jeder kann Bone-Dancer spielen.
Aber Bone-Dancer hat durch die zusätzlichen Pets
eine gewisse Tiefe.
Also ich finde Bone-Dancer ist eine super
Einstiegsklasse, weil
du kannst die One-Tap, Live-Tap spielen,
ohne dir Gedanken machen zu müssen.
Und killst damit fast alles.
Außer Leute, die eine passende Klasse haben
und ganz gut spielen.
Du kannst Solo-PvM machen.
Und
wenn du dich ein bisschen
mit der Klasse beschäftigst, kannst du auch noch
deutlich mehr.
Gerade, wenn du gelernt hast, wie du dich
positionieren musst,
was du, mal Gegner wegrouten kannst,
wo du deine Pets draufschickst und so.
Also ich glaube, BD dürfte
aus dem Grund eine der besten Einstiegsklassen
sein, wenn man auf Caster steht.
Weil BD ist easy
zu lernen und
mediumschwer zu mastern.
Aber,
bringt auch was.
Ist auch im großen RVR gut,
wenn du mit mehreren Leuten spielst,
TWF und sowas. Also BD ist eine super
Einstiegsklasse in Midgard, finde ich.
Kannst alles solo machen, kannst
Group spielen, kannst RVR spielen,
alle Sachen. Also BD ist immer gut.
Heiler
dürfte mit die beste Support-Klasse
im ganzen Spiel sein.
Kann alles, außer Damage machen.
Würde ich als Einstieg nicht empfehlen.
Ist zu schwierig.
Selbst wenn ihr gerne Supporter spielt.
Weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht,
falls wir ein paar Daok-Erfahrene haben,
aber Heiler als Einstieg
ist echt hart.
Du musst genau wissen, was du machst.
Und du musst was machen.
Wenn's deine
Nahkampf-Damage-Dealer verkacken,
verkacken's die Damage-Dealer, stirbt keiner von.
Wenn du's als Heiler verkackst,
egal in welchem
Sektor,
bist du eigentlich im Arsch.
Wenn du dich richtig heilst, Gruppe tot, dann ist das echt hart.
Wenn du nicht Buffs verteilst,
wie's sein muss,
und Nahkampf-Damage und so, dann killt die Gruppe
langsamer, wie's sein muss.
Und wenn du nicht richtig CC'st, wird die Gruppe überrannt.
Also Heiler ist echt
schwer gut zu spielen.
Wenn ihr Heiler spielen wollt,
dann auf jeden Fall Augheiler.
Augheiler ist deutlich einfacher
als Puck- oder Treespec-Heiler.
Augheiler müsst ihr im Endeffekt
nur heilen und ab und zu mal
einen
Nahkampf-Speed-Buff
machen.
Ich glaub, wir haben's, oder?
Ich glaube, wir haben die Quest fertig.
Jetzt nur noch
Yagre killen.
Wobei, der ist angeblich hier.
Ich hab den hier nicht gesehen.
Angeblich ist hier Yagre.
Ah, Moment, hier ist er doch.
Lull.
Okay, Quest fertig.
Moin, Phipps.
Quest.
Nice.
Kann man hier eigentlich porten?
Okay, wir laufen zurück.
So, komm ich ungefähr
hier bei der Festung raus? Ich hoffe es.
Also, wie gesagt, Heiler, super
Support-Klasse. Wenn ihr Augheiler spielt, ist
das auch eine ganz brauchbare Einstiegsklasse.
Aber Treespec und Puck-Heiler ist
zu schwer als Einsteiger. Hunter, Bogi,
keiner, Mauler, juckt nicht.
Runemaster ist quasi
so der Main, ja,
der Main-Range-DPS-
Caster in Midgard.
Ist,
finde ich,
nicht so geil.
Hat nicht so viele Spells.
Kann nicht so viel machen.
Ist im Zerg ganz gut
mit AE-Sperren und sowas.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie aktuell so das
8er, ups, bin falsch, das 8er-Meta
aussieht, was Runemaster angeht.
Ich würde aber fast vermuten,
auch da eher nicht.
Dafür ist es einfach zu spielen.
Aber Midgard ist nicht wirklich
für die krassen Caster bekannt.
So, dann gibt es Savage.
Auf Deutsch heißt das Wilder.
Eigentlich ganz gut übersetzt.
Ist quasi wie ein Bersi.
Nur, dass du nicht Äxte verwendest, sondern
Clown, die
mehrfach treffen können.
Savage hat theoretisch sogar noch
ein höheres Nahkampf-Burst-Potential
als Bersi. Aber
ja, ist
schwierig reliable, dann
diesen superkrassen Damage zu machen.
Nimmt sich nicht viel. Kann man beides
spielen. Bersi, Savage, beides
gut.
Nimmt sich echt nicht viel.
Ist ziemlich ähnlich.
Wobei Savage
komplizierter ist, durch die ganzen
Self-Buffs, die du noch hast.
Ich finde, Savage ist keine gute Einstiegsklasse.
Wenn einer wirklich
Melee-DPS spielen will, dann soll er lieber
Bersi spielen. Savage ist zu
kompliziert für Einsteiger. Erstmal.
Finde ich.
Mein Gen tut alles.
So, 24. Zack, bumm.
Easy. Fat Axe, Mann.
Was macht
eigentlich Danik?
Ah, der sitzt noch in Titranki rum.
25. Nice.
Okay.
Ich würde
sagen... Was waren wir denn
jetzt? Wir sind 25.
Waren wir gleich weiter.
Erstmal trainieren.
Habe ich jetzt genug Geld, um mir ein paar
Tränke zu kaufen?
Ja, ich habe genug Geld, um mir Tränke
kaufen zu können.
50.
Necklace.
Brauchen wir eh nicht.
Brauchen wir nicht, aber...
Ah, Two-Handed-Axt.
Wie sieht die Stats aus?
Cons...
Woah.
Hätte ich doch das lieber behalten sollen?
Stärke?
Moment, ich brauche max Stärke, Alter.
Alles andere. Sagt doch mal richtig.
Quickness ist okay.
Habt ihr irgendein Item, was Stärke gibt, vielleicht?
Constitution...
Quickness...
Oh, nö.
Ja, wenn ich jetzt wüsste, wo der Quartermaster
ist, dann könnte ich mir einfach eine neue Rüstung kaufen.
Weil ich
brauche eine neue Rüstung.
Wo eiert der Quartermaster rum?
Können wir löschen.
So...
Alles klar.
Ob ich jetzt zu einem der Quartermaster hier gehen kann.
In Windsor.
Alles klar.
Das ist richtig nice.
Ja, und falls du
früher gespielt hast und dich fragst, was da abgeht.
Es ist am
Samstag ist
Season 2 auf Eden gestartet.
Eden ist ein Dark Freeshard.
Das heißt, falls du früher gespielt hast,
mal wieder Bock hast, ist jetzt
genau die richtige...
Wann gibt's denn eigentlich den neuen Speed?
Battlesong...
Speed! Jawoll!
Und ja, Leute, bevor jetzt
irgendwelche Darkcanner zugucken, ich weiß, dass Schwert
eigentlich...
Dass Hammer eigentlich besser ist, aber ich spiel
lieber Schwert. So. Wir gehen jetzt mal
ganz kurz ins BG gucken.
Weil ich möchte 1L4
machen. 1L4.
Da kann ich
Longwind 2 kaufen. Und mit Longwind 2
sollte ich nahezu unendlich
sprinten können.
Vorher porten wir nochmal in die Housing.
Und kauf uns endlich einen
Endu-Trank.
Um die Sache hier nochmal abzuschließen.
Für Midgard.
Schamane. Also wenn ihr Bock auf
Support habt. Support, der auch
ein bisschen was machen kann.
Und
leicht bis semi leicht
zu spielen ist, dann ist Schamane
wirklich gut. Schamane ist die Main-Buff-
Klasse in Mid.
Wird immer gebraucht. Jede Gruppe braucht
einen Shami.
Und du kannst als Shami
auch ein bisschen offensiv was machen.
Ich finde, Schamane ist eigentlich
eine Klasse, die kann man super simpel spielen.
Aber ich finde, Schamane ist tatsächlich eine der coolsten
Klassen, die es gibt.
Weil das eine seltene Kombination
ist aus
ich will nicht gerade sagen
Damage.
Weil das ist jetzt nicht mit einem vollen Caster zu vergleichen.
Aber Schamane
kann ganz gut nerven, Schaden machen
und interupten.
Plus sehr gut buffen.
Und ein bisschen heilen.
Also Schamane ist wirklich eine interessante Klasse.
Die kann man
sehr eigen spielen.
Und die ist nicht super schwer zu spielen.
Weil es gibt nicht so viele Spells.
Und die meisten sind permanent.
Drückst da halt einmal die Buffs drauf.
Aber du kannst ein bisschen was machen.
Du hast einen Bolt mit großer Reichweite für Damage.
Hast einen halbwegs brauchbaren DD.
Wobei so hoch skillt keiner Cave.
Hast AE-Root,
AE-Seuche. Also Schamane ist eine wirklich coole
Einstiegsklasse.
In Midgard eine der coolsten Einstiegsklassen
würde ich sagen.
Neben vielleicht
BD und Orkheiler.
Also kann man auf jeden Fall empfehlen.
Wenn man Bock hat auf
Support, der auch offensiv ein bisschen was
machen kann.
Ist Schamane wirklich cool.
Skalde ist eine super Klasse.
Für mich persönlich die beste Solo-Klasse im ganzen Spiel.
Deswegen spiele ich auch in Alp
Sorg für Gruppen, Zeug
und
auf Mid Skalde
nur Zeug, RVR und Solo
rumgerenne. Skalde ist top.
Skalde ist
einfach auf der einen Seite.
Du hast ein paar Nahkampfangriffe.
Du hast ein paar Songs und Spells
die du drücken musst.
Bei Skalde kommst
um das Solo, beziehungsweise
auch
Solo im Grenzgebiet
navigieren zu können und
vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen schön reinzuadden in die
Fights, abzustauben und wieder abzuhauen
und was man halt als Skalde so macht.
Auch mal ein bisschen
Dark Knowledge.
Man muss wissen, was die gegnerischen Klassen können.
Man muss
Fights gut einschätzen können,
also gerade wenn man Solo lebend wieder rauskommen will.
Ja wenn du z.B. jetzt auf irgendeinen
Schleicher-Fight addest,
da musst du gut einschätzen können, wen greifst du jetzt zuerst an?
Wer ist am gefährlichsten?
Wo rennst du lieber weg? Engage neu?
Also Skalde wirklich
gut zu spielen Solo
ist gar nicht so einfach finde ich.
Aber...
an sich ist super einfach und sehr effektiv also auch eine tolle einstiegsklasse spirit
master für mich der langweiligste caster im ganzen spiel hat ein pet und macht zeug donnerkrieger die
noob klasse schlechthin in dem spiel jeder der damals dauer angefangen mit gerade gespielt hat
jeder hat donnerkrieger gespielt weil tor und blitze und hammer der fabian ist nicht dabei
vielleicht am wochenende mal gucken ob er bock hat er weiß auf jeden fall bescheid ich persönlich
mag donnerkrieger gar nicht so sehr als einstiegsklasse für zerg rvr ist donnerkrieger
gut für alles andere ja also pvm tanken kann er auch ist er ist er brauchbarer einstiegsklasse ich
persönlich würde was anderes empfehlen es ist aber also donnerkrieger ist die dauer
knub klasse schlechthin mir fällt jetzt nichts im vergleich von anderen games ein was sie nun
aber
aber donnerkrieger ist die klasse die jeder daug neuling der mitgang anfängt instinktiv
anlegt ja genau hammer und sowas du kannst dich auch schwer sehr schnell unbeliebt machen als
als donnerkrieger dann hast du mal kühre als letztes oder als einzelnetzten klasse
noch mal kür ist eine erneut klasse eigentlich sehr nice weiß ich nicht ob ich die als als
einstiegsklasse empfehlen würde weil kühre ist eine mischung aus
aus Support und
Nahkampf-Support
kann man schwer
beschreiben. Du kannst
Damage machen im Nahkampf, den machst du aber
weniger durch reinen Waffendamage,
sondern mehr durch Procs
und zusätzliche
Abilities
und du kannst
ganz brauchbar heilen.
Und auch ein bisschen tanken.
Also Valkyrie ist, glaube ich,
kein allzu guter Einstiegs-Char, aber auf jeden Fall
nice, dass es gibt. Warlock,
weiß ich gar nicht, ob es sie auf Eden überhaupt gibt.
Bin mir nicht sicher, ob
das, was ich im Kopf habe, jetzt Eden war
oder Phoenix.
Ich glaube Eden. Doch, doch, ich glaube, es gibt
Warlock. Warlock kann ich nicht
zusammenfassen, ist eine sehr weird
Klasse. Warlocks
können casten, können heilen
und als Warlock hast du so komische
Blasen über dem Kopf, wo du instant casten
kannst. Ganz weird. Ist aber auf jeden
Fall nichts für Einsteiger.
Warrior, gut.
Der Main-Tank schlechthin in Midgard.
Wenn jemand was spielen will,
passt mal auf, ich zeige euch mal hier.
Also, guckt mal Leute. Das ist Skill-Tree
Valkyrie.
Guckt euch das an. Kannst du skillen.
Und jetzt kommt Skill-Tree Warrior. Fertig.
Ich meine,
Warrior ist, glaube ich, so ziemlich
die einfachste Klasse zu skillen schlechthin.
50 Schild,
50 Waffe, Rest Parry.
Manch einer, der besonders auf Solo
geht, speckt vielleicht ein bisschen weniger
Waffe, ein bisschen mehr Parry.
Das war's. Easy.
Also, Warrior kannst du
eigentlich nicht verskillen.
Und Warrior ist rein vom Nahkampf-
Damage,
also von den internen
Stats im Game,
die stärkste
Nahkampf-Klasse. Du kriegst die meisten
Leben und du kriegst
die meisten Damage-Modifier
als Warrior.
Was aber die anderen wieder
wettmachen. Also, ich würde nicht
sagen, der beste Tank
im Spiel.
Ja. So. Bevor wir jetzt weitermachen,
muss ich mir überlegen, gehe ich jetzt
mal... Was macht eigentlich hier? Was macht
denn Danik? Ah, da ist 23
ins Hit. Oh, ist nice. Nice.
Vielleicht spielen wir gleich wieder mit
Danik eine Runde.
So. Dann porten
wir mal ins BG.
Ach, Quatsch. Ich kack-Noob,
Alter. Ich bin in die Housing geportet.
Um mir Endo-Dränke zu kaufen.
Und was hab ich gemacht? Mir keine
Endo-Dränke gekauft, Mann.
High IQ.
Komm, scheiß
drauf. Scheiß drauf. Wurscht. Ich kauf
mir keine Endo-Dränke.
Ich kauf mir ne ordentliche Rüstung.
Slash.
Slash-Hop ist am Start.
Nice.
Ja. Hi.
So. Ich brauch... Was brauch
ich denn? Ich brauch ne Rüstung.
Kostet 25 Bounty.
Bounty-Points. Kann ich mir das überhaupt leisten?
Kann ich mir das leisten?
Wie viele Bounty... Alter, Moment.
Bounty-Points. 3er kann ich mir leisten.
Okay.
Chest-Piece.
Ich brauch alles, oder?
Ah, die Ärmel gehen. Ärmel gehen.
Hose.
Dings.
Kopf.
Okay. Ready.
Haben wir ordentliche Rüstung am Start. Voll gebufft.
Jawoll. Auf geht's.
So. Wir sind wieder im PvP-Gebiet.
Schauen wir mal, wie gut das läuft.
Vielleicht levelt
Danik ja auch wieder ran.
Wenn's gut bei ihm in C-Trunky läuft.
Und...
Wir können da wieder zusammenspielen.
Oh, ich kack nur. Ich hab vergessen, die Quests anzunehmen.
Ach, guck mal.
Da laden Dings-Pumps. Bip. Ist wieder am Start.
Wir können wieder einladen.
Wenn er will.
Okay. Let's go.
Kann ich noch trainen?
So, wir warten mal, bis der da ist.
Hab ich irgendwelche Battlesongs?
So, wir sind alle 25. Das passt gut.
Fehlt doch eigentlich nur noch...
Danik.
Der braucht noch zwei Level. Dann geht's los.
So, wir machen jetzt ein bisschen PvP noch.
Bis ich 1L4 bin.
1L4 kauf ich mir Longwind 2.
Und dann wird's weiter... Okay.
Dann nicht.
So, mal gucken, wie viel hier los ist.
Wie heißt denn dieses BG überhaupt?
Hat jemand aufgepasst?
Wo bin ich? In Braema.
Okay. Wer ist denn?
Who? Braema.
15 Leute sind da drin.
Okay. Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal.
Erstmal Bäume bashen.
Baum bash.
Ich könnte jetzt eigentlich,
wenn der hier am Start ist,
mal den anderen Style verwenden, der ein bisschen Endo spart.
Easy.
Ich brauch unbedingt meine Makro...
Nicht meine Makro, meine
Shortcut-Software.
Dass ich das mappen kann.
Wartet mal.
Ich leg das mal kurz...
dahin. Da kann ich's
theoretisch wenigstens
hier auf 2 auslösen.
Bisschen Hände verbiegen.
Der Bäumesound. Hören sich bei euch
nicht auch Bäume immer so an?
So machen Bäume eindeutig.
Also cringe, wenn eure Bäume so nicht machen.
Aber ich hab euch ja vorhin die Story...
Oh fuck. Fuck.
Den greif ich nicht an.
Ich bin zu low.
Zu low leben.
Aber ich weiß was. Ey, der soll herkommen.
Wir kiten den. Wir kiten den.
Wir kiten den. Pass mal auf.
Wir kiten den.
Ich hoffe, der kommt.
Alter, komm her. Komm her.
Komm her. Komm her.
Komm her. Der soll sich nicht tarnen.
Der soll sich nicht tarnen. Jawoll. Jawoll. Geht rauf.
Sehr gut. Excellent.
Ich liebe es, wenn man die Leute outplayen kann.
Oh fuck.
Passt.
Den...
Weggenubt.
Oh shit.
Ja heil mich. Vados.
Perfekt. Excellent. Ehrenmann
Vados, Mann.
Siehste? Und das sind so Dinger,
...
Also. Das ist das was ich meinte,
Also mal zur Erklärung.
Man konnte es, glaube ich, nicht richtig nachvollziehen, wenn man nicht Dark spielt.
Also, das ist hier ein Bone Dancer bei mir in der Gruppe.
Der wurde angegriffen von einem Gegner.
Das war ein Schleicher, der kann sich tarmen, den hat man nicht gesehen.
Der ist quasi, während wir gegen die Bäume gekämpft haben, ist der ran geschlichen an den hier und hat den quasi backstabbed und hat ihn fast one-shotted.
Ich habe es ein bisschen zu spät gesehen, weil ich den betäuben wollte, habe ich nicht hinbekommen.
Aber ich habe es geschafft, ihn zu betäuben, nachdem mein Caster, ein Stelzer war das.
Daher kommt übrigens das Wort Stelzer.
Falls sich irgendjemand fragt, warum der Fabian und ich immer Stelzer gesagt haben früher, das kommt aus Dark.
Zumindest, ich habe es geschafft, ihn zu betäuben für 18 Sekunden.
Und dann war halt das Ding, ich warte selbst nur noch 40% Leben und der Gegner war Orange.
Das heißt, er hat ein höheres Level.
Den hätte ich im Leben nie im Nahkampf überhaupt killen können.
Deswegen habe ich gewartet, bis mein Typ vom Keep zurückkommt.
Ich wusste ja nicht, dass er nicht losläuft.
Und die Schleicher können sich nicht tarnen, wenn sie im Kampf waren, bis zu ein paar Sekunden danach.
So, das heißt, ich bin von ihm weggelaufen, weil der kann nur Nahkampf-Damage machen.
Wieso basht du Bäume? Weil es eine Quest gibt.
Um Bäume zu bashen.
Der kann nur vernünftig Nahkampf-Damage machen.
Wobei das ein Hip-Schleicher war, der kann auch ein bisschen casten.
So, dementsprechend habe ich gewartet, bis meine Betäubung ausläuft.
Dann den Typ angeguckt.
Der wollte sich tarnen, konnte aber noch nicht.
Dann habe ich ihn gesnared, dass er nicht wegrennen kann.
Resettet seinen Stealth-Timer auch.
Ein Nachtschatten, genau, ein Nightshade.
Und...
Danach habe ich geschaut.
Dann habe ich gesehen, dass Leute von mir kommen.
Dann habe ich ihm einen Damage-Shout gegeben, als er casten wollte.
Albs, Albs, Albs, Albs, Albs, Albs.
Oh, das ist eine Guild-Group, glaube ich.
Okay, vorne ist der Saracene.
Vorne ist die Zorg.
Oh, Metz, Metz, Jawohl!
Metz raus.
Cleric, Cleric, Cleric, Cleric.
Okay, ich bin auf dem Heiler drauf.
Perfekt.
Guck mal, das ist ein Bersi, der one-shottet den.
Das ist das, was ich meinte.
Burst-Damage von Bersis.
Oh, nee!
Oh, ich bin geslammed, shit.
Okay, dead.
Zu weit reingecharged, aber da können wir nichts machen.
Schön von der Seite geadded haben sie uns.
Ich könnte releasen und da einfach schnell wieder hingehen.
Aber doch.
Wir gehen da schnell hin.
Da habe ich ein bisschen overextended jetzt.
Da bin ich ein bisschen zu weit reingerusht.
Ich habe gedacht, die pushen hinterher.
Ich muss...
Wobei, ich muss die Caster interrupten.
Das bleibt mir nichts anderes übrig.
Okay, die sterben.
Ich gehe zurück.
Ja.
Und dann habe ich den Nightshade, das er nicht casten konnte, angeschautet, bis meine anderen da waren.
Und der war so gierig und ist nicht weg und wollte sich tarnen.
Dementsprechend haben wir den gekillt.
Danik ist 24, der kann gleich mitmachen.
Bashen, Alter, bashen, ja.
Wir gehen mal mit denen mit.
Wir zerren die jetzt einfach weg.
Easy.
Meine Leute haben keinen Bock, sich zu bewegen.
Auf, Leute, moved!
Okay.
Haben keinen Bock.
Ich laufe mit denen.
Da sind sie doch.
Let's go.
Es wäre sinnvoll, wenn wir mit den anderen mitlaufen würden.
Da hinten sind die Deserter.
Ah, gut.
Die sind etwas too slow.
Guck mal, wir haben ein...
Einhänderschwert ist das, ne?
Nehmen wir das trotzdem mal, weil eine Axt kann ich hier nicht nehmen.
Ich brauche unbedingt meine Shortcuts wieder.
Ich habe die Songs auf den Maustasten jetzt.
Auf Zirkumflex habe ich mein Matz.
Da bin ich mir noch nicht sicher, welchen Button ich damit belegt habe.
Und ich bräuchte eigentlich noch den Shortcut für den Snare.
Aber den habe ich gerade nicht gemappt.
Deswegen machen wir es mal so.
Den kriege ich auch noch so ausgelöst.
Oh, ich glaube, da sind Alps irgendwo.
Weil die, die hier oben sterben, das ist immer auch wichtig.
Muss man mal drauf gucken.
Die, die hier oben sterben, ist die Gruppe, die gerade an uns vorbeigelaufen ist.
Die wurde gerade von den Alps weggezogen.
Gezerkt.
Wobei, weggezerkt, weiß ich nicht.
Das waren immer ähnliche Kills.
Aber sie sind auf jeden Fall Alps am Start.
Ah, wir haben 1L4.
Nice.
Oh, Ink.
Ink.
Oh, viel zu viele, Mann.
Viel zu viele.
Das ist ein Clary?
Oh, shit.
Ah, meine Maus.
Fucking shit.
Ah, warum kriege ich den nicht angeklickt?
Alter, Boomer.
Okay, es sind zu viele.
Es sind zu viele.
Kann man nichts machen.
Der Frasier.
Der Frasier hat irgendwie gerade keinen Bock.
Aber vielleicht ist er am Wochenende.
Wird er am Wochenende wieder dabei.
Pass auf, Danik ist gleich rangeleffert.
Kann er mit, mit.
So.
Finish.
So, jetzt sollten wir alle zusammenlaufen.
Die haben keinen Bock.
Alter, Leute.
Wollt ihr jetzt, wollt ihr wieder mit der Gruppe in die ganzen Alps rennen, oder was?
Wir sollten jetzt denen einfach mal hinterher.
Was sind Alps?
Mit B.
Das sind die Spieler aus Albion.
Wir können doch einfach questen.
Nee, egal.
Ja, Runi.
Runi, auf.
Oh, die sind wieder alle so brain-afk hier.
Was ist da los?
Let's go, Leute.
Let's go.
Wenn ich eines hasse in Dark, ist es sinnlos, das rumstehen, weil irgendwelche Leute afk sind.
Da dreh ich durch.
Richtig, die NPCs, deine Mates.
Na, beim ersten Fight hat man gesehen, so schlecht sind die gar nicht.
Aber die Group vorhin war eindeutig besser.
So, Bäume bashen müssen wir nicht mehr.
Sag mal, was ist mit euch los?
Lauft halt geradeaus, Mann.
Ich bin kein Dark-Streamer.
Ich mache normalerweise ganz anderes Zeug.
Aber ich bin alter Dark-Spieler.
Und natürlich...
Oh, oh, hier war ein Alps.
Hier war ein Alps am Start.
Alps, ink, ink, ink.
Also, ich spiele das seit 2000...
Wann kam es in Europa raus?
2002?
East?
East, East, East, East, East, East.
Okay, da müssen wir...
Oh, da müssen wir...
Die müssen wir assjam, Leute.
Die müssen wir richtig hart assjam.
Richtig hart geassjammt.
Werden jetzt...
Gatschi-Bass, Leute.
Gatschi-Bass.
Alter, der ist frei.
Warum ist der frei?
Der soll nicht frei sein.
Der soll verrecken jetzt.
Ah, okay.
Der hat gefacet.
Der war nicht blöd.
Jetzt stehe ich 35 Minuten.
Nice.
Yeah.
35 Minuten...
Äh, 35 Sekunden rumstehen.
Beste.
Weil ich nicht aufgepasst habe.
Jawoll.
Pogu.
Okay.
Aber gab ganz gut RPs.
Nice.
Ach, da ist noch einer.
Nee.
Ach, Deserters.
Okay.
Dessert.
Pipo Fett.
Aufmacht Damage, Jungs.
Damage.
Gebt das nochmal ganz gut.
Wie lange bin ich denn eigentlich schon on?
Alter, 4 Stunden 40.
Seriously.
Hast du den Trailer von Eden gesehen mit ihrem neuen...
Ja, hab ich.
Hab ich.
Ich bin da immer pessimistisch, was sowas angeht.
Ich kann ansatzweise...
Ich kann ansatzweise erahnen, was das für ein Aufwand ist, wenn man auch, sagen wir mal so, moderne Tools zur Game-Entwicklung nicht unterschätzen darf.
Also es gibt auf der einen Seite deutlich erhöhte Komplexität, auf der anderen Seite deutlich bessere Tools, sodass ich sagen würde, unterm Strich vielleicht ein bisschen einfacher sogar noch Spiele zu machen.
Aber da gehört schon enorm viel dabei, ja.
Und, also, ich bin da pessimistisch, weil sowas, ob da was rauskommt.
Ich bin skeptisch.
Es wäre mega.
Wobei ich da halt auch wieder die nächste Frage, die ich mir stelle, ist, wie sieht's Copyright-technisch aus?
Weil sobald da irgendwas...
Ink.
Wo ist der Bade?
Weißt du?
Da steht der Bade.
Steht.
Sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Leute, aufwärts, sendet Tanks, killen.
Oder auch nicht.
Ey, der kämpft doch nicht.
Okay, okay, wir sind dead.
Wir sind dead.
Wir haben verloren.
Dead.
Wir können uns hinsetzen.
Ähm.
Wo bin ich denn gerade?
Stehen geblieben.
Ja, also, Unreal-Projekt, wie gesagt, ich bin da skeptisch.
Ich bin da skeptisch, ähm, ob da was rauskommt.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, das sehe ich ganz anders.
Also, es kann sein, dass es Copyright-technisch okay ist, einen Dark-Free-Shot anzubieten.
Weil die ursprüngliche Server-Software ja irgendwie mal von Mystic selbst released wurde oder sowas unter irgendeiner Lizenz.
Aber einen Dark-Client zu programmieren, der eventuell sogar Original-Dark-Assets verwendet, das wird nicht funktionieren.
Also, wenn Sie vielleicht keine originalen Dark-Assets verwenden, dann wäre es eventuell möglich, dann ist halt die Frage, inwieweit das noch wie Dark aussieht.
Ähm.
Also, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin echt skeptisch, was, was das anbelangt.
Ganz ehrlich.
Aber ich lass, ich lass mich gerne eines beobachten.
Weil ich fände es mega, und, also, wenn es, wenn es einen modernen, moderneren Dark-Client geben würde, als den hier.
Zumal Camelot Unchained ja mittlerweile, ich will nicht sagen, zum Scam geworden ist, weil Scam impliziert, er hatte von Anfang an vor, die Leute zu verarschen, das glaube ich nicht.
Aber, ähm, es wird halt nichts mehr.
Ähm, ist EA nicht raus? Haben die das nicht verkauft an Broadsword?
Und Broadsword?
Das hat mit EA nichts mehr zu tun.
Haben die die Rechte nicht verkauft?
Aber Broadsword könnte sich genauso gut darüber aufregen.
Also, ich könnte mir vorstellen, selbst wenn sie theoretisch Recht bekommen würden, ob sie sich auf ein Rechtstreit einlassen wollen, ist halt wieder die Frage, ja.
Ich persönlich würde es hoffen, und ganz ehrlich, seriously, wisst, wisst ihr was, wisst ihr was ich machen würde, wenn ich, äh, paar Millionen hätte?
Ich würde versuchen, die Rechte zu bekommen.
Und ein offizielles Dark zu machen.
Also, ich habe aber keine paar Millionen dafür übrig.
Und wenn der Hersteller, wenn Broadsword schlau wäre, und das Potential darin erkennen würde, dann würden sie das vielleicht fördern und nicht direkt unterbinden.
Aber Broadsword traue ich halt echt gar nichts zu.
Warum killen wir eigentlich wieder Bäume?
Wir sind fertig mit Bäumen.
Ich sehe nichts.
Übrigens, diese Fürze hier, das ist AE-Zeug vom Shammy.
Falls sich vorhin jemand gefragt hat, so, was machen Shammy's eigentlich?
Die machen so AE-Fürze.
Die Baum-Sounds macht mich immer noch fertig.
Ja, für alle, die vorher nicht dabei waren, ich erzähle euch nochmal kurz die Story.
Wisst ihr, woher die Dark-Sounds kommen?
Die haben damals festgestellt, während der Entwicklung des Spiels, dass sie keine guten Sound-Designer sind und haben.
Und deswegen haben die sich das Äquivalent von Stock-Footage gekauft im Jahr 2001, 2000.
Die haben sich eine Stock-Audio-CD gekauft damals.
Und da sind alle möglichen Sounds drauf gewesen, so.
Natur-Sounds, oh fuck.
Ja, ja, ich, ah, shit, jetzt lassen sie, jetzt haben sie mich abgestellt.
Direkt.
Oh, ich muss weg, ich muss weg, ich muss ganz schnell weg.
Okay.
Übrigens, Turks sind übelst OP in BGs.
Wegen, unter anderem.
Mit dem Kram da.
Das ist nice.
Übrigens, Pets, die auf einen geschickt werden, sollte man nicht killen.
Dann ist man nicht CC-bar.
Alter.
Die Laps, man, hier.
Was ist da los?
Ja, Turk ist richtig krass at low level.
Die Mids können sich aber auch mal zusammenreißen und zusammenlaufen.
Nicht hier komplett planlos rumstelzen.
Aber das macht nichts, wir haben gute XP gemacht.
Wir haben...
Train.
Wir können Longwind 2.
Erstmal kaufen, Temporea, das wird nachher wieder gelöscht.
Train, bisschen Battlesongs, neuer DD.
Erster Resi-Song, ja, das könnte man...
Oh, nee, noch nicht, noch nicht.
Noch nicht.
Dafür Schwertspeck.
Neuer DD.
Ja, und bisschen mehr Level könnten wir auch haben.
Ja, alles gut.
Oh, Buffs brauche ich, Buffs brauche ich, cool.
Ja, so sieht das auch in DAG aus, manchmal ist man auch...
Wie sagt unser Brain mit immer?
An manchen Tagen ist man der Baum, an manchen Tagen ist man der Hund.
Oder in manchen Fights ist man der Baum, in manchen ist man der Hund.
Also, Strength.
Wir haben jemand in der Gruppe, ich habe ja den Chat unkenntlich gemacht.
Wir haben jemand in der Gruppe, der komplett neu ist und meint so,
sorry, Leute, sorry, falls ich nichts auf die Reihe kriege.
Ich muss dem gerade mal gut zureden.
Also, ihr seht, es gibt auch Neulinge.
Und er spielt Shami.
Als hätte er mal einen Stream geguckt, hä?
Shami ist eine super Einstiegsklasse in dem Game.
Ah ja, und man kann übrigens mittlerweile die Lampe anmachen.
Das haben die in Eden gepatcht, dass man nur noch selbst die Lampe sieht.
Ich muss dem erstmal gut zureden, dass es ja nur BG ist und es eigentlich hier überhaupt auf nichts ankommt.
So, hätten wir noch ein paar Level mehr?
Und hätten wir vielleicht noch einen achten und einen zweiten Heiler?
Wäre schon enorm pog.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wen ich alles...
Also, ich muss auf jeden Fall die Hexe abstellen.
So, und danach...
Eigentlich muss ich direkt den Turk interrupten, dass er keine Pets aufstellt, weil die total broken im BG sind.
Das Problem ist nur, wenn ich nicht auf den Clary gehe und der Clary von uns nicht abgestellt wird, geht niemand auf den Clary.
Also, insofern...
Tja.
Schauen wir mal, wie die Fight so laufen.
Mit Tank Trains.
Lass mich raten, du hast zu Zeiten gespielt, wo die Leute Triple Savage gespielt haben.
Das war so ziemlich...
Aus heutiger Sicht, glaube ich, mit das nervigste Meta, was ich je in Dark gesehen habe.
Triple Savage Meta.
Triple Savage Meta ist echt Pains Champ.
Wir werden eh gleich wieder gebasht von der Seite.
Wobei, wir sehen die Alps ja auf der Map.
Ich glaube, das waren die, oder?
Also, Triple Savage...
Übrigens, aus heutiger Sicht hättest du wahrscheinlich mit Triple Savage gar nicht mehr so viel Erfolg.
Heute wissen die Leute, wie man gescheit kited und gescheit spielt.
Aber damals war Triple Savage krass.
Wobei, ich ja persönlich sagen muss, ich hätte damals schon Double Savage Krieger oder sowas gespielt.
Aber Triple Savage war nervig, auf jeden Fall.
Trotzdem haben wir damals gegen die meisten Triple Savage Gruppen gewonnen, außer Ultra HRR.
Das war schon...
Alps on top?
Okay, okay.
Wo?
Ich sehe keine Alps.
Wo sind Laps?
Wo sind sie?
Wo sind die Laps?
Ich sehe nichts.
Oh, habe ich die Deserter-Quest vergessen anzunehmen?
Kann das sein?
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Habe ich nicht vergessen.
Oh, shit.
Ey, Alter, die Ass-Gem ja so krass.
Den zu hitten ist dumm.
Wir müssen...
Warum geht denn der auf mich?
Jetzt kommen die Alps noch dabei.
Lull.
By the way, wir sollten nicht den Tank hitten, ne?
Ich sag's nur mal so.
Ja, Tank-Trupp war...
Generell gab's eine Zeit lang, da war es übelst meta.
Um Tanks zu spielen.
Was aber auch mit daran lag...
Gibt's aber echt auf den Sack.
Was?
Wie sollen wir Heiler hier protecten?
Wir haben doch nix dagegen, ne?
Heiler muss kiten und wir müssen die richtigen Targets picken.
Und wer schneller fällt, hat gewonnen.
Das ist in BG nicht so easy, wie die Leute im Chat da grad schreiben.
Also hier im Ingame-Chat.
Wir brauchen...
Wir brauchen unseren Brain.
Ähm...
Wenn du Caverns macht, ja.
Sekunde, Sekunde.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ähm...
Eden, Vicky...
Da mach ich mit, wenn der Vendo macht.
Eden.
Äh, Vicky.
Midgard.
Vendo.
Immer noch am Kryten, ja.
Immer noch Kreise, Kreise Kryten.
Ähm, by the way, wir sollten einfach mal die...
Oh, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Die Surters, die Surters.
Oh, wir haben nicht mal alle die Surters gekillt.
Wie haben wir das denn geschafft, ey?
Also, das ist nett.
So, wir sollten jetzt einfach mal die Quests abschließen und dann raus hier.
Weil lange gucke ich mir das nicht noch mit an.
Wir sollten jetzt einfach noch zwei, drei Mobs killen und dann ist gut.
Oder...
Was ich ja viel sinnvoller finden würde.
Wir laufen ein bisschen außenrum und nicht unbedingt direkt den Alps und den Hips in die Ärmel.
Alter.
Wie viele von diesen Kackbäumen wollen wir denn noch killen, Mann?
Wir haben schon 300 Bäume geschnetzelt.
Ich brauch die Bäume nicht mehr.
Kann man eigentlich noch Turkpads amnesien, dass die dann nichts mehr machen?
Weiß ich nicht, ob sie das irgendwie...
Das ging mal nicht.
Oder war es amnesien oder war es Confusion?
Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Man konnte Turkpads easy killen.
Ink Hips?
Na geil.
Wo?
Okay, der muss sterben.
Wo ist der Heiler frei?
Da hinten.
Fuck, da muss ich hin.
Da muss ich hin.
Okay, keine Chance.
Alter, ich fass das nicht, Mann.
Der Typ soll sich mal verpissen.
Sag mal, ist der Heiler AFK oder was?
Der steht ja einfach nur auf dem Knopf.
Der steht ja einfach nur.
Wo ist mein Team?
Leute.
Team.
Nice.
Okay.
Wo ist mein Team?
Hier, haben wir gewonnen?
Haben wir die gebasht?
Ich glaube, wir haben gewonnen, Leute.
Wir haben das geschafft.
Ja.
Weil ich Pfeiffer den Heiler interrupted habe, würde ich sagen.
Sonst wäre das nichts.
Das wäre gut geworden.
Das ist das, was ich meine.
Man braucht ein bisschen Übersicht und ein bisschen...
Man muss die Gegnerklassen kennen.
Das hätte man doch deutlich besser machen können.
Ich hätte mir meine Shouts besser einteilen müssen.
Weil ich kann einen Heiler, der einen...
Oh, come on.
Die Nächsten.
Ich gehe jetzt raus aus dem BG.
Ich habe keinen Bock mehr.
Ist ja abfuck.
Es ist heilig.
Hyper abfuck.
Übrigens, wer sich wundert, warum ich nichts mache.
Ich kann nichts machen.
Ich bin blau hier unten.
Okay, dead.
Okay.
Ich würde sagen, es reicht jetzt mit Battleground.
Wir machen jetzt Frontier-Quests weiter.
Das sind mir ein bisschen zu viele Hips.
Und ein bisschen zu planlose Mids.
Aber gut.
Ich meine, man muss Fairness halber sagen.
Ich meine, die sind wieder mitten.
Wir waren noch mitten im Fight.
Leute tot.
Und...
Immer ein Frontier-Quest.
Ja.
Einen Run mache ich noch.
Einen Run mache ich hier noch.
Ich meine, wir könnten einfach die Quests machen, ja.
Wir laufen hier außen rum, machen schnell die Quests und hauen ab.
Aber nope.
Alter, Leute, hört doch mal auf zu fighten, ey.
Ich brauche Buffs.
Also mein Ziel ist heute eigentlich Level 40.
Oder zumindest in die Richtung.
Dazu kann ich mich nicht eigentlich mit BG sterben aufhalten.
Wir leveln zwar.
Aber wir könnten durchaus...
Was macht denn da Nick?
Wir könnten durchaus...
Wenn du...
Ach, wenn du ist er.
Wir könnten durchaus schneller sein.
Also hätte ich mir einfach nur hier 1L4 geholt.
Und hätte dann Frontier-Quests durchgecrindet.
Wären wir wahrscheinlich schon 30.
Okay, einen Run machen wir noch.
Train.
Bald könnte ich mir sogar noch SOS kaufen.
Aber da muss ich...
Longwind wieder wegspecken.
Battle Songs.
Erster Resi-Song.
Schwert.
Brauch ich nicht.
Okay, alles.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Resi-Songs.
Body Spirit Energy 8.
Na.
Das bringt es hier noch nicht so richtig.
Resi-Songs sind eh sehr situationsabhängig.
Auch später.
Übrigens, so nice ist Permanent Endo-Sprint.
Also Permanent Sprint.
Wenn man einen Charming in der Gruppe hat.
Der hat so einen Ausdauer-Buff.
Und mit Ausdauer-Reduce.
Wir können einfach unendlich lang rennen.
Wenn sie halt rennen würden.
Rennt halt, Leute.
Drückt Sprint.
Da vorne ist doch was.
Oh, da vorne sind wieder Mids.
Hips.
Ist das der Bade?
Ist das der Bade, den ich erwischt habe?
Ich hoffe.
Ich hoffe, es ist der Bade.
Problem ist, wir verlieren die halbe Gruppe.
Wir verlieren die halbe...
Die turnen am Berg.
Die turnen jetzt hier gleich.
Leute, wir sind viel zu...
Wir haben die halbe Gruppe.
Wir haben die halbe Gruppe verloren.
Alter.
The fuck.
Jetzt habe ich den Bade nicht mehr angeklickt.
Das ist so fail.
Ich muss vorne rennen, um den Bade zu interupten.
Aber, tja, jetzt ist es vorbei.
Leute, ihr müsst halt einfach den Sprint-Button drücken, man.
So schwer ist es doch nicht.
Okay, komm.
Wir hauen jetzt...
Wir kloppen jetzt schnell den Charming weg.
Hier, zack.
Bam.
Pass auf, die enden uns wieder, während wir fighten.
Ich sage es euch, die enden uns direkt.
Die enden uns direkt wieder rein.
Die warten schon drauf.
Die warten drauf, dass die rein enden können.
Okay, ich verteile mich schon mal.
Ich verteile mich schon mal, weil ich wette mit euch, die Inkenklei.
Die warten nur, dass wir fighten.
Okay.
Nichts zu sehen.
Jetzt machen wir Deserter.
Da oben sind garantiert Hips.
Oder die Hips warten am Deserter-Spot.
Ich würde auch am Deserter-Spot warten.
Die warten an der Seite.
Warten, bis wir Deserter machen.
Und dann gibt es auf den Sack.
Leute, ihr müsst doch einfach nur den Sprint-Button drücken, Mensch.
Okay, Leute.
Ich bleibe jetzt mal ein Stückchen weg.
Die kriegen die auch ohne mich gekillt.
Und ich will im Zweifelsfall den Typ interrupten, der uns gleich das Leben schwer macht.
Weil wir haben dies...
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, Kollege.
So nicht, du Pisser.
So nicht.
Habt ihr gesehen, wie er unseren Caster stelzen wollte, der Infi?
Aber nicht, wenn ich daneben stehe, Kollege.
So nicht.
Ink.
Ich bleibe auf dem Clary.
Oh, shit.
Nein.
Hilfs.
Okay.
Alps.
Okay, wir bleiben...
Oh, noch mehr.
Okay, wir sind dead.
Wir sind dead.
Wir können die auf die Alps vielleicht ein bisschen umlenken.
Alter, die Hips sehen alle gleich aus, dass da Bade auf dem müssen war.
Äh, zu viele.
Zu viele.
Keine Chance.
Machst du nix.
Dead.
Okay.
Da wird er...
Da wird er geaddert.
Er ist fucked, man.
Leute, die gehen im Chat gerade wieder ab, man.
Alter, das ist Battleground.
Du hast hier nix großartig.
Ich sag...
Also, ich sag euch...
Ey.
Es ist in Dark auch so, du hast so ein paar Leute, die können es über...
Die flippen immer aus, wenn sie mal sterben.
Und...
Bisweilen geht dieser...
Sag mal, die ist so alt.
Die...
Die rasten immer aus.
Und...
Ich...
Also, ich war früher ähnlich in Dark, ja?
Ich hab so auf übelst Elite 8 vs. 8 und alles ist kacke und so.
So richtig, so richtig Dark Elite Kack-Spaß.
War ich früher.
Mittlerweile bin ich viel entspannter, was das angeht.
Ich mein, hallo?
Das ist ein 20 Jahre altes Game.
Ein Game, wo absolut kein Hahn mehr danach kräht, ob du da drin jetzt abgehst oder nicht.
Außer für dich selbst.
Ein Game, wo wir froh sein können, wenn neue Leute reinkommen.
Ein Game, wo wir froh sein können, dass es überhaupt noch Server dafür gibt.
Es...
Wir sind doch auch 20 Jahre älter mittlerweile, man.
Wir sind keine 20 mehr, 18 mehr.
Und irgendwelche Rage-Kiddies oder so.
Ich versteh die Leute nicht, man.
Die sind...
Wisst ihr?
Ich...
Ich versteh's ja, wenn man irgendwie so 16 ist und so.
Und super competitive Multiplayer und so.
Aber...
Ey, die Leute sind 40.
Die sind so alt wie ich heute.
Gut, ich bin noch nicht ganz 40.
Die sollen mal ein bisschen...
Die sollen sich mal ein bisschen abregen.
Ich...
Leute, ich bin auch übelst abgefuckt von dummen Mitspielern.
Ja, das ist immer so.
Okay.
Nice.
Hoffentlich kommen die mit hier.
Ich bin auch übelst abgefuckt von dummen Mitspielern.
Aber die hier sind nicht dumm.
Die sind...
Die sind neu.
Die sind ein bisschen unkoordiniert, weil sie noch nicht zusammen vorher gespielt haben an sich.
Die vergessen zu sprinten.
Aber das ist Battleground.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
So nicht, Kollege.
So nicht.
So, ich muss gucken, wenn der Bade...
Fuck, der Bade kommt raus.
Der Bade ist dumm.
Der Bade hat geheilt, anstatt zu metzen.
Sehr gut.
Alter, kann mal irgendjemand die fucking Heiler interrupten?
Ich muss auf dem Bade bleiben.
Sonst ist...
RIP.
RIP ist sonst, ey.
Und wenn der Caster frei ist, ist auch RIP.
Okay, gut.
Gut.
Alter, ich kann nicht mehr interrupten.
Kannst vergessen.
Kannst du nicht machen.
Warte, willst du machen, ja?
Ja, das willst du machen.
Das sah aber schon ganz gut aus.
Ich sag euch, die Hips, das ist keine reine Random-Gruppe.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass da die einen oder anderen so drei, vier bestimmt öfters auch schon zusammenspielen.
Das siehst du denen auch an, weil die sich gegenseitig die Targets abruten und sowas.
Alpsink, Alter, das sind alle tot.
So.
Level 28.
Ich mache jetzt noch ein paar Front-Gitars.
Ich habe keinen Bock mehr auf Battle-Crowned.
Ah, guck mal.
Ach, das ist wahrscheinlich der Main-Scharf von Danik.
Okay.
Ich, ähm...
Ich porte mal...
Ich frag mal, oder wollen sie noch einen Run machen?
Ich frag mal, ob sie noch einen Run machen.
Okay, einen Run wollen sie noch machen.
Ah ja, gut, dann wollen wir mal nicht sein.
Wir haben uns ja nicht eilig.
Wie gesagt, wir sind ein 20 Jahre altes Game.
Wir können froh sein, dass es noch läuft.
Ist doch gut.
Wir sollten einfach nicht so sehr auf Elite-Krasse-Borgers-Gruppe machen,
sondern noch ein paar andere Mids mitnehmen,
weil, ähm...
Dann läuft es auch besser.
Man muss auch sagen, also die Target-Wahl der Leute ist nicht so optimal.
Der BD macht es ganz gut.
Wir haben auch zwei BDs.
Ähm...
Also ich kann nicht mehr machen als Bade-Truide.
Versuchen einen davon vielleicht zu killen sogar.
Sobald ein Caster frei wird, musst du eigentlich dort auch versuchen, weil sonst bist du tot.
Atheno, danke für den Sub.
Ansonsten, mal schauen.
Ich hoffe, die anderen Mids kommen mit.
Es wäre sehr nice, wenn die mitkommen.
Hopp, komm mit.
Middies.
Hopp, hopp, mitkommen.
Komm mit.
Helder.
Die Mids machen immer auf Elite, Mann.
Ist das WoW 2?
Äh, äh...
Alpha.
Moment, hier vorne sind Alps.
Ah, voll in den Quick-Cast reingerannt.
Aber pass auf, jetzt enden uns die Hips, während wir hier stehen.
In dem jetzt wäre Poggers.
Nice.
Sag mal, kam jetzt erst...
Atheno, kam jetzt erst der Sound, dass du subscribed hast?
Super lahm, Alter.
So, was müssen wir überhaupt noch killen?
Frogs?
Frogs müssen wir killen.
Dann lass uns doch mal mit den anderen Mids laufen.
Ist doch ganz easy.
Oh, die machen Bäume.
Ich mach keine Bäume mehr.
Ich mach keine Bäume mehr, Leute.
Ich hab genug Bäume in diesem BG gekillt.
Ich mach keine Bäume mehr.
Dann mach ich lieber Frontier-Quests.
Wie, Wasser-Buff?
Wasser-Buff?
Der hat keine Endo mehr?
Ah, der hat nicht die richtigen RRs gespeckt.
Alter.
Was ist hier los?
Der hat nicht die richtigen RRs gespeckt.
Und wie wär's mit Tauchen, Kollege?
Tauchen.
Hat keinen Bock, will gesehen werden.
War da oben was?
War da oben ein Gegner?
Kann das sein?
Ich hab's nur ganz kurz gesehen.
Nee.
Oder?
Sind die zwei Mids?
Frogs!
Jawoll, mach die Frogs.
Die brauchen wir für Exp.
Ach, ja, übrigens, in jedem See kann man tauchen, aber meistens ist da nichts drin.
Man kann super rumklitschen.
Mit Tauchen.
Weil die Leute eigentlich richtig hitten können, wenn man permanent ab- und auftaucht.
Also da kann man schon etwas nerven, wenn man es drauf anlegt.
Hab ich eigentlich Tokens?
Prima-Token.
Ja, da sollten wir mal ein paar abgeben vielleicht.
Wir können nicht turn-in, weil wir Albs sind.
Äh, nicht Albs sind.
Wem gehört denn das Keep?
Moment, wie...
Oh, ich hab vergessen, wie man das guckt.
Slash Realm?
Kennt man das so?
Oh.
Nee.
Okay, keine Ahnung mehr, wie man erkennt...
Ach, M?
Nee, ich weiß nicht mal, wie man erkennt, welcher Realm...
Why, hat er das hier nicht?
Battle Crowns?
Nee.
Keine Ahnung mehr, wie man erkennt, wer Battle Crown Keeps hat.
Irgendwie erkennt man das.
Ich meine, man erkennt es, wenn man ranläuft und sich die Fahne anguckt.
Was?
Gibt's Slash BG oder sowas?
Nee.
Nee, keine Ahnung.
Low IQ, richtig.
Kreiselgrind.
Braindead Kreiselgrind.
Übrigens, ich finde die Fantasy-Musik übelst entspannend im Hintergrund.
So, wo sind die Frogs?
Da unten ist ein Frog.
Dann haben wir die Quest fertig.
Quest.
Quest is done.
Ausgequestet.
Da vorne.
Hips.
Ein Solo-Hip.
Die Leute checken's wieder nicht.
Nope.
Perfekt.
Ah, der Lurikin-Schrei, wenn sie sterben, ist der beste.
Ja.
Boah.
Ich hab 4,5 Stunden über das Game geredet jetzt.
Ähm.
Also, es ist aus meiner Sicht...
Ja, wir turnen jetzt die Tokens in.
Ähm.
Also, es ist aus meiner Sicht das beste PvP-Game, was es gibt.
Sicherlich kommen jetzt die Leute um die Ecke.
Oh, aber Guild Wars, aber Elder Scrolls Online, was auch immer.
Aus meiner Sicht ist es das beste PvP-Game.
Und...
Ach, guck mal, da sind die Lapps wieder.
Die Lapps.
Guck mal, da sind sie.
Da müssen wir nicht hin, Leute.
Wir wollen doch jetzt nicht mit sieben Leuten das Keep raiden ohne Ramme.
Okay, wir haben den Siege-Giant.
Der Typ kann wieder nicht sprinten.
Ich meine, ganz ehrlich, ich nehme das.
Das BG geht bis 29.
Sollten wir das schaffen, nehme ich das mit.
Ich glaube aber nicht, dass wir es schaffen können.
Die Hexe wird einen guten Aemerts rauskriegen und uns bashen danach.
Ja, aber, ähm, also, es gibt einen Faktor, den Dark zum besten, also von den Voraussetzungen her, zum besten PvP-Game ever macht.
Das ist, weil es drei unterschiedliche Fraktionen gibt.
PvP-Game muss drei Fraktionen haben, dass es nicht unbalanced und nervig wird.
Das hat Dark gezeigt und viel zu wenig Spiele aufgegriffen.
Und man hat es heute schon so oft gesehen, die Fights wären einfach nicht gut gewesen.
Gebe es nicht drei verschiedene Fraktionen, ja?
Du addest in einen Fight rein, wo zwei kämpfen.
Du kämpfst, wirst von der Seite geaddert.
Du ziehst dich raus.
Du, ähm, machst nochmal eine Runde, gehst nochmal neu drauf.
Also, es gibt im Spiel einfach so viele...
Alter, was macht...
Ähm, what the f...
Was macht unser Siege-Giant?
Unser Siege-Giant will sterben, glaube ich.
Aber das hat keinen Sinn.
Kommt mal weg hier, kommt mal weg.
Das hat keinen Sinn, kommt mal weg.
Kommt mal weg.
Der Siege-Giant, was?
Wie der da rumbackt.
Wir müssen übrigens unbedingt...
Okay, ich gehe auch mal hin.
Wir müssen unbedingt die Wachen killen.
Weil der Siege-Giant stirbt schon.
Leute, ihr müsst ran!
Da können die nichts machen.
Oh Gott.
Die stellen sich an, the fuck, Alter.
Ihr müsst ran, da hinten werden...
Okay, ich hau jetzt auch ab.
Okay.
Wenn ihr euch unten ran stellt, können die von da oben nichts machen.
Wenn ihr euch natürlich in Caster-Range stellt, dann seid ihr dead.
Aber ich will mich nicht beschweren.
Wie gesagt, wir haben neue Leute in der Gruppe.
Man muss das alles lernen.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Herr Sarazene.
Fuck, der hat mein Metz resisted.
Der Kack-Noob.
Alle ran, alle ran, dann können die nichts machen.
Ich meine, ich rede mit mir selbst hier.
Äh.
Warum?
Warum greife ich eigentlich so langsam an?
Beziehungsweise, warum greife ich denn eigentlich gar nicht an?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Lasst euch nicht rausziehen, dann könnt ihr genugt werden von oben.
Sag mal, was ist mit der Vision und den...
Alter!
Was ist mit den Guards los?
Das ist ja nicht normal.
Die backen so krass rum.
Man kann die nicht hinten.
Guck mal, ich kann die nicht hinten.
Die sind nicht möglich, den zu treffen.
Das ist so krass verbuggt gerade.
Man kann die nicht hinten.
Okay, jetzt.
Jetzt, jetzt kann man es sehen.
Wachen geben übrigens auch gut, Exp.
Okay.
Jetzt erstmal langsam.
Ich mach mal Speed für die Heiler an, dass die sich besser positionieren können.
Hände hoch.
Haben wir eine Ramme?
Auf, kommt rein, Leute.
Oh, zu viele Alps, zu viele Alps.
Raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus.
No chance.
Keine Chance, keine Chance, Leute.
Nicht reinrennen.
Nein.
Okay, komm.
Sterben wir halt da drinnen.
Let's go.
Der Relikt-Dude.
Guckt euch, guckt euch das Elend an, Mann.
Man weiß es halt schon.
Man weiß es halt einfach schon.
Du flötest meinen Heiler nicht.
Weiß es halt einfach schon.
Oh, das ist ein Reaver.
Oder ein Heretic?
Wahrscheinlich ein Heretic.
Okay, weißt du was?
See you.
Ich bin raus, Leute.
Ich bin raus.
See you.
Also, ich mach nicht den Stream aus.
Ich hau aus dem WG ab.
Ich mein, noch ein halbes Level bis Max-Level, kein Ding.
Ihr könnt es euch aussuchen.
Ihr könnt es euch aussuchen, Chat.
Wir sind ja schon fünf Stunden am Start.
Also, ich bin da entspannt.
Ich bin auch noch eine Weile online.
Ach, die Stelle anzeigen.
Nein, mach ich jetzt.
Mach ich jetzt.
Okay, die hauen alle ab.
Dann hau ich auch ab.
Okay.
Ich guck mir das an, sobald wir in Sicherheit im Keep sind.
So, Leute.
Überrede die jetzt dazu, mit mir Frontier-Quests zu machen.
Da brauch ich ein neues Schwert.
Abgeben.
Quest.
Okay, wir machen ein F-Quest.
Wir machen ein F-Quest.
Ich muss jetzt mal gleich afk mir was zu trinken holen und was zu essen.
Aber erst mal, dass die nicht abhauen, die NF-Quests holen.
Okay, das können wir.
Ich sell das mal schnell.
Sell.
Oh, wir haben 100 Trinkets noch.
Krass.
Hätte ich das mal ingeturnt, ey.
Hätte nochmal ein bisschen Level gegeben.
Improved Necklace.
Dex.
Melee.
Parry plus 4.
Naja.
Haben wir da zum Vergleich so Magic-Spells.
Okay, auf jeden Fall das.
Eins ist besser.
Äh, zwei besser.
Was hat das?
Melee, Weapons.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Back.
Ring.
Äh, Strength.
Okay, das ist nicht schlecht.
Back.
Okay, mal gucken.
Im Viertelfall der Fälle.
Dass wir dann doch nochmal ins BG gehen.
Aber ich glaube eher nicht.
Ähm.
Hm.
Constitution.
Matter.
Strength.
Ja.
Nämlich.
Äh.
Okay.
Was haben wir hier?
Body, Melee, Weapons.
Okay, nice.
Next.
Let's go.
Ich bin mal kurz auf dem Klo, Leute.
Und hol mir was zu essen.
Afk, Bio und Klo.
Und dann, ich bin gleich wieder da.
Okay.
So.
Ich bin wieder am Start.
Ähm.
Wieder am.
Oder wie der Fabian früher gesagt hätte.
Wieder am Schlüssel.
Soll ich erst mal kurz ein Abbild dabei?
Ja.
Stellenausschreibung.
Ja, genau.
Wolltest du mir angucken.
Da unten ist was.
Moment.
Was wird die killen?
Tatsächlich.
Ähm.
Ausbildung.
Zum fachinformatische Systemintegration MWD.
Okay, wir gucken.
Ich muss bloß da irgendwie AFK hinlaufen.
Ohne, dass meine Gruppe irgendwie verloren geht unterwegs.
Ich brauch keinen Pod.
Das ist ein Schammy.
Ah, nee.
Das ist gar kein Schammy.
Das ist ein Bone-Tänzer.
Ups.
Ja.
Ja, ich kann halt schlechteres Lesen und Rennen dabei.
Das ist.
Es gibt noch offizielle Server.
Ja, ja.
Aber.
Das ist ein Community-Server.
Zum Glück.
Weil die offiziellen Server haben kaum noch Spieler.
So, hier.
Die müssen gebasht werden jetzt.
Okay, also.
Lass uns mal gucken.
Im Rahmen deiner Ausbildung beschäftigst du dich mit der gesamten Wahlpreis-Technologie in Stacks.
Die wir für uns groß finanzieren.
Okay.
Wow.
Das ist ja relativ 0815.
Kann alles sein.
Das bedeutet konkret, du erhältst Einblicke in nahezu alle Serverfarben mit Betriebssystemen wie Linux, Unix und Windows.
Haben die wirklich noch Unix am Start oder schreiben die das einfach?
Haben die echt noch irgendeinen Solaris oder HPOX?
Oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung am Start?
Kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Also ich glaube, das schreiben die einfach nur.
Ja, IBM Mainframe wahrscheinlich.
Ja, das kann.
Das kann schon sein.
So, haben wir hier noch was?
Aber irgendwo hier ist noch ein Gegner.
Ähm.
Ach, und auch Mainframe.
Steht ja auch da.
Und auch Mainframe.
Was soll man hier killen eigentlich?
Die da?
Hier, den sollen wir bashen wahrscheinlich.
Guck mal.
Äh.
Wo ist mein Team?
Team?
Ja, lass sie erst mal alles bashen.
Alles was da ist.
Alles was da ist, wird gebasht.
Okay, Frey-Dingsbums müssen wir noch bashen.
Ich muss jetzt raggen.
Und während ich ragge,
guck ich mir die Rest an.
Äh, Mainframe wird ein Bestandteil der Ausbildung sein.
Außer mit Netzwerk und Sicherheitslösung machst du dich unter anderem mit Middleware,
das ist auch so 0815 Begriff,
Datenbank und Bank fachlich in Applikationen vertraut.
Zudem beschreitest du mit uns den Weg,
zur digitalen Transformation unserer KundInnen.
MWD, hier lernst du verschiedene Cloud-Lösungen und DevOps kennen.
Ah, ist schon,
sag mal so, ist sehr vage, aber ist jetzt nicht, äh, irgendwie...
schlecht oder so.
Liest sich ganz gut.
Von den Farmen her würde ich fast sagen, Sparkasse?
Aber...
Das könnte auch die Bahn sein.
Lul.
Aber das passt ja mit Finanz wiederum nicht.
Guck mal, in Group geht es halt einfach gleich viel einfacher.
Das ist übrigens das, was ich meine.
In Dark ist halt einfach nice.
Wenn man grubbt, es geht, es geht so gut wie alles besser in Group.
Haben wir hier noch irgendwie Mobs?
Ich sehe nämlich nichts mehr.
Ey, keine Mobs mehr.
Wo sind, wo sind diese komischen Snowmen?
Ja, Snowmen wieder am Start.
Ich könnte auch Mana und Endu laufen lassen eigentlich.
Ich lasse Mana und Endu laufen.
Hier in Richtung Sparkasse.
Ja, von...
Habe ich hinten was gesehen?
Ne, ne, sind einfach nur Respawned.
Mobs sind Respawned.
Oh, kurz was trinken, Leute.
So, also, ich muss euch daran erinnern, wir sind immer noch im Grenzgebiet.
Hier könnte potenziell jederzeit ein Gegner vorbeikommen.
Allerdings, an der Stelle ist es nicht so wahrscheinlich,
da hier ein, ein, äh, Tor dazwischen ist.
An der Stelle ist es nicht so wahrscheinlich, da hier ein, ein, äh, Tor dazwischen ist.
Und da kommt eigentlich keiner durch, es seien dann alle unsere Festungen wurden erobert
und das ist ja nicht der Fall.
Deswegen alles Eats.
Oh, ich brauche neue Schwerter.
Und neue Armlinge.
Irgendwo hier ist angeblich auch noch ein Named.
Hier muss noch ein Named sein, der sich Prey oder Frey oder so nennt.
Weil wir da mal schauen müssen.
Was, Irish Sea? Wir sind nicht Irish Sea, wir sind...
Upland sind wir.
Upland?
So, und als nächstes...
Ah! Hier ist der Dude, oder was?
Ist ja kacke.
Da müssen wir in die andere Grenzfestung.
Okay, dann gehen wir mal zurück.
Alter, nicht da durchrennen!
Wie ich so Mobs hasse, die einfach random spawnen irgendwo im Weg.
Okay.
Okay, jetzt sind wir auf jeden Fall 30 gleich.
Und dann...
Können wir noch mal ins andere BG gucken?
Vielleicht?
PvP-Technisch?
Wir machen Frontier-Quests.
Der Typ hat keine Endu, Mann. Braun.
Ich muss dem sagen, dass er...
...dass er Longwind kaufen soll für mehr Sprint.
Nice!
Next! Next!
Next! Next! Ordentliche Quests!
Next! Next! Next! Ordentliche Quests!
Okay.
Äh, wo ist...
Wo ist Slashtop?
Äh, Slashtop ist irgendwie AFK.
Nee, Slashtop zählt gerade.
Okay. Nice.
Ein Cratesword.
Okay. Let's go!
Neues Schwert.
Kann nix schaden.
Oh Gott. Lass mich in Ruhe, Schneemann.
So, jetzt müssen wir aufpassen.
Denn, wenn man durch dieses...
Alter, Schneemann. Verpiss dich.
Wenn man durch dieses Tor geht,
dann...
...ist man offiziell so richtig im RvR-Gebiet.
Wo müssen wir überhaupt hin? Nach Osten.
Dann ist man so richtig im RvR-Gebiet.
Und jetzt habe ich das Problem,
jetzt müsste ich eigentlich...
Jetzt ist mal ein Problem.
Jetzt müsste ich irgendwie meine Position verstecken mit Chico.
Weil es gibt immer ganz tolle Leute,
die Streamsnipen.
Auch in Dark.
Für ein paar Graue. Pass mal auf.
Chico...
Chico muss größer werden.
Nice. Perfekt.
Leute.
Chico hidet jetzt die Map.
Riesen-Chico, ja.
Oh Mann.
Man muss halt was sagen, dass er Stickloss hat.
Sag mal.
Die sind ja alle wieder richtig planlos, ja.
Beim puren gerade Auslaufen
verlieren wir schon die Hälfte der Group.
Sechsen... äh, nee.
Dreiunddreißig
mit gelbem Speed.
Das ist übrigens auch der Grund...
Wisst ihr, was wir machen?
Nee.
Das ist übrigens auch der Grund, warum BDs
so gut sind.
Leute, ich habe eine Idee. Wir machen das anders.
Zack. Chico?
Du schrumpfst mal wieder.
Und...
Die Map kommt einfach über den Chat.
Ja.
Das seht ihr ja auch nix.
Wobei...
Man sieht genug. Man sieht genug.
Man sieht genug.
Man sieht genug, dass man uns findet. Wahrscheinlich.
Wenn man sich echt drauf anlegt.
Wenn man sich echt drauf anlegt, findet man was.
Aber ich meine, scheiß drauf. Komm.
Wenn es einer wirklich snipen will, ein paar Graue.
Was brauchen wir eigentlich?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, was wir alles brauchen.
Als Mobs.
Okay. Anscheinend alles.
Alles, was es hier gibt, brauchen wir als Mobs.
Okay.
Die Scrags brauchen wir nicht.
Nee.
Skeletons brauchen wir.
Skeletons.
Oh, nice.
I named...
Bogu.
Ja, Riesen-Chico ist wieder weg.
Ich glaube, Leute, das ist heute echt der längste Stream, den ich in ganz langer Zeit gemacht habe.
Bäume sind etwas im Weg.
Oh, nice. Wir haben eine Welt dabei.
Das heißt, wir haben sogar einen Heiler, der ein bisschen heilen kann.